uh good morning um members of the
committee before we start the hearing uh
hearings for the day just a couple of
well more than a couple of remarks from
my end of the the room I think we did
well our first year um assignment to
this committee has often been requested
by people who have had bad experiences
with the court and have come to
conquered loaded for bear that usually
doesn't work it's not worked well in the
past because others are out in the field
with their guns and sometimes they shoot
back at you and not only that some of
the Bears you're loaded for also are
armed I could make a pun about bearing
arms and arming bears but I won't so my
goal was to get us to work together
wherever possible by ganging up against
problems and not ganging up against
others and sometimes circles get squared
and when not we still disagreed without
being disagreeable most of the
time some of you first termers have
probably started a file now entitled
great speeches I never had to give
because you were ready for things that
didn't get pulled off consent and it was
voted in with a lot of other things and
you had a great speech ready um some of
us have a thick file of those don't we
yes
yes uh this year we're going to have to
work quickly because we have a lot of
bills including some that will likely
have hearings that will go from 1 in the
afternoon until who knows when so if
you've got a real question that no one
else has raised raise it but give it
briefly and if the subject has been
covered it does not need to be covered
again um it's not encouraged for you or
I to repeat what somebody else has said
and it's generally the policy for us not
to give
speeches during hearings but instead ask
brief questions they need to be
questions not speeches is disguised as
questions now I tend to be broader in my
interpretation of that rule because I'm
probably one of the flagrant disobey of
it but there's a point so we all have to
watch ourselves on making sure a
question of somebody testifying is RAR a
question we will start at 9:30 except
for those Tuesdays where there is a
Tuesday morning meeting for chairs and
vice chairs at which point we will start
at 9:45 or 10
plan on possibly going until
4 now there may be a few hearings that
may go on beyond that and you will
discover if you haven't already that a
lot of what people sign up to say has
been said many times they have a right
to say it we have a right to think I've
heard this a lot I've already pretty
well figured up my what I'm going to do
I will schedule things more tightly
um because we got to get things done and
I don't want to have to meet a second
day each week when I first came into the
house the committee I was part of had
about as many bills as we did last year
and we met twice a week it was a very
very loose schedule I would prefer to do
what we did last year and move as
quickly as we can um without rushing you
know I mean we can be On
Target at the end of a hearing unless
it's already obvious I will take a straw
pole of the committee that's a pseudo
vote that doesn't count and it will give
us a sense of what we could do next if
it looks like we are in total agreement
or almost like 15 to one we'll exec the
bill right then and there and vote
accordingly ought to pass in expedient
to legislate and send it off to the
consent calendar the speaker wants stuff
sent out quickly or secondly if it looks
like we're not in agreement and nobody
thinks we can really fix the bill by
working and working and working on it we
will hold the bill until an executive
session I'm planning one for the morning
of January 30th and there'll be more of
these or thirdly if if it looks like
we're not in agreement but we think we
could come to agreement we could get
that Circle squared if the bill got
worked on I'll hold the bill and ask
three or four people to go craft an
amendment we can all live with and bring
it back to the exec session the three or
four of you could either be a formal
work session and that will have to be
noted in the calendar or you might one
individual might decide to craft an
amendment on your own after having
discussed it informally with others keep
me in the loop the fourth thing we could
do is vote interim
study there's no vote for retained bills
in the second year because remember
retained bills from last year got voted
on last week well last week next year is
a new house the election is taking place
so there's no retain bills but interim
study means a workg group meets to
discuss the bill and makes one of two
recommendations only a good idea for
future legislation or not a good idea
for future legislation I personally have
never favored the interim study
route early bills these are bills that
have to go to another committee they
must be out the door by February 15th
our last meeting before then is February
13th the Tuesday which means they're
batting first pretty much here because
if we want to Tinker with them we'll
have to do that because the final vote
has to be out by the middle of February
we will not meet on February 27th that
is New Hampshire school vacation week
there is no session it's been announced
several times some committee chairs go
ahead and make committee meetings I
don't do that you're getting the week
off with your kids or grandkids in
enjoy finally no food or drink in the
room except water that means you can't
have your lunch here if you brought your
lunch you got to go down to the
cafeteria or somewhere outside of a
meeting room uh people again ask what to
call me I've wanted illustrious
potentate but that was shot down so I
like Mr chairman M the Mr chair is what
I sit on I like to be Mr chairman and I
like to honor others according to what
they wish to be called um just let me
know when asking a question of somebody
testifying first thank me and then thank
the person who is
testifying uh as in thank you for taking
my question and uh then off we go so any
questions procedurally as we start our
new year yes representative Nelson hello
Mr chairman hello
representative I just have a question um
I know that sometimes people are unable
to attend committee for the entire day
so um I completely understand your your
scheduling um and all of the process
that you just said um just curious if
someone would need to leave early for an
whatever reason um would we ask to have
a replacement for us for the entire
day Replacements are for the day not for
after 3 o'clock so because oh I'm sorry
can I follow up I'm sorry about that
thank you Mr chairman so um because we
will be having testimony and then
possibly exacting some bills then that
would just be the general course what we
would do we will exec them only if it
looks like it's going to be unanimous
where one or two people's absence
doesn't make any difference like we've
got a few people who can't be here today
and that's why if it was a controversial
Bill well I'm not going to execute
because it's not fair we didn't give the
opportunity for a replacement to come in
only if it looks like it's unanimous
because the absence of somebody won't
make any difference in terms of the vote
okay try to be fair any other questions
before we get
going
okay I'd like to open the hearing on
House Bill 1189 relative to criteria for
reporting child support delinquencies to
federal agencies and the chair
recognizes representative James Spain of
Deerfield the prime sponsor also chair
of or chairman of Fish and Game and is
that the correct title of it fishing
game and Marine
Resources but not Air Force or Army
you thank you Mr chairman and members of
the
committee before I start with 1189 I
want to give a heartfelt thank you to
you all for working so hard on HB 618 FN
which with your help after you retained
it uh was able to go onto the consent
calendar in pass last week I think it's
great that we're going to be letting
people know what their right is to work
together to handle their child support
when they have their final divorce
decree um and not involve garnishment in
the state um anytime people are informed
of their rights I think it's a good
thing HB 1189 I bring before you because
uh I had both bills I bring before you
now are going to look familiar because
they both were in front of you last year
uh HB 1189 was not passed last year uh
well the pre predecessor to it um in
that one we had tried to fix a situation
where I personally was denied a passport
renewal because my wage garnishment
doesn't line up with the payment
schedule that DCF was expecting um and
uh or Child Support Services was uh
expecting and when the request for the
uh passport was put down from the
Department of State in the federal
government it came back with a no from
New Hampshire because I was between $3
and $6 under what the total should have
been so we tried in the last bill to put
a dollar amount that would be the lowest
amount that someone could be in a re for
one month just to make sure or for one
payment sorry not one month one payment
uh since the payments are done weekly
and I think it was around $20 or
something something and we were argued
against that uh the opposition from the
Department um said that we already
follow federal guidelines for reporting
for the passport denial you'll see in
the handout I sent out on the second
page
um halfway down it says under the
passport denial program it states uh
certify cases in which an obligor owes
more than $2,500 in unpaid child support
the office of Child Support Enforcement
transmits the information to the
Department of State so that a US
passport will not be issued renewed or
someone is not uh to someone who's not
supporting their children now obviously
I was not $2500 in AAR I've never been
$500 in AAR but somehow my passport got
denied so there's a problem but the
department said they never report it to
the federal government unless it exceeds
that amount so I said fine if
that's what you're saying then I'm going
to put a bill in that says You must
follow the federal guidelines and in
addition the other problem when I called
the uh Department of State to find out
why my passport was being denied they
said well we can't see the dollar amount
you're inter for New Hampshire doesn't
report the dollar amount to us they only
tell us yes or no they're either in
they've either paid the amount they're
supposed to or more or they're in a rear
and it doesn't say what the dollar
amount is so part of this bill says they
must report back with the dollar amount
when they make that
report uh other states do report dollar
amounts New Hampshire does not so it's a
fairly simple bill you have seen it
before this iteration of it simply says
uh and I'll read it to you the
department shall maintain an automated
system of reporting child support aages
that complies with the federal
guidelines on child support
delinquency and that means if those
guidelines change we'll still stay
aligned with them which means that we
don't have to revisit this that's why I
wrote it that way and shall not report
as delinquent any aage that does not
meet the th Federal threshold this gives
us the ability to come back and say why
did you report it when you said that you
weren't going to and now you're in
violation of state law the system shall
also report the request to the
requesting agency the dollar amount of
the aage if the account is delinquent
and that will allow the Department of
State to look at it and say this isn't
more than $22,500
it's as simple as that that and I'm open
any representative Raymond I can see
your hand all right thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for coming um I have a question about
the
um the line 10 where it says shall not
report as delinquent any a rear rage
that does not meet the federal threshold
does this bill um mean that they can't
report it to anyone or is it only
specifically for the federal government
for the passport program because I know
in both the handout you gave and then
the our research handout um it talked
about how um child support sometimes
reports to you know collection agencies
they report to Driver's Licenses um and
that
threshold um seems to be different in
different circumstances so I'm curious
about whether this bill would prohibit
them from going to collection agencies
as well so by tying it to the federal
threshold that means whichever Federal
threshold you're talking about it should
have to align with that so if the
thresholds different for driver's
licenses that's the threshold that they
have to meet uh it's not specifically
saying a dollar amount here and it's not
specifically saying this is you know it
has to be $2,500 it's saying the federal
threshold so for any agency they report
to whatever the threshold might be now
if a collection agency or a credit hero
doesn't have a threshold then the
threshold
zero if a driver's license has a a
person has a threshold of of a smaller
amount than $2,500 then that becomes the
threshold for reporting we're saying You
must align yourself for reporting with
whatever the federal threshold is
because that's what they said they do
and I'm just going to try to hold them
to that but in addition I want the
dollar amount reported when that report
is made which is currently not being
done
any other questions representative
Bickford thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question oh you
haven't taken it yet but um it looks
like you're trying to uh put a check on
the system in other words you you said
it's an up or a down but this says when
you get the number figure that helps
them understand if there was an error
correct okay and the Department of State
told me that they could not override it
because they didn't know the dollar
amount so they couldn't finish
processing my passport if it was in
error because they didn't know the
dollar amount so I had to actually work
with the state pay them five or6 dollar
to get it to zero and tell the Federal
Department of State again now run your
check and please do it before the next
processing time because then it might
fall in misalignment again um and I can
for anybody who wants to see
it's personal information so I don't
want to just throw it out there but I
can print out how my uh deductions from
my pay equal out throughout the year I
get paid every two
weeks the Bureau of Child Support
Services expects a payment
weekly so at certain times in the year
I'm in a rears at certain times I might
be slightly above by the end of the year
it equals zero because the way the work
calculates that they say here's the
amount he needs to pay at the end of the
year let's divide that over all these
pay periods of every two
weeks and then that's what they take out
of my
paycheck unfortunately since I'm not
paid weekly it doesn't line up exactly
with the payments and that's why I'm in
this situation and I'm sure that anybody
who's paid in other ways it misaligns as
well so um I could show you how halfway
through the year I'm always in AAR when
I add those up but by December It lines
up again it's just just because of the
way that those payments hit on various
months that have various pay periods in
them every month doesn't have two um and
it's just you
you I see no further
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the
committee and the chair recognizes Lee
day Koski uh from the Bureau of child
supports she
provide good morning Mr chairman thank
you and good morning uh members of the
committee um my name is Lisa
dekowski I am the uh bureau chief with
the Department of Health and Human
Services
Bureau of Child Support Services and we
are the um program that
administers the child support program
under the Social Security Act title
Roman numeral 4D uh for uh here in the
state of New Hampshire um and I am here
today just to provide some information
in relation to House Bill
1189 um it was unclear to the department
uh specifically what uh this proposed
legislation was in fact seeking to
accomplish um up until hearing um
representative Spain speak to the intent
behind the bill this morning um so I
want to thank you for the opportunity to
just speak uh to this briefly um you
know the department uh takes the
position that we are already uh in
compliance with the title 4D uh
reporting requirements for Federal
collections uh the code of federal
regulations under the title
4D um Act is uh pretty prescriptive in
terms of uh ensuring that we have
federally certified automated systems to
which I will speak to our New Hampshire
uh automated system is a federally
certified system um that um already has
programmed in all of the programmatic uh
requirements that our federal
collections programs uh requests for us
to
submit um to um both the federal offset
and the federal passport denial program
um
so um again um want to assure the
committee that the uh current system
that the state of New Hampshire has in
place uh for child support services
meets all of the very specific
regulations um specifically uh outlined
in the code of federal regulations um
307 um and
um uh the specific guidance that our
federal office of Child Support Services
Division of federal systems provides to
us uh for technical guidance um so in
circumstances uh as it was spoken to the
division of federal systems provides
states with very specific technical
guidelines and data elements to which we
are required to provide uh for both the
federal collections offset program as
well as a passport program to meet the
eligibility thresholds um at time
certain and um we are currently uh in
compliance with that um so I would be um
happy and available um one of the data
elements that we do provide within our
data file is the aage amount um the
federal threshold for uh eligibility for
um passport denial is um uh an
individual's a reage amount in order to
be included in that file must
demonstrate uh an amount of $2500 or
more um the federal threshold um and
that indicator is then uh sent within
the data file that we send to the
federal office of Child Support
Services um so with that I will just uh
want to again just reassure the
committee um that our system is already
in compliance with these rules we are a
federally certified system um and
certainly if there were
um any questions that the committee may
have I would be uh happy to answer them
any questions from the committee
representative D
Simon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my
question I I full disclosure I am a uh
co-sponsor of this bill um my question
to you is uh since it it is your
statement that you are in full
compliance this bill will not change
true again as I stated rep thank you
representative ton I appreciate the
question um again currently we are uh
responsible to providing the federal
government with the data elements that
they uh ask us to do and we are
currently in um uh performance with that
so
um if I don't see that
this
um since we're already in compliance
with our automated system as prescribed
by the federal government um I don't uh
I I would be concerned that we would be
um uh again the federal government is
the entity the office of uh Child
Support Services is the entity that
requires tells us what to report to them
so I certainly would want the department
to ensure that we maintained uh
compliance with whatever they requested
us to provide for data elements uh for
their system
processing I'd like to give the followup
could you answer that in one word please
yes will this bill change anything or
not one word thank you Mr chairman for
the question
see Vice chair long thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
questions uh with respect to uh sh
maintain an automated system you already
have that maintain that automatic
automated
system thank you for the question
representative long yes we are maintain
an automated system
correct okay can I follow up Mr follow
um I want to go back to representative
uh Raymond's question as it pertains to
the uh shall not report as delinquent
any arage um as it pertains
to as it my understanding is has it
pertains to the federal request only is
that yours does this affect any other
reporting of a
reage within your agency not necessarily
to the feds does this bill change any of
that language or do you or are you
seeing this as as it pertains to the
federal
request thank you representative long
for the question um the way that it is
written speaks specifically to Federal
thresholds um that is how I would
receive that information would be
specific to Federal threshold that is
certainly how representative Spain spoke
to that um so that's how I read it okay
thank you and one more one more uh with
respect to data
elements the feds request information
you give them information somebody's
$1,000 behind on a
rage
um now through testimony uh it was
stated that it was a minimum amount owed
uh however they went after their
passport um and that's out of your hands
that you know have you heard of the feds
taking your
information um that they requested and
uh going after licenses or uh uh
passports for under the
$2500
minimal thank you for the question
representative long um I am not aware of
any of those circumstances that you uh
referenced I would like to clarify if I
could that um the file in which we the
bureau sends to the federal
collections um office uh is there there
are several Federal thresholds depending
upon the federal enforcement remedy uh
that we submit to in this particular
circumstance um a file is sent routinely
to the office of Child Support uh
Services federal office of Child Support
Services
wherein uh cases that meet the federal
threshold for federal tax refund offset
the federal thresholds for eligibility
for aages in those cases are in
circumstances where Public Assistance
arear or also known as tanif arear um
that is
$150 in AAR at the end of the um at the
time of submission and in nonpublic
assistance also known as non- tanif
aages that is a five $500 Federal
threshold so when a case meets that
eligibility criteria that file is sent
with that amount that amount will change
based on what the aage amount of the
case is in a passport denial situation
with the federal passport denial program
again I just want to clarify that that
threshold is 25 00 or more so that will
only that indication will only go to the
passport Deni program when that
particular case meets that aage
balance I would like to clarify though
that once you are once a file is
submitted to the federal passport denial
program it is not automatically
removed from the Federal passport denial
program the individual that was
submitted must then work with the state
agency uh to that submitted them to
remove that indicator from their
passport denial or from their passport
um
status um once the aage balance for that
in uh case reaches zero
in the federal passport denial program
the indicator is automatically removed
and if there are circumstances where
there may be discrepancies the state can
work with the office of Child Support
Services and the passport denial program
to assist an individual to address uh
any potential lag or concerns in
indication okay thank you thank you
chair recognizes
representative
grman thank you Mr chair just a follow
up to that um qu your response what
state agency would the individual work
with if their passport has gone to that
Federal passport program and they need
to work with the state program what
office would they work with thank you
representative rosan for the question if
we as the uh Bureau of Child Support
Services was the state agency that
submitted those child support aages it
would be with our program that that
individual would work directly with
thank you thank you okay representative
used to be Molton now is Gibbons correct
hi thank you for T what did you get for
Christmas I know um thank you for taking
my question so you seem pretty neutral
on the bill would you recommend that we
passed this bill or would you recommend
that we um itl
it thank you representative Gibbons
that's yes I'm changing my name but yes
it's in the process uh representative
Gibbons for uh the question again um you
know the department uh takes yes a
neutral
standpoint um as to whether uh the
committee um chooses to pass this bill
or not I just want to assure um the
committee that we are
currently um in compliance with what we
are regulated to provide as prescribed
under the title 4D program here for the
state New
Hampshire representative Greg thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for being here
and for taking our questions we
appreciate it I just in going back to
you know it it comes down to this is
kind of a neutral thing but if process
is already being done the necessity to
legislate something such as this when I
don't think that we've had an
overwhelming um number of them but back
to the root of this if uh somebody who's
paying child support is having it it
seems like if if this is the way that it
is where it gets paid every week but the
individual only gets paid every two
weeks then it's a system where it's set
up for them to be in AAR aages um is
there is there a way for them to adjust
that like if they get paid every two
weeks I mean obviously the person with
the child the bulk of the time has the
expenses all the time they don't have
you know expenses only every two weeks
but is there a way to combat that so
that we're not setting somebody up for
failure in a rear
edes thank you representative Greg for
the question um the answer is is that e
each case is taken into consideration on
its own merits every case situation uh
fluctuates differently uh so our case
workers um are trained to look at the
nuances of particular case circumstances
to determine if there are circumstances
where there may be
um uh timing concerns in relation to the
amounts of the obligation versus the the
time of the payments so we do to um have
procedures in place that our case
workers will look specifically at those
types of circumstances to ensure that if
there are any manual exclusions that
need to be placed uh on the case uh
record that that can be done
so you want to follow up followup thank
you for the followup so just to make it
clear then if there there is a way to do
this so you're not set up to constantly
have Rees every year there is a process
where you can fix this correct thank you
again representative cig for the
question uh yes there are circumstances
where uh our case workers will look at
individual case circumstances and
determine whether or not any types of um
exclusions may need to be placed as
prescribed by the uh guidance that we've
programs representative
ball thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um I actually
have two now because I wanted to follow
up on that question do the um people in
the department look at the situations
the individual St in situations before
or after the situation occurs in other
words do you already have um you you
understand what I'm asking sorry thank
you representative ball for the question
it's a continuous review process our
case workers are are constantly uh
looking at the uh case circumstances
right at the onset of the case when
we're putting our orders on the system
and when they are passed to our child
support enforcement officers for review
and maintenance so we routinely look at
cases and are triggered to look at cases
at a variety of different um uh uh
junctures throughout the case so it's a
continuous re view but yes there are
circumstances where we receive Direct
Communications from our constituents who
are asking us to look at certain
circumstances to which we will also do
at that same time follow follow up and
before I would ask the witness please to
be brief her in her words we don't need
long drawn out answers that can be as a
given in one word or one phrase please
representative ball thank you chairman
and thank you again um so the question I
now have is is I'm understanding you to
say that the federal to be in federal
compliance you report if it's $2,500 a
reage to the
passport but if it falls below the 2500
why is it still being reported because
it's no longer meeting that threshold
I'm not understanding why it would stay
on um as being a a
flag thank you representative ball so to
be submitted for the federal passport
program the aage balance has is
triggered by the $2500 aage so once your
aares meet $2500 or more if you're
submitted within the file you're
submitted to the passport denial program
so it's an eligibility
criteria but when it falls below that
when the next payment comes in why is it
still remaining that's that's the the
point so when he got down to $3 to5
dollar because of the twoe um pay period
um why wasn't it removed at that time
because it know no longer met that
criteria or the threshold I should say
thank you representative ball the
policies and procedures in relation to
the federal passport denial program uh
indicates that the uh once submitted to
the passport denial program the
individual must reach out to the state
agency to uh have that removed because
in order to be removed from passport
denial your rear balance has to equal
zero
and that's part of the federal policies
you representative
Panic thank you chairman for taking
allowing me to have question um and
thank you for taking my question if the
requirement is
$2500 in the rare to be put into the
passport denial program and if
representative SP only was in the rears
$5 is and you're say telling us that
everybody in your agency is following
the guidelines is there a
possibility that there was
a data breach a computer hack that would
list thank you for the question
representative Panic um I'm not quite
sure how I can answer that question
question um I would say uh no uh I'm I'm
not aware of any concerns related to
that um and I don't know that that would
be a circumstance however
no thank you the question the answering
all right my question thank you for
taking it if I understand representative
Spain's not only testimony today but
last year that he was in a rage a very
small amount and that the feds did not
know how
much where is the problem is it his
faulty memory is it what you did or did
not send or is it the feds can't figure
out what you appropriately did send
here thank you representative Pearson
for the question um I think it's a uh I
think the problem lies in understanding
how the data flow Works between the
state the federal office of Child
Support Enforcement and how that
information then gets transmitted to the
Department of State for the passport
denial
program the state agency submits the
files for aares and federal thresholds
to the office of Child Support
Enforcement Services the office of Child
Support Enforcement Services then sends
an indicator to the Department of State
that handles the passport program that
an individual had met the threshold but
they I don't believe send to the
Department of State the aage
amount that is maintained between the
office of Child Support Enforcement
services and the State Child Support
Agency so it could be in fact and um I
don't have those specific details of
data elements in front of me but that
could be that the department of the US
Department of State that handles the
passport process just know knows that
the child support program has submitted
an individual for the passport denial
program and then they ask the individual
to return to the state agency that
field any other questions yes
representative ball thank you chairman
Pearson and just one last question um I
just wanted to know when these um
notices of a rear ages go to other
agencies do the people who are in AAR
are they also made aware that the other
agencies have been been told that they
are in AAR in other words if somebody's
applying for a passport would they know
that they could have corrected this
beforehand or that there's going to be
an issue or is this something that after
six weeks of waiting for their passport
they then find out oh my God I have to
pay $5 and then we got to go go through
the whole process over again when do the
people find out that their name has been
submitted into an agency um because of
aages thank you representative ball uh
the Bureau of Child Support Services
does provide notices and uh information
to our uh obligor that are paying child
support services the federal offset
program also sends out a
pre-offer collections a reage amount and
you've been submitted to the program you
will receive that initial notice as well
as an annual notice to be informed of
that representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman so if in
the individual's case where the
individual was not in a rear of
$2500 or
more which did not
meet the federal requirement would that
that person receive a notice of a
reement a reage as well because the
person that we're discussing did not
receive such
notice thank
you thank you representative deimon for
the question if I understand the
question that you're asking um anytime
an individual within our program is
being um submitted or if any enforcement
action is being taken uh within our
Authority the individual is provided
notice uh our program does require us to
send multiple notices uh more than one
time in some circumstances to try to
engage with individuals again I cannot
speak to specific case circumstances
naturally um every case is taken uh you
know that facts of each case is taken
into consideration so uh but on a
general basis again we absolutely notice
our uh customers of any and all actions
that were taken in their cases at a
variety of different times throughout
welcome Vice chair long thank you Mr
chairman
uh would your Bureau be able to look at
those that go in a reage knowing that in
December in their payment plan they're
going to be paid in full and not have to
submit those to the
feds thank you so in this case it was a
reage because of the monthly payments uh
and I think why would that have to be
reported to the feds if in December I
know it's going to be paid
for thank you representative long I
believe the short answer is yes we could
uh pre-identify cases that would be um
uh approaching um uh collection uh you
know uh approaching a full obligation um
you seeing nothing further thank you for
your testimony the chair
recognizes uh The Honorable Betty gay
she asks for three minutes we're running
minutes representative Spain was never
in
$2500 a
reage that shows that there is a problem
with the system it sounds like a
software problem because as
representative Greg pointed out all only
in weeks only in weeks that end on the
weekend are a payment going to match a
whole
week everybody is going to be in a reage
every week not
$2500 but they will be in a reage if
this software is not uh modified so um I
think this bill will cover for that
builtin reage by requiring the reage
amount to be input only if the software
$2500 I'm going to gather as a person
with a technical bachelors's that it's
always a good idea to have the real
numbers somewhere stored in the data so
if somebody wants to ask a question
about it from another angle they've got
it there for instance when uh when when
representative Spain was trying to deal
with the federal government to free up
his right to have a a
passport apparently nobody ever
discussed a reage amounts and if this is
an automated system then the automated
system has to get fixed otherwise it was
verbal and they never asked how much
he's in a reage they just said is he in
reage they said yes so we can fix it we
can fix the software or we can just
require that the amount is always
available to be considered when the
question is asked but again if it's an
automated system my opinion is the
software has got to get fixed or people
are going to be in a reage almost 52
weeks a
year any qu any questions for The
Honorable Betty gay any thank you for
your testimony thank you I'd like to ask
a question of Representative Spain
please before I do a polling of the
committee to see whether we want to
exact this bill as
presented having heard chairman having
heard the
testimony might this committee wish to
consider an amendment that would add
some toughening language to what we have
in front of us because the longer I
heard the assertions of how we so
frequently review the case how we are so
careful in doing this and yet here is
the problem there is a problem and it is
your problem because of someone else's
problem do you think it would be
advantageous to what we're trying to do
to um perhaps have an amendment to
toughen this bill Mr chairman there
there appeared to me to be some areas
that make obvious some of the holes in
the system during the
testimony uh that may not be addressed
by the bill as it's written so you may
want to consider that for example I can
tell you that um in the testimony I
heard that notice is given to the person
that they can correct it before they
apply for their passport renewal if they
exceed the
threshold in my case where I didn't
exceed the thresold and I don't know how
it got triggered into that system I
never received notice and I actually had
to send my passport back back to them
with the payment that passport was no
longer in my possession so even though
it was good for six more months I still
was banned from traveling waiting six
weeks for their reply and when their
reply came and said now you're in a
rears you need to talk to them I had to
trigger calling the SEC the Department
of State then calling the the Bureau of
Child Support Services here in the State
trying to figure out what happened I had
to actually uh pay the $5 or so to the
Bureau of Child Support Services then
wait 20 24 hours so that it would be
processed by their system and then tell
the secret Department of State please
process it again now because it should
be zero
now and none of this should have
happened um in addition I heard that
while we review these cases for special
situations it doesn't but yet the
software is automated so whatever
triggered the software and sent the
notice out happened before they may have
reviewed the case the cases are not
being reviewed prior to it doesn't say
all right here's a trigger now let's
look at that before it gets sent because
it's automated so what's happening is
it's being triggered and sent
automatically and then if there's a
problem they'll review it but every
single one of these
triggers because of the situation
they're in where more and more people
are being paid not on a weekly basis I
think there's probably a lot more people
than me that may be hitting these
thresholds maybe they didn't apply for a
passport port and they didn't realize it
and things zeroed out again but it's
going to happen again and it's going to
happen again because these triggers
should be reviewed or the software
fixed would you like to work with one or
two of us in this committee on a
possible amendment to be brought forth
by say January 30th our exec session I
would be happy to I see a question for
you though yeah and it's it's not a
question as much as it's a statement uh
that's going to try to look like a
question that um violates what I read
earlier um that since the department has
stipulated all the good
things but they didn't
happen for
us articulate them is not an insult in
the slightest because they maintain
they're doing it so we're just asking
them to do things they they're already
doing right in their opinion that's why
I drafted the bill the way it
is but yet it looks like it may need a
little bit more
teeth
perhaps yes
representative
Rosman thank you Mr
chair I'm just a little concerned that
we're legislating to a specific case
right now we don't have other cases of
people coming forward we haven't had any
other cases come forward with this
problem it's up to the individual that
gets into aers to follow up with the
passport that's the trigger even if it's
at $3 but at some point it triggered to
go into AAR so the only person we've had
coming forward is representative Spain
and I'm really uncomfortable with
legislating this way okay thank you
comment okay that will conclude this
thank you for your time hearing and I
will not move this to exec and uh you
can be in touch if you wish with one or
two people if you wish and that is our
right to do so this ends the hearing on
Bill
1189 and we now open the hearing on Bill
1111 and it is the penalty for false
reports of suspected abuse and neglect
made to
DCF and the chair recognizes the prime
Spain
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee this bill will look very
familiar because this is the exact same
bill that you passed out of this
committee and we passed out of the house
and sent over to the Senate last
year uh the Senate decided uh the the
chair of the senate committee decided
that uh she was going to interim study
it um I will tell you that I had two
different phone calls from the chair of
the committee asking me questions
I spoke to the governor about the bill
and he was in support of the bill I
spoke to the department and they were in
support of the bill in fact the old
director of DCF helped me draft the
language of that bill which is why we
passed this out in the exact same
language you're seeing before you now
last
year my intent is to put this in front
of the Senate
again because I'm going to uh keep
pushing them to try to to stop
especially with all of the news lately
about the the lack of resources for dcyf
to stop allowing people to weaponize the
system with false reports and and give
people a free get out of jail card so
that they don't have to do anything at
all for making a knowingly false report
I believe our bar was very high when we
passed this out of the house we said not
only does it have to be knowingly false
but it has to be done with intent to
harm it's a very high bar it Exempted
all mandatory
reporters and uh I I passed around as
you'll see a uh
reminder that approximately 28 states
carry penalties in their civil child
protection laws for a person who
willfully or intentionally makes a
report of child abuse or neglect that
the reporter knows to be false we're not
breaking new ground of those 28 States
states such as New York Massachusetts
California all have this law it's it's
not a a freebie to go ahead and make
false false reports of child abuse or
neglect against people it's not uh
something that comes without penalty if
you're chewing up DCF resources for
false complaints our DCF department is
understaffed and has enough to do they
don't need to be chasing down false
reports constantly from people who just
have a beef with somebody and the
department should be able to Levy some
sort of penalty against someone that
they find repeatedly doing that and as
as was brought out in the testimony last
year in order to prove that bar of
intentional Report with intent to harm
it's probably not going to happen the
first time
but once that person has made multiple
reports over and over again of unfounded
reports the department can take action
at this point and the department can can
Levy something to to show that person
they shouldn't be doing that and I think
that once the example is made you'll
find that people are unwilling to make
that false report because they've seen
what
happens and so I ask you again to pass
this as you did last year out of this
committee so we can send it back over to
the Senate and hopefully convince them
that this is the right way to go and
I'll take any questions any questions
for representative Spain on the bill
1111 representative
bigford thank you Mr chair um I've
almost gotten through what you passed
out um but this is about penalties on
people
that um do not
report that that's the first part down
the bottom um let me find the exact
paragraph for you I highlighted it on my
sheet but it didn't copy so the
Highlight didn't come through
um it is almost the end of the uh
paragraph on the first
page after
uh after the section about mandatory
reporters who fail to report there is a
section that says approximately 29
states carry penalties in their civil
child protection laws for any person who
willfully or intentionally makes a
report of child abuse or neglect that
the reporter knows to be defaults it's
right at the very bottom and I can I can
show you my highlighted version so you
better thank you H oh thank you
um I follow up Mr
chairman yes thank you and thank you
um what is the penalty in New Hampshire
there is none for not reporting for not
repor in uh I would actually direct you
to the chair for that because I don't
know I haven't been following the the
but as as I know the chair is a
mandatory reporter he might know what
the penalty for not reporting is I can't
tell you uh I can tell you that for for
falsely reporting there is no penalty in
New
Hampshire I've never not reported when
it was a case where as a mandatory
reporter I had to so it never concerned
uh Mr chair you want to follow up yes Mr
chairman follow up thank you Mr chairman
well I thought we were all mandatory
reporters now that we had passed
legislation sometime okay technically we
are technically okay thank you thank you
too I'm sure the traditional mandatory
reporters are much more aware of that
than everybody who lives on my street
yeah exactly I believe that most people
if you ask them on the side of the
Street right now they wouldn't even know
they're a mandatory reporter it's just
not a well-known thing and they
certainly wouldn't know what the penalty
is for not reporting um however they
there's a lot of people out there
apparently who know that there's no
penalty for falsely reporting because
it's being weaponized and it's happening
more representative Gibbons thank you Mr
chairman name plate to follow that's
right
um whether or not all adults were
mandatory reporters my profession is a
mandated reporter profession and the in
the training that I've always gotten you
have to have a
suspicion of abuse or neglect in order
to report just a suspicion as a
mandatory reporter but that's completely
different than just making something up
so there's no penalty for reporting a
suspicion because you would have to have
some something that
um gives you that suspicion you have to
have some type of fact you know the kid
has has bruises all over them something
like that
um as opposed
to um as opposed to you know just making
something up the kid has bruises and
they don't have them so to answer your
question um I've
never heard of what the penalty is if we
don't report but we just don't really
want to risk our licenses so you know
there's always that
so thank you
Mr thank you Mr
chair with my Christmas present of
lateral Vision I now call on
see I turned it off thank you Mr
chairman and thank you uh representative
for being here so um I do know there is
no penalty in New Hampshire for not
reporting um I used to practice in New
York um for DCF and they do have
penalties there was a very famous case
out of Westchester where some guidance
counselors failed to report sexual abuse
and they went to jail for it so um I
guess my question
is are you interested
in copying the rest of the the states
that have laws like this where we're we
penalizing people for falsely reporting
most of those also have a penalty for
failing to report because failing to
report is more serious to the you know
health and well-being of a child than
somebody calling you know because
they're mad at their neighbor so I guess
my question is did you consider or would
you consider um having that be part of
the bill if we're if we're copying other
states on one half of the the problem
thank you for your question I absolutely
would I thought there was a penalty in
the first place as well as several
people who are have been traditional at
atory reporters for a long time we all
thought there's something that will
happen to you if you fail to do it um so
I think the assumption that there was
there was some teeth behind it was
always there and I would say that's a
critical thing too we we should have uh
when there's a suspicion it should be
reported absolutely but when there's
somebody making something up there
too to follow that up if if I'm
following the train of thought correctly
uh do we
know that a mandatory reporter and I'm
going to use that in the narrow sense
not the way it is on the books in New
Hampshire but the ones who are likely to
do it licensed uh professionals who are
mandated to report like myself um and we
don't do it do you know one way or the
other whether there's a penalty I do not
testimony from your representative said
there is not and I'm getting this from
other sources up here saying there isn't
would we like to do that here I would
welcome that and maybe that'll help get
it through the Senate maybe so um let's
consider okay any further questions for
representative Spain representative
Nelson thank you Mr sorry thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um just to be clear this um
Bill does not mandate someone give their
name it is it is optional to give your
name and you can still report
anonymously is that correct correct
thank you correct that language was uh
agreed upon by the director of the dcyf
program when I worked with him the old
director I have not yet met the new
director former director former director
that's right we're not going to put age
into it um both of them are in good
middle age category so yes the former
former director and uh we worked for a
while to make sure that language gave
them the ability to to
encourage names for followup so that if
there were questions they could follow
up because um there's a a problem with
following up with a lot of anonymous
reports as well that the department said
and they would like to encourage but not
make it banned
so further questions for the prime
sponsor seeing none the chair would like
to call the middle-aged but not old um
director uh Jeffrey fiser from dcyf to
come
up
Williams good morning uh chairman
Pearson and members of the children and
family law committee this brings me way
back in time I'm looking for represent
David Bickford I first appeared before
this committee not with a fancy
microphone in front of you back in 1999
so that's far I go back with the
committee uh for the record I'm the
legislative director for Health and
Human Services and with me today is uh
good morning Jeff fler director DCF and
uh want to thank you and the committee
uh responding to refm Spain as you
probably are aware we as an agency do
act as a resource to committees and we
certainly have a hand in drafting
legislation I've not I was not involved
directly with those conversations but I
was involved with at least uh
discussions with Joe ripson regarding
the Department's position around the
bill uh Joe was here as a resource to
the committee to provide information to
the committee um uh however the
department did not take a specific
position on this legislation last
session uh so if there was some
confusion I apologize to the committee
and also to represent Fain uh but the
department hadn't taken a position on
the bill I also understand that director
ripson former director also was looking
at other state jurisdictions that have
similar legislation as that proposed
here here uh before the committee uh
with that said um there are concerns
around the issue of the chilling effect
for reporting and children's safety and
that is at least one of the the
considerations that I we believe that
this committee needs to consider when
thoughtfully putting forward such
legislation I know that was an issue
when the bill was heard uh in its former
iteration in the Senate uh and one of
the reasons that I believe that uh the
committee did not uh move the bill
forward for consideration and with that
I'll turn it over to our current
director to introduce himself because
he's a newer face to you uh maybe not
since 1999 but he is a wonderful
addition to the department so this makes
you old John Williams then uh not as old
as the Director and composer but yes the
Williams yeah just a correction I'm no
longer middle-aged but I think I'm old
old old old age now so just a correction
for the record but uh yeah yeah we have
a lot of confidence in our Central
intake that's screen out you know if we
feel calls are not legitimate or um not
to be uh filed up or to screened out
we're well trained in that um and we're
also fearful that if penalties are put
forth it may discourage people from
doing their Duty as mandated reporters
into report so that's just basically it
um uh again we're pretty comfortable um
with uh with how things are working out
now and Central intake is um Al
overwhelmed uh has been noted um they're
they're experts at at deciphering what's
not if I could ask a clarification these
are my words but I would ask if they
would be your words too that if we let
it be known that there would be
penalties for intentionally false
reporting it might scare away some
sincere reporters thinking uhoh if I'm
wrong I will be penalized even though
because they're sincere they wouldn't be
it would scare them off is not what I'm
hearing yeah so that's be our fear and
what we're doing now working on a
resource guide for people to report in
uh suspected abuse neglect abandonment
and this will be a guide a computerized
guide for people um to guide them into
how to report what to report and then uh
if they feel it's not risen to the level
of reporting um they'll also be
available for services we're going to
have uh Community guides who will help
connect people with services to get to
the families that that are in question
um so there's some systems a lot of
systems that are being built now um to
really help people report
accurately I would assume that there
would be a section in this wouldn't
there be that makes it a question um
that would say if you sincerely believe
and have a reason to sincerely believe
then don't worry if we later investigate
and find out that you you were there
sincere yeah yeah yeah I mean that's
that's it John did you want um uh very
very uh good question there uh chairman
Pearson there is already in the RS
andard the chapter
169c uh immunity from liability when
they created the reporting system and
the legislation it's been on the books
for many many years now if not decades
uh relative to providing a level of
immunity because they were balancing the
interest of protecting children versus
the concerns and fears of people making
reports so uh I believe your concerns
are addressed currently in the RSA
follow up then if that be the case uh
and I would believe you um then wouldn't
the malicious false
reporters uh be quite different and we
would want
to try
to minimize that because I know from
working on Family Court matters that
sometimes people weaponize false
reporting wouldn't that yet be still a
concern now that you have let uh the
people who are sincerely reporting know
their immunity question
mark um drawing on my former experience
back in the early 1990s from Rockingham
County when I was an assistant County
attorney uh in court matters where
individuals uh falsify information
regarding material facts before the
court there is a class B felony uh at
least it was at that time I don't
believe it's been changed for um uh
perjury or providing false information
uh so I would imagine that there are
some boundaries in current law not
reflected necessarily in RSA 169c but in
other areas of law that would prevent uh
individuals from coming in falsifying
testimony uh at a court proceeding then
would it not be a an easy matter to use
the same language about falsifying of
testimony under
169c that is a policy consideration for
your committee I do think it's important
uh to recognize the concerns regarding
the chilling effect for making reports
because you're actually asking the
individual to process another level of
concern relative to putting the Child
Safety First that's a consideration that
can that you should take into account
the other one is is the stakeholders
that are out in the community those
people who are the mandated reporters
typically from either the school setting
or from a clinical setting like the
pediatrician's office that we want to
make sure that the laws that are in
place which are currently in place they
they they are working in terms of people
making reports the concern is that by
changing this law and penalizing for
false reports under current statute uh
that it could create a Ching effect for
balancing interests of protecting
children versus concerns for for making
those reports and I think that's the
concerns that we're trying to articulate
without taking a specific position
because the policy determination is
within the hands of the legislature on
this
issue representative de
Simone thank you Mr
chairman welcome back welcome again
director fleet Fleet I'm sorry I knew I
fer we've had this discussion for the 16
years I've been here
almost every year and and I think that
it's really um something that would
could help the committee or but it will
definitely help me I'm not going to
speak for the committee there's a big
difference between falsely reporting
and reporting something that you think
is neglect and abuse but according to
law it truly is not you're reporting
something in your heart of hearts you
believe that the child is being hurt by
this particular Behavior but you're not
false reporting can you talk a little
bit about the difference between false
reporting and reporting something that
turns out not to be abuse in someone
eyes yeah I mean that's a that's a great
question and um uh you know that's our
challenge you know when a call comes in
our intake at first through the phone
and questioning and hopefully now people
using our resource guide to determine is
this the law is this you know legally
abuse or neglect and that's what our
people do every day and again they're
well trained in trying to decipher that
the idea of people abusing that and and
weaponizing it um it's not something
that comes to has not come to my
attention since I've been here um uh
it's not you know T targeted as an issue
for us or as something that's
problematic and again I think that has
to that's attributed to to the way we
screen calls and um and then when in
doubt we get out there we investigate
and we see for ourselves what's going on
um so you know I I think that's the
important part is that are we equipped
to to uh go out there and really tell
the truth from from falsehood and the
other thing is we are making efforts now
to make it more clear for reporters on
how to how to report and sort of guide
them uh to screen out those that are not
uh legitimately abused or
neglect thank you and thank you Mr
chairman representative
panck thank you chairman for allowing me
to ask this question uh with regards to
false reporting there's a very good
reason why
um you would want to have the person who
is making the report to identify
themselves because when you're doing
something like when you're doing a
serious allegation of child abuse what
happens to the person that you're
reporting and if it isn't true what
happens is they lose their second
amendment rights this I know has
happened it happened to my son and he
lost his gun ability to have his guns
for a whole year based on a false report
so I think it's very important make it a
question so how do we protect that from
you and uh chairman Pearson uh in
addressing uh represent panic's question
um one of the things I think you have to
take in consideration is the scope of
the legislation in front of you in other
words the four corners of the do of the
bill and it's a threshold about the in
the report to the central registry in
other words abuse neglect what happens
in the real world when there are either
divorce actions or actions involving
custody of children as we know there are
a court actions so that's another layer
well beyond just the initial report
trying to make a determination if a
child uh if an investigation needs to be
looked into uh many of the reports we do
get are uh unfounded and we close out
the case accordingly and of course those
of you who have been doing this for year
years uh knows very well about the
thoroughness of that system because we
certainly worked with this Committee in
terms of retention of records and and
whatnot so I I think we would be ill
advised to try to get into the mindset
of a specific court case uh certainly um
there are safety valves in terms of uh
appealing uh Court decisions uh there's
also judicial conduct uh Council if
there's a question regarding the judges
uh in their Ethics in terms of a case
but I think that's beyond the scope of
what we we're going to be able to answer
for you today represent
Panic one more question followup yes
followup question thank you uh my
understanding is that
95% of these cases are false reports and
what they do is they try to air on the
side of safe out of safety concern which
I totally understand that so I mean it
we can't always tell when somebody's
lying so how do we
that's why I don't think it's a good
idea to keep fall I don't think it's a
good idea to have um it the tips brought
in
anonymously I move to a question oh
thank you I this is for exact sessions
good stuff but all right thank you and
I'm talking to myself when I say that
welcome representative ball thank you
chairman I'm just going back in my
memory it has been a year so if you
could refresh it um perhaps I remember
we had testimony and I thought it
pertained to this about 10,000
allegations per year is that a correct
number or somewhere around
there um don't know the it's about right
um but we we screen out about 50% and
that's what I I'm asking if you could
confirm because what I remember and if
you could confirm this was that there
was about 10,000 and it Whitted down to
to about a th000 and then ended up at
around I think around 400 um that all
had to do with um alcohol and drugs so
is am I recollecting that correctly from
the last year's it wasn't you who has
testified so I'm yeah I'm just wondering
if those are accurate numbers now we'll
get back to you on that I'm here five
months but uh we're in the in the well
above 10,000 calls we screen out about
50% or so um
and uh I don't know as far as the the
connection between drug and alcohol um
so we'll have to get back with you on
those that at that thank you thank you
very
much any yes representative
McMahon thank you Mr
chairman Mr
Fleer relative to what you stated
earlier is that you have staff members
that take calls from
complainants that are uh offering
testimony that there is abuse taking
place and that you have 100% confidence
in the determination on whether it's
real or made up on the result of these
calls on whether uh action should be
taken does that mean yes yes okay then a
followup followup thank you Mr chairman
uh then would that thereby make this
bill
moot um yeah
I'm have you read the bill I've read the
summary of the bill oh the summary but
not the bill itself right well that's
then unfair to you I thought you might
have read the bill uh your guidance is
very important right here is in reading
the full Bill and in comparison to what
is happening now under your direction uh
that you're responsible for do we need
this bill or not yeah again based on the
summary and I don't know if John has any
other um more in depth but we would say
there's no need for the bill that's what
our current uh assessment would be and
and between both of you who's the
authority having
jurisdiction well I will readily state
that I not only read this bill but every
other bill that's coming before your
committee today so uh with that uh I
think again it's a it's a policy
determination if you feel this is
necessary I think you can tell from our
testimony to that we have concerns uh
around the bill and I would have to
leave it to you to determine whether or
not this bill is moved based upon our
current practices uh to the uh people at
the witness table a follow up to
representative McMahon's question about
uh great certainty in screening out Tru
and false allegations is one thing for
you people to proceed I think the heart
of the bill goes to punishment of those
people who hurt others by making false
accusations so to
stipulate your well-trained staff I've
only met a few of them and I was very
impressed um is one thing but the
punishment of wrongdoers is another
thing and I think the bill goes to that
point uh you're
agreeing we can do
it I director yeah don't bunk your heads
well that would be just the other
concern would be if there's these
penalties that that's that the public is
aware of would that keep them um from
those that are well-meaning of reporting
is you know that the danger of them
being okay accused of reporting
irrespective of how great the new
document is going to make it abundantly
clear that they have immunity people can
read it and not get it I understand I
work in the legislature yeah thank you
any other uh
representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I am thankful
that you are here and always here and
your valuable resource to us
um is there any data that um backs up
what we're talking about um so maybe Pro
in states where there is a penalty for
false reporting is there any data that
you can point us to um for those States
like amount of um
amount of reports prior to amount of
reports
post and how many um people actually
penalized that is a great question and I
don't have that answer we we'd have to
look at those other
states and I was going to say and given
the amount of work that your committee
researcher I would be uh remissed if I
even suggested for her to be looking
into Miss Dyer to to to that question uh
perhaps the National Conference on state
legislators might have a similar uh kind
of a document something Shelf ready out
there that would address it but that's a
great question in terms of looking at
the image before and after uh post
legislation in terms of either numbers
of reports um um around that matter um
so hopefully that's something we
continue to work on rent
Nelson having never met anybody more
eager to write term
papers
and doing such a wonderful
job I bet we'll have that information in
a few weeks or at least a little bit of
it enough to guide us
representative who else
ball thank you Mr chairman so in reading
the bill I mean this bill specifically
says that it would be a misdemeanor but
it would have to be malicious or intent
so it would be a repeat offender it
wouldn't be the first time someone calls
that would be the way that I am reading
this in understanding that that's who
we're really this bill is really
targeting um in order to I mean you just
testified that 50% of the cases that are
brought
forward are not they don't have any
validity to them or they're not enough
to go forward so knowing that now in
reading the bill that this is only
intended to go for those people who are
weaponizing a system and that they would
have repeatedly um done this and you can
see a pattern of Behavior would that um
change your mind in trying to uh curtail
that in order to also protect the
parents and the children who then have
to be investigated to find out that this
was really a malicious attempt to um
hurt the family with that change your
opinion on
this and rident Pearson uh drawing again
my prior uh background as being uh
criminal law attorney in uh Rockingham
County ass assistant County attorney
prosecutor um this matter if you're
going to put in a a provision in there
for a misdemeanor that's a criminal
offense uh we as the agency that are
doing the screening of cases uh to
determine whether or not the information
provided either meets a threshold on its
face of Prim ofasa child abuse uh that
would be our particular role if this
case were to be referred to a law
enforcement agency it would go to
whatever uh presumably either conquered
police State Police somebody would do
the investigation into this matter the
word malicious intent they're getting
into when you're doing a criminal act
and I'm loving looking at ripson Pearson
because he's caught up on more seasons
of uh criminal law uh and should
probably already be an honorary jurist
doctorate himself okay uh that uh that
in the mindset of malicious intent I
mean the word malicious if you just look
it up in a dictionary would mean evil
Bad whatever kind of intent it's not
talking about repe conduct of that
individual it's so whatever their state
of mind was at the at the point of time
that they actually did the act and in
this case the ACT would be either in
communication orally verbally or through
written communication providing false
information for the purposes of
obviously deceiving um you know folks
about the actual circumstances around
that child our our goal here is as an
agency at least under current law is we
don't make those assessments of who's
telling the truth we have to allow the
the process to protect children so if
somebody makes a claim of something that
on its face would be child abuse we
would be required to looking into that
matter investigating it there would be a
secondary if this law were to pass a
secondary process that would occur under
the criminal justice system uh relative
to whether or not they met the threshold
of the misdemeanor offense which would
include the mental state or Mena that's
fancy word that they pay to go to law
school to get Mena mental state uh of
malicious intent but it wouldn't
malicious intent in of itself is not
repeated
conduct everybody got that that's that's
yeah that's good I got more law books
for Christmas but I haven't gotten to
that one yet representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you again for taking another question
for me uh my
concern with uh whether the department
is accepting this bill or not is the
difference
between false purposeful false
reporting that that would have an
adverse effect on someone's life and
lifestyle
MH and currently the department having
no teeth
whatsoever in pursuing the false
reporter so if I were to call and I did
call once it it wasn't because I was mad
at somebody but I called because
I I heard parents using four-letter
words in front of their 2-year-old
continually and I thought oh dear God
now the two-year-olds running around
saying those words because they're all
Miner birds and I thought oh my God that
is such bad behavior turns out it wasn't
child
abuse but I was doing it for the right
reasons but we are hearing all too many
times parents being being raped over the
Kohls for supposedly abusing their child
because a family member or a friend of a
family member wants them to pay dearly
for the divorce or separation or
whatever wouldn't you
say that it would give the
department more teeth to have a bills
like
this that that gave a provision for the
person to be punished for falsely
purposely falsely reporting child abuse
or
neglect yeah well again
um 50% or so uh that calls that we get
from well from well-meaning people most
of them uh pan out not to meet meet the
stat states of abuse neglect like the
the parents cursing in front of their
child that wouldn't meet our
statutes um we are um making every
effort though even for cases that don't
meet abuse and neglect we're offering
services to that to that family and and
also that reporter to know that these
services do exist and there's any way we
can get them to the family as far as
again this this has not been a problem
that we that I've seen that my staff
when I talk about this spill um uh has
said this is a problem and yeah this
would help us that that's not come from
my team um so I'm not equipped to answer
that at this point um it's just
something that that we're that's um not
come to our attention and again we're
doing everything we can in training and
getting the right people the right
amount of people and now with a new
community resource guide to really make
sure that we're not uh allowing people
who are maliciously reporting um to
affect those lives of that family uh
we're doing everything in our power to
do that I don't know I don't have any
evidence that a penalty would help or
not
help anyone
else seeing none thank you so much and
uh director I am older than you and
still consider myself middle AG I don't
know we'll have to get our driver's
license
out do you have a Hampshire driver's
rean now we're way over time this was
very hopeful but we are way over time
and I'm looking at several cards who say
they would like two or three minutes and
we are going to go to the three minute
rule so with that representative Alicia
leus has asked for three minutes and the
clock starts once the microphone it is
on and once you say your first
word thank you for having me here my
name is Alicia leus I represent
Hillsboro
38 I'm here to tell what happened to me
based on a false and malicious call I
lost my granddaughter for 14
months my daughter-in-law came from
Seattle where she did not need a
driver's license cuz she always took
public transportation and when she
married my son and was pregnant she came
out to New
Hampshire um she decided once she was
having to get rides to work that she
needed a driver's license and
um was she had a babysitter during the
days while she was working and was
paying somebody privately to give her
driver's instruction and she by the time
that was done she would arrive at the
babysitter's house after my
granddaughter had gone to bed
my granddaughter
was approximately 6 months old might
that so she said I'm not going to wake
her up to take her home just to bring
her back in the morning so she made
arrangements for three days for this
babysitter to keep her daughter so she
could finish getting her driver's
license
training and in the meantime a relative
of the person who was babysitting was
jealous of my daughter-in-law and
believed that her boyfriend was visiting
my daughter-in-law when in fact her
boyfriend had gone to school with my son
and was going over and my son and and
her boyfriend were hanging out together
but this girl being jealous reported
that she was
abandoned and
neglected so she was uh my granddaughter
was taken away from the
babysitter
um 14
months 14 months of a time when a
child is really bonding with their
parent 14 months they put they in the
process my son and my daughter-in-law
broke up over
this they put them through all kinds of
trainings that they had to go through
they told my daughter-in-law she had to
get a youth bed that because the baby
had grown larger and could no longer be
in a crib even though the crib could be
you know dropped down and the bars
dropped down and used as a bed or um a
single bed which my daughter had which
most people graduate kids from a crib to
a to a you know regular twin bed no they
made her get a youth bed just all kinds
of things she had to do and finally at
the court at the court decision they
said no harms were done my
daughter-in-law and Son were not guilty
of anything and return the
baby except then they charged them fees
for all of any expenses occurred during
that time when they had taken her
all because of a malicious report that
hadn't you know that was malicious
you've got 30 seconds to wrap it up
please and so consequently my
daughter-in-law ended up leaving the
state because she couldn't afford to pay
those penalties couldn't afford to pay
all of those expenses when she had done
nothing wrong and that person who made
that report should be deter other people
like that should be deterred from making
similar reports so this is something
that happens thank you would you take
any questions sure from the committee
any questions from the committee
um Mr chairman yes representative
bigford thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question um the
things that
dcyf I'm going to say
recommended um were were they not a more
safety situation for for the
child you said about the expense you
said it was a great it sounds like you
you meant it to be a great expense to
make these changes or upgrades of a bed
anyway you mentioned and I'm asking with
the upgrades uh because they felt it
would be a safer for the
child I actually don't know why they
recommended a youth bed most people
don't have youth
beds the expense
that they charged her for the person
whose care they put the my granddaughter
in got a job and had to
um had to pay for child care while she
went to work and they put that expense
on my daughter-in-law when she got her
daughter back made her pay for all of
that child care during that time which
she never would have incurred on her own
okay thank you
thank you I have a question
representative thank you for taking it
uh I'm trying to get a timeline here or
um an action
sequence this report by the jealous
person was made to
DCF who then presumably screened it
between false and true the 50% we heard
and thought it had Merit to
proceed um was there testimony given to
the
investigator that this W the facts as
you stated was that the boyfriend wasn't
distracting the gal the boyfriend was
with the Son and the gal the babysitter
was actively doing her
responsibility was was that testimony
was there an opportunity for that
testimony to be given by your family we
had no idea who made the phone call
until after we got the baby back was
there an opportunity for you to give
testimony according to the statements
made
anonymously um certainly my granddaugh
my daughter-in-law you know explained
what the situation was when they
contacted her but the baby was already
gone they took her from the babysitter
not from my do daughter-in-law they went
to the babysitter while she was staying
there and took her and my daughter did
not her daughter-in-law did not know
until she went to pick the baby
up um and this was dcyf that did this
yes and when you started learning more
information was it then welcome for you
to say to DCF wait a minute this is this
is false like I said we it it was much
it was after the baby had been returned
you know over 14 months later it was
later that we found out who the person
was who made the report we had no idea
and it was afterwards we found out who
made the report and why and by then my
daughter-in-law had already taken the
baby out of the state but presumably my
followup is that when the baby was uh
taken away from the babysitter's
custody did they give you a reason why
NE um abandonment abandonment and they
and neglect and
neglect and were you able to give a
response you were someone able to give a
response to that at that
time
um there was a lady who was the guardian
adidam for the baby and we were able to
tell
her but I never got to testify no no not
until we went to the court case which
was 14 months later when they finally
returned my granddaughter that's when I
had a CH the opportunity I personally
had the opportunity to um to talk to
them therefore I would ask does it seem
plausible that word on the
street that that jealous person has now
been prosecuted for FAL reporting at
Great cost emotionally to your family
word on the street would prove a
disincentive to others who might do that
I would hope so yes thank you any
further questions representative Raymond
I just
um thank you Mr chairman um isn't it
true that here in New Hampshire DCF does
not have the authority to remove
children only judges and Court can make
that
order
I actually do not know any of those
rules so that would be something I would
hope you would
happened representative panic I know the
answer to that
question if I can
answer would we be persuaded by your
testimony
that can I that's a question I made it a
question so go ahead
thank you chairman
um representative Raymond um my
son had custody of his his child and
there was a false report that the
mother
made and um before it even went to court
they got the police to my son's house
and
removed my grandson from my son's home
and we didn't see see that child for 8
months not until we went to the Sea a
gotting it lit him and had to Hash it
all out and so no they don't need to see
a judge first they just can go in there
and sweep them up I guess thank you for
that testimony of your experience anyone
ball would you believe that when I was a
casa they did take the children from the
home
um in in that particular case it may
have been warranted because um there was
drugs in the house but there was nothing
going forward they just showed up and
took the
child well given that that's what
happened to my granddaughter I certainly
would believe
that so I'm hearing is it fair to say
representative that there's due process
is not in place here it's there's a
there's a problem it is believed to be
valid
the baby is immediately removed and it
may take going to court there's no 48
Hours by which it must be justified or a
hearing be held or anything like that
it's a long time that's was my
experience yes okay thank you anyone
else representative Bickford uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you um I'm curious
how old was the babysitter and how long
happen um the babysitter was middleaged
I
think which is slightly younger than uh
director fleser and me
exactly um and it happened a while
ago over 20 years
ago okay thank you so I don't know that
um the the reason I ask is because
there's been a lot of resources that
have been directed to DCF in the last
I'm going to say five years so I just
wanted to get a feel for that thank
you any other questions seeing none
thank you so much for your testimony and
taking questions
again in the three minute rule um thek
chair recognizes uh Gail drat to come up
for three
minutes thank you Mr chair members of
the committee for letting me testify
today during the special committee
investigating the New Hampshire family
courts um former Commissioner of DC wife
did testify and he said just north of
20,000 calls are made to Central intake
just North the 10,000 are weeded out and
approximately 10,000 are assessed for
needed services or allegations of abuse
and or neglect and they count in the
hundreds how many actually go to
court this tells me there is a problem
with false reporting or um also the
parental rights Foundation has
referenced a federal statistic roughly
83% of child abuse or neglect reports
investigated ultimately prove to be
unfounded or unsubstantiated and when
reported anonymously the number Rises to
96% too often reports are made out of
spite or to gain an upper hand in the
court proceeding weaponizing the system
the false reports further harm innocent
children and families by a way of
obstructing the relationship between the
children and the targeted parent and
interfering with parental rights and
responsibilities of that parent during
an investigation period the child often
times is obstructed from from seeing or
having a relationship with the targeted
parent this holds true for large numbers
of false reports of domestic violence to
gain an upper hand in the court
proceeding again weaponizing the system
and causing unnecessary
delays the investigations can often take
months if if the court is involved child
parent contact may be obstructed for
months if not years prior to ever being
convicted of child abuse or neglect a
parent may be put into a central
registry which can add adversely affect
a parent's ability to find an adequate
employment or simply Chaperone a child
School field trip when these actions are
done maliciously and with with ill
intent there needs to be a remedy to
address such actions implementing this
bill would be a step in the right
direction I may suggest changing the
word may to Shell further protects
parental rights and limits government
interference and changing the word from
May to Shell would change the the
reporting to confidential reporting
rather than Anonymous reporting this
aligns with the 2021 Health and Human
Service task force of the American
legislative exchange Council as they
voted unanimous unanimously to endorse
model legislation to require
confidential reporting to child abuse
hotlines thank you so much uh do you
have a copy of that testimony you could
give to the clerk later on yes thank you
so much that's that's some good
information
witness seeing none thank you for your
testimony chair recognizes uh Mr Robert
minutes the clock starts once you hit
button
now you have to hit the talk button
great thank you all right I don't know
if you can hear
this his name is Robert
kangu b a n g u a
y and what's his do you know his date of
birth actually we don't know his date of
birth no this is the domestic violence
Coalition calling on and then where is
currently October 31st he in the
legislative office building and he's in
the children and family law committee
room which is room um 206 through 208
must be like an auditorium
style I would ask you to could you keep
this to the bill it is to the bill um
he's come across we're across the street
in the state house so he's come over to
our building yeah
um so
that's the domestic violence
Coalition um after they invited me to
their place to report well I by Paul
English I wanted to
um get some help with domestic violence
in in my case in my family false reports
of domestic violence and then un
unanswered uh domestic
violence doesn't matter what laws we
what happens uh really here matters what
happens in the courts courts don't
pursue any of the crimes such as perjury
as the gentleman did mention which is a
some laws which I actually been looking
up I've done a lot of reading been
through a lot of pain and I've been
before you you all and I do appreciate
your
standpoint and um so one of them that's
very relevant uh so we got title 4 d
That's What funds the state it's
actually like a about $16 billion fund
across the country um where States
compete on a competitive basis by
issuing child support orders and that
funds our state
federally to tune about a half a billion
dollars you know that's that's my
understanding of it section 401 of 42
USC
has you have one half minute to wrap it
up thank you has reasons for um getting
child support uh the purpose of this
part is to increase the flexibility of
the states operating the program to
designed to provide assistance to needy
families so that children may be cared
for in their own homes of relatives two
to end a dependence of needy parents on
government benefits by preventing uh job
preparation work marriage uh
reduce the incidence of outof wedlock
pregnancies four encourage the formation
and maintenance of two parent families
section 4026 certification standards for
Fraud and Abuse and that includes it all
the way at the
end now Mr Tang is we've gone three
minutes and 15 second so I will ask one
bill I I do support the bill um part
part of the bill oh no that's it I gave
you three minutes I gave you an extra 15
seconds so um thank you for your
testimony and I do I do have the shut
off button here so thank you you may u
go back to your seat now and the chair
is yeah I do all right the chair now
recognizes Jane Bergeron from a special
I think it's a special
administrator from
n e
a I'm sorry
158 well it's okay we'll we'll look
forward to you coming up I see no more
cards on um
1111 I'm going to do the straw pole and
the only right way to put your thumb is
the way you believe do you want to move
into exec session now or not an up thumb
no okay so we will hold on to this for
two or three weeks and um representative
Spain if there's anything you wish to
work on in the remaining three weeks or
in fact anybody else wishes to the only
criteria is an amendment must be
presented by a member of the committee
doesn't have to be written by an
amendment a member of the committee so
thank you very
much and let's take about 30 seconds or
paperwork
the hearing on House Bill 1111 is now
concluded and I now open the hearing on
House Bill
1425 prohibiting the suspension of
driver's licenses in child support
enforcement matters and the chair
recognizes representative Bernardi the
prime
sponsor thank you Mr chair JD Bernardi
Rockingham 36 Hampton Falls Kensington
Southampton Newton plastow here to
sponsor House Bill 1425 FN an act
relative to prohibiting the suspension
of driver's licenses in child support
enforcement
matters all 50 states have statutory
administrative Provisions authorizing
the suspension or revocation of various
licenses for failure to pay child
support the license affected are gener
only driver's licenses but also
occupational professional business or
recreational licenses like fishing and
hunting each state imposes its own
criteria for the amount of arear the
obligor or the person owing the child
support must owe for a license to be
suspended and the amount of time that
must they must be delinquent before the
suspension
occurs related Provisions include
procedures to Halt the revocation
proceedings reinstate licenses and issue
temporary or restricted licenses in
recent years some legislators have been
easing up on license restrictions that
would impair the obligor ability to earn
income or otherwise meet their parental
obligations for example 15 states in the
2020 ncsl report allow for temporary
driver's license if the suspension would
prevent the obligor from traveling to or
from work parenting time or religious
Services some states allow for temporary
occupational professional licenses while
administrative or judicial reviews being
conducted are or have largely abandoned
the use of the suspension power alog
together a 2020 report by Dartmouth
Rockefeller Center for Public Policy and
social sciences note that in the
previous
five years 22 states have passed
legislation to reduce license suspension
for non-driving offenses by varying
degrees license suspension itself is
derivative of the child support
enforcement program enacted in
1975 by a federal program under the
infamous title 4D of Social Security
Act the program is designed with seven
major functions on behalf of children
locating absent or custodial
parents establishing paternity
establishing child support orders
reviewing and modifying child support
orders collecting child support
payments Distributing child support
payments establishing and enforcing
support for children's medical needs
child support collection methods used by
state agencies include income
withholding interception of tax refunds
interception of unemployment
compensation leans against property
reporting child support obligations to
credit bureaus interception of lottery
winnings sending insurance
settlements uh enforcement in
information to agencies and authorizing
seizure of a assets of the debtor P
parents held in public or private
institutions and finally the authority
to suspend or revoke driver's license or
other professional
licenses all this were were part of the
96 personal responsibility work
opportunity reconciliation Act and the
act as President Clinton noted if you
flee across state lines and refuse to
pay your child's support you will be
charged with a federal fenal penalty a
federal felony offense and land in jail
for up to two
years under current New Hampshire law a
driver's license may be revoked for
three classes of offenses not related to
motor vehicle
operation one default or non- compliance
for payment of a fine two drug or
alcohol offenses and three failure for
child to pay child support but as the
Dartmouth report I referenced earlier
indicates suspending a revoking a
person's driver's license has collateral
consequences limiting an individual's
means of transportation can seriously
affect employment status income level
Public Safety and child care
options many offenders particularly
those in rural areas may find them self
with no alternative but to drive on a
suspended license if stopped by police
while driving they could be charged with
another misdemeanor or a Class B penalty
pen uh felony in addition to further
fines the department the Dartmouth
report further indicates by analogy
because there was a lack of concrete
information from our division of motor
vehicles or the uh Department of Health
and Human Services that a suspended Li
in a state uh about 50% were for failure
to pay the
fines various fines 40% for failure to
appear in court two and a half% for
failure to pay child support and 1% for
drug
offenses note that nothing in this bill
prevents the state from using driver's
license information to track down
failing those failing to pay child
support it only only prevents the
suspension or revocation so that the
party can maximize their opportunity to
earn the monies they need to pay that
child support
debt now let me review a one case of one
of our legislative colleagues The
Honorable Jason Janan of
seabook he's been without his licens for
four
years yet all his child support payments
are currently are are presently current
he lost his license without notice that
should not have happened he ran a truck
driving
business that business was destroyed
with the last lack of his license and
four other people lost their employment
business it's been a long bumpy road but
he obtained other less Rumer to
employment has his has his uh child
support current but through another
Comedy of Errors associated with false
tickets and whatnot uh it it is it is
now he is now at the point where he
should finally renew get his license
renewed at the end of this
month meanwhile the state has lost
considerable revenue from the loss of
his
business so finally let me turn to that
fiscal note that's at the end of this
bill I believe the impact of the State
Highway fund Revenue listed as
68,000 needs to be compared to the
279 million or the 45 million including
Turnpike monies that the state
receives in uh in its in its
taxation this is a d Minimus amount
compared to the harm done to the
individual's ability to to earn a
reasonable living in order to pay child
support
obligation and as I noted it further
discounts the additional State monies
lost because of depressing the earning
capacities of those so uh
inhibited with respect to the likelihood
that New Hampshire would be fiscal
fiscally and financially punished for
making changes to its laws I remind the
Committee of the comments I made earlier
that nearly half the states in this
Union have already taken action to
reduce the impact of this honorous
penalty without any adverse
consequences thank you and I'm ready to
take any questions any questions for the
representative representative Gibbons
thank you Mr chairman um so I do like
this bill because you're absolutely
right with the logic where if if you
take away someone's ability to go to
work then how are they going to pay
their child support my question is that
it it also makes sense to me for there
to be consequences for someone who's
who's actively trying to avoid paying
child support so um so the question that
I have is if someone was to and you may
or may not know this maybe someone else
does if someone was to go out of
state with malicious intent to try to
avoid paying child support is child
support um able to be collected across
state lines um because the way I see it
we should allow them we should allow
people to go to work but we do need
consequences for people not paying child
support so if in other words if it was
to follow them that they can't get away
from paying child support but still
allow them to work then that makes the
most sense to me do you so you might not
know the answer but maybe you do well as
I indicated this bill does not limit the
limit the state's ability to track those
kinds of cases and so uh in in the early
in the late 90s when this when this
legislation was in its Heyday and and
and the dead be dad Provisions were
being touted uh the examples given were
uh
Mr X left his family in Ohio and moved
to Kentucky and now he's applying for
that Kentucky driver's license uh well
this bill allows the states to share
information yes he's here in Kentucky
he's he's applying for a driver's
license here you can track him here and
and get your child support issues dealt
with um and as I also mentioned uh that
the that the current current laws allow
numerous other methods to collect child
support and probably the the most
important is to tap into someone's uh
income tax returns and and get monies
that way and and that's a vehicle for uh
for getting after other assets as
well sounds good representative
Panic thank you um chairman uh thank you
for taking my question
what I don't see in here is the
um where the protections would be from
revoking their Professional
Licensing could that be added to this
bill I wanted to start small I wanted to
start with the driver's license issues
only uh I also agree that uh you know if
you're a Prof a professional license uh
or business license that it would make
sense but uh I I wanted to take a small
bite at the Apple first to see the
temperature of the uh of the legislature
and then if that made sense we could
representative seeing none thank you so
much for your testimony thank you chair
recognizes Susan I want to get it right
Briston DHHS Bureau of Child Support who
has ticked the Box indicating opposition
Bill thank you Mr
chairman uh good morning to the
committee my name is Susan bristen I'm
the uh Chief staff attorney for the
office of child support in the
Department of Health and Human
Services uh we appear today to give
testimony with regards to House Bill
1425 uh this bill prohibits the
suspension revocation or denial of
driver's license for failure to comply
with the child support order and allows
for reinstatement for individuals whose
driver's license have been suspended
revoked or
denied
um as a condition of receiving Federal
4D funds which is the 66% of the the
budget for the child support program
our state is required to have procedures
regarding the withholding suspension and
restriction of the licenses of
non-custodial parents who owe past due
support this comes from the statute it's
a16 sure 42 USC section
welcome um the Mandate also besides
driver's license covers professional and
occupational licenses recreational and
sporting licenses as well uh we would
note that second to the income
withholding order the suspension of
driver's license is the most used and
the most highly effective enforcement
tool available to the child support
program um in New Hampshire our policy
um allows for
the certification of an obligor as
non-compliant after 60 days of
non-payment um I did a little bit of
research in PR preparation for today to
sort of see where New Hampshire lies
with regards to the the day amount
looking at New England New Hampshire at
60 days Connecticut it's 90 days Maine
it's 60 days Massachusetts it's 8
weeks um Rhode Island it's 90 days
Vermont always wants to be different
it's a quarter of the annual obligation
which is basically 90
days
um
so if this legislation as proposed go
would go through um it would place the
bureau out of compliance with its
federal state plan requirements and in
direct conflict with federal law making
the State subject to significant Federal
sanctions which could include the total
loss of federal
funding um as well as funding for the um
incentive funds and the federal tan of
block
grant so I've been told to keep it short
there extra credit um anyone with a
Bickford
microphone microphone on is it yeah red
red light got it thank you attorney Bron
right um who's so good about answering
our calls here um but you you talked
about the loss of funding and do you
have any idea what that loss of funding
might be and could you tell us what we
get now from the
federal
funding uh thank you for the question
yes um it's could be up to $16.9 million
in federal funds uh an additional 1.2
million in federal child support
performance measure incentive funds and
1.9 million in the federal tanif block
grant
funding and
followup uh thank you Mr chairman
and it's hard to believe they would take
that much away just for uh license do
you have any
indication what they would take away if
this past
actually uh unfortunately i' I've
despite being with
the Bureau for 23 years we've never
lived through one of these so I I I I
don't know what it would look like
um I do believe we would be given a
chance to remedy what the feds would say
is our mistake but what that would look
like whether that would sort of be an an
all or nothing or gradual that I I'm I'm
sorry I can't I can't really address one
one further one well thank you Mr
chairman um we heard about other states
doing something but not I'm not clear um
um reduction it was called in driver's
licenses uh suspension do you know
anything about that um I I do know that
other states do do temporary licenses I
think that's sort of been the case all
along in that personal experience from
my aunt who lives in New York who has a
very heavy foot um she's she when she
lost her license due to speeding she was
always able to get a a temporary license
to get herself to work so that's that's
something that that I know other states
do I don't think that's specific to the
child support piece oh um to my
knowledge it's not something New
you representative long was next thank
you Mr chairman um
so a lack of a lack of compliance to
child support uh has their license
revoked so they have a job um and their
license and they're not paying support
um so is is there is there some way that
New Hampshire
can prior to pulling a license can can
they work out a payment plan and show
that that plan is being observed where
they could retain their license thank
you for the question representative long
yes I we they do the child support
officers definitely do work with people
um what I've found in the past is that
the driver the the threat to the
driver's license is sometimes the first
way we have of getting somebody's
attention who's not paying their child
support if they have a job we have a
wage assignment in place if they have a
uh what we call a W2 job meaning that
they work for somebody else they're not
self-employed and they're not in the the
gig economy so then this is not an issue
because the payments are coming in but
for people who are sort of outside the
the more normal
employment um we send them letters look
you owe this money when you're going to
start making payments you know what's
happening and they get ignored so it's
the first letter that goes out that says
you're getting close to the point where
we might take your license a lot of
times that's all it takes they they call
they set up a payment
plan we ask them what's going on and and
sort of be like okay let's get this
going um I do know that once we've
certified them to
DMV uh DMV then sends out a notice and
gives them time to come to an agreement
with us at which point we would then
revoke the revocation or there's you
know there's language that deal with it
um so a lot of times you know people
don't they don't actually lose the
license in that we we try do try to work
with them we also would encourage some
but if somebody comes in and says they
they are unable to pay because they
think it's too much money we would
encourage them and help them to apply
for a modification of their
order because obviously that's something
if you know if they've had a change in
circumstance or something like that it's
like well let's get it to court to make
it more affordable and then hopefully
then you can make your payments okay
thank you you're welcome represent
resentative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman I'm happy
to be back we're happy you're back and
thank you for taking my question uh for
full transparency purposes I am a
co-sponsor on this bill but um I just
wanted to um ask you one question and
it's regarding the federal funding um
the sponsor of this bill stated that of
all the states who have
um a law similar to what this bill would
be come um that uh there's been no
federal um funding that's been withheld
C can you either confirm or disprove his
statement to that fact uh thank you for
the question um I don't have any
information about other states other
States Federal funding I will tell you
from it's a national group
that basically listed all the different
states and what they do for for license
revocation and it's all all 50 states
there is not any state that doesn't have
it some of them do have the temporary
the the the whole temporary piece of it
U so then it's up to each state I think
welcome thank you for your testimony
thank you
chair recognizes Jennifer Bailey from
[Music]
DMV good morning chairman members of the
chair my name is Jennifer Bailey and I'm
with the Division of Motor
Vehicles oh that's what DMV means yes I
knew it thank you I I'm having
flashbacks to life in Massachusetts
where the
RMV bad bad bad bad bad thank you you're
the good guys thank you so the DMV is
not in they're not opposed we're just
here as a neutral party on this and to
present some statistics stal data for
DHHS so in
2023 we received 2400 um requests from
Child Support to suspend driers licenses
so our process in that is to send out
notification to the most recent mailing
address on file with us as well as the
address child support provides us if if
it's different so two notices
potentially can go out this gives the
applicant 30 days to respond to child
support if they do child support sends a
resend notice to us and then we resend
that
suspension of those 2400 new child
support complaints last year 258 ended
up having to pay suspension fees of
$100 708 of them cleared child support
before the suspension and fee went into
effect um 69 are currently pending 1,400
of them them are still active they have
not cleared child support nor paid um
their suspension fees so their licenses
remain
suspended in that count though they may
not only be suspended for child support
we often see that those that are still
remaining suspended are suspended for
other reasons so clearing child support
may not be priority for them as
a DWI or something else is Holy them
um I wanted to make note of an earlier
testimony where it was stated that DHHS
would still be able to use DMV to track
these um defendants for their child
support they would not DMV DHHS would
not have any provisions if this law went
into effect to be able to use DMV to
gain addresses of these individuals so
that's all that I have for you guys
much and it's my custom the custom of a
lot of uh chairs to give the prime
sponsor uh unlimited time and then
expert Witnesses in my choosing that is
to say people from agencies especially
if they bring a contary view to have um
quite a bit of time I'm now going into
the public comment phase where we will
be back to the three minute Rule and
while you're up the chair recognizes The
Salem I promise it's three minutes or
less I'll speak from my personal
experience in the cases that I'm
familiar with but I won't mention
anybody's name in my personal experience
I've known cases where driver's licenses
are still being suspended for years
years for failure to pay child support
even when the obligor has not ever been
permitted her due process to contest
unreasonable charges and
orders immediately the payer was
stripped of their driver's license
without regard for driving to
work I also know of many cases where the
payer withholds child support
for several months at a time over a
period of
years and they only pay a week before
the pay goes to the expense of a court
hearing further missing
work in these cases these many payers
have never lost their driver's license
despite their longstanding history of
withholding child support in a malicious
game
that's why I support this bill it is
totally totally
non not used for everybody it's just a
whim of who gets penalized and who
doesn't so I think there are other more
effective ways to make people pay child
support without denying their chance to
go to court and show whether or not this
is a fair fair obligation
questions seeing none thank you so
much uh chair recognizes uh Mr Robert
tangu again for three minutes Make It
can mik on oh hello thank you um so
anyway anyways uh I was I was talking
about and I I just looked up the bill um
there was a question earlier it's called
Uh the pdps system problem driver P
poter system it's basically interstate
commerce where uh if you agree to get
Highway money from the federal
government you have to acknowledge other
states tickets and uh they have that's
attached to licenses I will get into
that if I have some time uh what I was
talking about was section 401
uh of title 4D 601 not 606 and and so
the there's a lot of mechanisms that the
uh state has uh to enforce child support
within the court um contempt of court
boom and then over and over again if you
keep doing it then you're going into
jail and people go to jail and that
should be done but uh one of the things
that they don't follow with uh
601 uh of the same uh scheme is is fraud
so if you report fraud say there's fraud
in the case and your child support Rees
there's just so much and is you're
contesting that for them to pull a
driver's
license is is it's horrible and that's I
got my driver's license back because uh
in California they said I owed some
money and I said well I'm in New
Hampshire you have to prove it article
14 and I got my license back I talked to
Earl Sweeney uh
went all the way up there through the
political process and they just flipped
a switch so we have that and I also want
to bring uh the committee's attention to
the uniform support Act of
1955 which I read and it's on the books
and uh one of those is amount of support
five RSA
54685 and basically they consider assets
so a lot of times just picture this Bill
Gates finds a homeless woman and
willfully gets her pregnant then decides
he doesn't want to be with her he can't
just kick her out and that's what the
law states and in order for I mean I
could read the law to you but that's
basically what it it it gets that
feeling of it it's supposed to be equal
for children it's supposed to be uh
you're not supposed
to burden the other
party doesn't matter it's all about the
children and then further there's a law
you can be arrested if you are uh
failure to support but they have to
prove that you have the ability to
support and I can see that you're
fidgeting so I'm getting close you are
getting close you got about 45 seconds
okay so um child supports interstate
commerce it's it's it's funded by
Federal grant
money for the administration of child
support and then with the DMV and all of
a said and good in most cases but I do
support this bill uh passing because if
you take away someone's driver's license
in New Hampshire they absolutely cannot
uh support themselves or their children
and it's a downward slope thank you the
rail system is pretty non there yeah
would you take questions if there are
any yes any
questions seeing none thank you so much
and thank you for playing Beat the
Clock oh that es me I see no more pink
cards on this so with that I conclude
the hearing on House Bill 1425 and now
open the hearing on House Bill 1588
relative to court jurisdiction over
persons receiving special education and
forward thank you Mr chairman
hospitel uh 1588 uh speak into the
record because we know who you are but
the listening audience may not
representative long representing
Manchester Vice chair of children family
you so House Bill
1588 was uh brought to me late in the
process that's why you see me as the
only sponsor uh it's in to amend the uh
Juvenile Justice
statutes um to align with the new upper
age uh limits for special education it
is important uh topic and worthy of uh
my attention that's why I brought this
forward um there are there's a woman
here to testify uh that could articulate
this a lot better than I
could so if there are any questions I'll
okay
them
that would
be Jane burgun yes she and I go back
what 10 to 15 minutes anyway right come
on
up good afternoon my name is Jane Bon
bullu I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire ass Association of special
education administrators and we are here
to speak in support of this bill um
basically um a couple years ago special
education statute was amended um to
raise the eligibility age for students
with disabilities to age 22 or sometimes
called 21 inclusive um at that time when
the legislature um passed that bill they
didn't take into to consideration the
Juvenile Justice
statutes um which um really you know
this bill would return the jurisdiction
of um
students until they age out of special
education so it would actually align the
special education statutes with the
Juvenile Justice statutes so you know
we're in support of this bill because it
really um supports those students who um
are in those situations where um they
may be in a residential treatment center
at age 18 and yet they can't continue on
um with special education through age 22
and you have to apply for waivers and
there's you know lots of blocks so on
behalf of the students that that we
serve um we are in support of aligning
recognizes yeah I know rep none only one
changed the name over Christmas
representative Grossman
sorry thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you for helping to bring this forward
and um bring this information to us
basically this is just a housekeeping
Bill essentially right to line the
current
22 and that's it it's yes that's from
you know it's on behalf of the kids just
they don't get stuck in the system thank
you I know in working a fair bit with
the DD Community things could really get
streamlined and maybe this bill will
help that is that the assertion of those
who favor this
bill exactly say yes yes thank you
anyone else uh representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman and thank you do
we know um how many uh kids we currently
have in placement who would be impacted
by this spell I'm just I'm trying to
think of numbers because I know we have
a number that are being served out of
state because we don't have placement in
state like 50 or 60 um and I'm just
curious how many of them fall into this
this age hole of 18 to 22 thank you for
the question I don't have that
information today but I could get it for
you okay thank
wow the chair recognizes a man who needs
no introduction but he's getting one
anyway The Honorable John Williams
Esquire late of Rockingham County
decades in service to the state of New
Hampshire and chairman Pearce members of
the committee thank you very very much
and thank you I am again pulling second
Stringer for the day uh for total
transparency we're here to provide
information uh on this bill and by way
of background I actually before I went
to law school had my background in
special education um and really enjoyed
working uh with that population uh of
kids but as to the bill that's in front
of you in with less than three minutes
of time we are supportive of the concept
um this bill attempts to do what other
legislation that you've seen either with
this committee or the house education
committee to align the age for children
to receive Services up to age 22 so
that's what's attempting to be done here
we support the concept uh although we
know it's an issue for division three
but knowing that your chair is very good
friends um not only friendship um
collegial uh but also from the class of
2016 of legislators is representative
Jess Edwards so there is the need to at
least mention uh the need for resources
if we're going to do what is being
requested in this bill which we would
say the underlying goals here are latory
there are going to be the need for the
resources we can't do it without the
resources in terms of the communitybased
care for these children because they're
going to need those Services up to that
particular age uh there are modum
Staffing Resources that are identified
in the fiscal analysis attached to the
bill and those are things we know that
will be addressed if this bill passes
out of the committee to be for
discussions at division three however
I've been at division three and the
first question they asked did you bring
up these Financial issues before the
committee and I know at risk of being
told we're a policy committee not fiscal
you can't do the policy without the
fiscal part of it and you're not doing a
service to the citizens that we both
Serve by passing legislation that
doesn't have the resources to accomplish
those goals so with that that ends my uh
commentary and with that I am concluding
my
testimony and might it be true and this
isn't would you believe this is a real
question might it be true that while
the bill
itself might demand lots more money from
division free in the real world it does
not demand as much as one thinks because
when waivers are sought and gained that
now that was a
question it was a money question and at
the end of the day I always check my
wallet my account to see how much money
I need to have and this is going to need
money whether it's called through waiver
Services we do need a direct
appropriation for this I'm obviously not
understanding the question okay
obviously I I did it in the liberal arts
form I'll try to put it in lawyer
language no I can't um we're spending
money for people over 18
now it's called the you're getting some
waivers and that funds things and the
orange badge people are nodding and
therefore we're we're partway there
we're not starting from zero saying
every needy person from 18 to what 22 is
now going to get a lot of money we're
saying some so I I think I Now
understand better when you're referring
to W you're talking about waiver
Services yeah uh through through the
department and it is true that when
we're looking at the different
categories of individual children who
are 18 or under 18 to 22 and then the
adult community there is still a gap
within that area of the 18 to 22 which
this bill is trying to align again I
came here saying that we are supportive
of the concept of Bill but we do need
the resources and can't do this without
those resources and I need to make that
abundantly clear chairman Pearson thank
you and I'm rehearsing my speech towards
the chairman of division three as we
speak thank you and if you could mention
the need for putting appropriation
language in the bill that would be
greatly appreciated and we could
certainly be part of that conversation
to assist you with that so since this is
going to division three should it pass
uh they can put funding language
in would you say particularly in if
they're encouraged by the policy
committee that recognizes that the
department needed the resources to be
able to implement the
legislation the chair recognizes
representative
Grossman great job Mr chairman thank you
um would you
so the students that are currently the
18 to 22 now that that law has passed
that aren't in the Juvenile Justice
System wouldn't it be illegal if we
didn't find the money the funding so it
becomes these CH these kids under free
and appropriate public education you
know this is a housekeeping these kids
still have IEPs they still have needs
they still that hasn't changed it's just
that these kids happen to be in the
Juvenile Justice System
versus the other kids that we found that
funding for up until 22 in our school
systems my son is one of those kids
who's 18
um it's it we'll get lawsuits as well we
you know if we don't fund this on the
front end because it will be required by
federal
and given that I have a whole host of
attorneys including those who might want
to provide commentary behind me that
would be fing the litigation I will just
refrain from answering it but we do
think that there's a merit behind this
bill and and the need to accomplish the
goals of the
legislation representative ball thank
you chairman parison would you believe
that we talked about another bill
totally separate from this one and we
were actually told that the budget
committee would not do anything on
speculation and we needed to pass the
bill and they will find the
money would you believe that
one and being that I've been doing this
work for over 25 years um I will believe
anything you'll tell me uh about about
that yes thank you and having been a
prosecutor you know people who can make
it
happen anyone else hey folks what do you
thank you thank you folks uh while we're
up what do you think we like it we want
to go forward
thumbs everybody have a thumb want a
thumb thank you thumbs look at these
thumbs a community of
thumbs
the this closes the hearing on House
Bill 1588
FN I now open an executive session on
House Bill
1588 and I will entertain a motion who
would like to make a motion
why that would be representative
grman thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion to um move House Bill 1588
FN for a to pass OTP and since we've
done very well by having uh a Republican
and a Democrat on most things is there a
republican who would like to Second this
I saw representative McMahon's hand
any
discussion we could all go over to see
representative Edwards is a group
couldn't we any further discussion
seeing none uh the question before us is
the motion ought to pass on House Bill
1588 FN moved by representative Gman
seconded by representative McMahon the
clerk please call the
role chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long
yes representative deimon yes
representative representative Bickford
is not here representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative grman yes Representative
patr no is not not here representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative
Molton oh sorry excuse me she is not
here uh representative Raymond
yes we have 12 yays zero Nays and we
have four people who are not here the
motion of ought to
pass carries by a vote of 12 to zero it
will go to the house floor it will then
go to
finance we come back at 1:00 boy we made
that
for
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill
1598 relative to the Department of
Health and Human Services management of
Social Security payments and veterans
benefits for children and Foster Care
the chair recognizes the prime sponsor
[Music]
walner see this is the mark of a veteran
legislator here she automatically knows
to turn on the microphone without a
prompt I was just in a committee where
no one had their microphones on so if
you're in the audience you couldn't hear
a thing so well that's not true here
that's well good okay um I'm Mary Jan
walner I'm a state representative from
here in
conquer um and in September the national
public radio ran a story and the story
was entitled kids get the bill for their
own foster
care and Nationwide about five and five%
of Children and Youth in foster care
qualify for Social Security disability
or survivors Ben
benefits these are children with
disabilities or children who have lost a
parent and across the nation states have
retained these benefits when a child is
in foster care but that is changing many
states are moving to pass legislation to
preserve the benefits for the foster
child benefits are held securely for the
child until they are no longer in in
foster
care the US Department of Health and
Human Services and the Social Security
Administration have sent a letter to the
State Child Welfare agencies encouraging
them to make needed changes in this
these
policies the national public radio and
The Marshall Project found that 49
States including New Hampshire routinely
retain a child's benefits and the funds
are used to reimburse the state for the
cost of foster care states have an
obligation to pay the cost of foster
care under state and federal law so the
existing policy of the state retaining
the benefits means some of our neediest
children pay for their own foster
care the proposed legislation has the
Department of Health and Human Services
establishing an appropriate account to
conserve to conserve the benefits until
the CH child leaves foster care this
could be lifechanging for a young person
leaving foster care they could now have
some resources to pay for housing
possibly continue their education or buy
a car to allow them to get to a job we
hear so often that many youth leaving
foster care have no family to go back to
no resources and and often become
homeless I want to thank the uh division
of children youth and families for the
assistance they gave me in drafting the
bill making this change in state policy
will be time consuming for the
department and I have added the ability
for an
appropriation to the bill at the time of
unclear how much the department would
need to accomplish this for Foster
children if your committee finds the
policy
worthwh the finance committee can work
with the Department on the needed
appropriation at the time of the bill
drafting this policy change was
estimated to affect about 90 children a
year in New
Hampshire and according to the
information from the Department of
Health and Human Services the state
retained 569 ,000 in
2022 and
$521,000 in 23 from foster children
children's disability and survivor
benefits in a state that has a budget
surplus has reduced business taxes and
moved to eliminate the interest in
dividends tax it seems shameful for us
to retain the Social Security disability
and survivor benefits from of our foster
children to pay for their own foster
care these are some of the neediest
children in our state and by passing
this legislation we can make a huge
difference in their
future I have um I was going to leave
you with a couple of um articles about
this and the impact it's having
Nationwide on the foster care system so
um I'll leave them for you if uh someone
want me too I can run upstairs and get
copies for the committee but I do have
at one one copy of each of the three
articles I think we like that sort of
thing and if you want to do it after
immediately after this hearing has
concluded that way you won't miss
anything that we're discussing and uh
come on back and then give it to
representative Bickford who'll pass them
around great thank you is there a fiscal
note anywhere um I believe that I I had
not seen the f fiscal note that the
department had uh but I believe there is
a fiscal note floating around someplace
at the time that the bill was published
there was no fiscal note and when I when
I started to draft the bill I I did uh
work with the Department on the wording
of the bill and they they were very
helpful in helping me word it the way
they felt comfortable with it and at the
time it was really hard to determine
what kind of a fiscal impact it would
have so I think that's something Finance
can work with them on and but I did put
in the bill it does have an
appropriation of $1 to allow us to allow
us to work on the bill and to have an
appropriation the bad news is although
we have a lot of money there's a lot
more people wanting a lot more than we
have and at the very least our
discussing this can be aspirational for
the next budget I hope we can do more
than that but at the very least we can
uh signal that it is the belief of this
well what the belief of this committee
is towards funding in the future uh will
you take questions sure sure anybody
with a question representative
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you so much this is a
very interesting Bill I'm curious do we
know if there are any states who have
enacted uh legislation like this yes do
do you know which ones there are there
are quite a few that are
right now working on it and many that
have passed it also and I have these
articles which I will bring back and you
can see some of the examples of state
and our bill this bill was drafted using
the model of the Arizona okay thank you
legislation representative
bigford thank you Mr chairman thank you
represent walner yes the
Social Security uh payments which I
assume that this includes payments uh
made when there's a parent that dies
okay and what is the intent of that
Social Security
funding why why did this federal
government decide that we should give
Social Security money
to on behalf of children not necessarily
to children but on behalf to support the
to support them and specifically for
children with disabilities also to help
them be sure that they get the services
that they need thank
you anyone
else thank you
representative thank
you chair now calls upon Mr George uh
pisker is it do I have it
right do I have the right Bill yes 1595
yet
okay thank you now I hope I'm going to
do better is that 1598 okay good uh
Michelle
wangerin
assistance you know what the I asked for
is thank you all right good uh thank you
honorable chair and members of the
committee my name is Michelle wangren
I'm an attorney at New Hampshire legal
assistance and the director of the youth
law project the youth law project at New
Hampshire legal assistance is a specific
project that works with system involves
involved kids to make sure that their
civil needs are met to keep them out of
the Juvenile Justice and Child
Protection Systems um so in that vein my
testimony today is going to be very
practical I am not a social security
expert but I do have some experience
based on my representation of Youth who
have been in the system and how the
current practice has a very real impact
on already impoverished Youth and
families so as a sort of a broad
overview uh Social Security the Social
Security commissioner has very broad
discretion in determining who is the
What's called the representative paye
for a child who receives Social Security
benefits so representative pay is
typically an adult or an it could be an
agency um that manages a child's Social
Security benefits for them because they
are children and we don't just hand over
that money to them so the money that is
received by uh Social Security to a
child is supposed to be used for their
benefit and there are various different
types of Social Security but
if we make it very basic and talk about
SSI um which is the supplemental social
uh security income that income is
designed for children who are um either
disabled or or who have lost a parent um
and who have um very minimal Family
Resources um so so it would not be
available to children and families who
are well resourced and have the ability
to maintain Ain um
their housing and food without some
supplemental income um it also is um
designed to ensure that their disability
based needs um can be met because those
often come with added costs so if we
look at it with that lens um and the
fact that the representative pay
obligation is to make sure that this
money is used in the best interest of
the of the child um there are certain
factors that uh Social Security is
supposed to look at in determining the
best representative pay one of these
factors is the relationship of the
recipient to the child typically that is
a natural parent because a parent is
presumed to act in the child's best
interest to manage um money that is uh
provided to them on their behalf parents
um typically do that and and and there's
typically a rebuttable presumption that
if they're not for what reason managing
their funding then Social Security can
look to other folks that could be a
close relative it could be a close
family friend but somebody who knows the
child well and knows what their needs
are is typically looked to there's a
list of of folks that are sort of an
order of preference and um in a manual
that it's a Palms manual that explains
how Social Security benefits should be
managed um and typically a state agency
is last on the list um it is not what
typic typically Social Security should
look to as the first choice to manage a
child's Social Security benefits another
factor that Social Security is supposed
to look to um in determining a rep
representative paye is a knowledge of
the child's current and foreseeable
needs again a parent typically knows
what the child's current needs are and
what the child's hopes and dreams are
and what they what they may need down
the road um and then the third factor is
custody and proximity of the
representative pay in to the beneficiary
um typically you know when you're
talking about a child in um the custody
of the department it could go either way
I mean the department is typically based
in conquered a family could be in close
proximity they should be in close
proximity they may not be in close
proximity but the presumption is is
they're visiting and maintaining that
close connection to the family so that's
how Social Security is supposed to work
um most States including New Hampshire
have a very long-standing practice ice
of
bypassing that order of preference when
a child enters the custody of the state
um so when a child is removed from home
and enters either foster care or
institutional placement that order of
preference sort of disappears and what
happens as a matter of practice and it
used to be dcyf policy I'm not sure if
it still is but but DCF will typically
apply to become the child's
representative
and typically the Social Security
Administration will rubber stamp that
without any investigation as to whether
or not the child has a natural parent or
other person who can manage the child's
fund funds um in their best interest and
in my legal practice uh representing
kids who have entered the custody of the
state this absolutely happens with
absolutely no
investigation how does that impact the
children so so when so typically again
we have to remember these are
impoverished families who are um who
have maybe been receiving these Social
Security benefits for their disabled
child um or for or for children who have
um lost a parent for a long time before
the child enters State custody this
money is Subs subsistence money it's not
money that's designed to add to the
child's life and go on vacations and do
these things the family has determined
that the child needs the money to meet
the child's basic needs that includes
housing that includes food that includes
clothing that includes
um disability Based Services that the
child needs um and Recreation to the
extent that Recreation is available when
we talk about Recreation that doesn't
mean um that doesn't mean vacations but
it might mean something normal like you
know being able to play on a basketball
team and pay the fee for the uniform
forms so we're talking about very um
basic basic needs so when a child goes
into custody uh whether it's a
residential placement or a foster home
the the plan always is in the first
instance to reunify the child with the
family now what happens when a a family
who's receiving say $700 which is the
typical it's 700 and some change I don't
know what it is these days but it's
around there um they suddenly they
suddenly lose that money that they need
that they've relied on to maintain the
child's home food clothing um and those
basic
needs in my experience those families
are become immediately at risk of losing
their housing um and some become very
very close if not actually losing it
while the child is in the custody of the
department um in a case several years
ago this was exactly the scenario where
the family actually did lose their
housing I went to Social Security um the
The Who who was managing the child's
benefits at the time and I said look
this this family is about to lose
housing they need this money the
department is using it automatically
they became the rep pay and they're
they're paying to reimburse theirselves
themselves for the child's residential
placement this family wants this child
back this child wants to go back to the
family but that this child will never
make it back to the family if the family
loses their home and in the end with a
lot of work a lot lot of work that
typically these families don't have
access to lawyers um but I was
representing this child on education
issues and happen to know that this was
happening um and and was able to get
involved because nhla has expertise in
it um but with a lot of work we were
able to convince the department to
provide the parent um gas cards and rent
rental assistance to be able to maintain
that family's home and be able to
continue contact with the child that
would have never happened without that
tremendous effort um the second thing is
that when a child goes into placement
even if they're not necessarily at risk
of losing their home um kids don't have
money these are families that now have
to use all of their resources for their
housing um because they're shifting from
using a portion of the payment to
support the the maybe the child's
bedroom they have to have a two-bedroom
instead of a one-bedroom and so um they
they're allowed to use that money for it
um but now they don't have extra money
so if the child wants a particular and
we're talking about teenagers sometimes
or you know middle schoolers and the
child goes in and they have you know a
shampoo that doesn't work with their
hair or they want you know one cool pair
of shoes to fit in the family has no
money for this the child receives a
subsistence money and has no access to
it whatsoever because it's being used to
reimburse the department department for
um services that otherwise does have
fory money um State funding to be able
to pay for it puts the child and the
family at a very severe disadvantage and
has very very real consequences on these
children so for all of those reasons um
nhla strongly supports this bill and is
happy to answer any questions you may
have knowing that I am a child um
Juvenile Justice and child welfare
expert not so much so Social
Security thank you councelor will you
take questions yes anyone with a
question representative
Bickford thank you Mr chairman um some
time ago I during the Clinton
Administration I recall a uh law that
came through the federal government that
um was to push children out of foster
care and get them adopted I can't
remember the name of the law you may
recall I know John does um so I'm trying
to figure out where Where Do We Stand
how many kids are in uh foster care for
how long do they typically stay in
foster care I know at the time they were
talking about one year yeah so I think
that depends I think that's a question
the department can better answer I know
that in terms of
teenagers um you know the the number
fluctuates you know probably
between I know it's about 200 at any
point in time what it is across a year I
don't have that off of the top of my
head but when we're talking about you
know the broader child Ware population
I'm I'm assuming it's a lot larger you
had a second question and now I forget
it I think you I think you answered it
okay oh oh and how long are they staying
so again that depends so some some
children you know aren't able to reunify
their with their families and they um
they do get adopted the the preference
in under federal law is always
reunification so always what
reunification so the state is required
to work with the family for at least one
year to pursue that reunification unless
I think the legislature passed a bill
last year that said if there's really no
possibility of that reunification they
can start looking earlier but typically
they need to look at reunification for
one year what we know in you know as far
as as teenagers go we know that once
they enter residential placements in
particular they stay there for a long
time typically more than six months
often more than three years okay thank
you representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I just as
I'm looking at the bill um lines 9 to 14
talk about if a child is already
receiving benefits and then it says uh
the department shall identify in
consultation with the child and the
child's representative a representative
pay in accordance with uh 20 CFR 404 etc
etc and shall apply to become the
representative only if no no other
suitable candidate is available I guess
my question
is how is the depart like what are the
guidelines for the department or I would
say maybe the court in deciding whether
or not the current representative p is
quote unquote suitable under this
because based on the presentation my
assumption was we're going to let the
parent who's currently collecting it
continue to collect it unless there's
some extraordinary circum cumstances but
as I'm reading this now I'm wondering
like how do we if this passed how does
the division know who's who's
appropriate and then and suitable and at
what point did they then apply yeah so
typically the child enters with social
security benefits and social security
has already made the determination about
whether or not the parent is suitable so
I think what this gets to is If the
child already has a representative the
department will talk to them to
determine whether or not they are they
continue to be willing to act as the
child's representative pay even though
the child is no longer living in their
home I without having um spoken to the
sponsor about it I'm not sure that's
what this means but if it was if it was
patterned on another bill my guess is
that that's what this means is that and
then if the child is going in and
they're identified as potentially
eligible for social security benefits
and does not currently have a
representative P I think that's what
this means by a child's representative
um in line 11 it says with a child and
the child's
representative so I think that would
refer to a child who is not yet
receiving um Social Security benefits
and the department would talk to that
representative probably the parent maybe
a guardian um to determine who should
apply to become the child's
representative
pay and that the department should only
do it if nobody else who is suitable um
um is available but but like I said
social security has a formula to
determine who is a suitable
representative pay based on the
relationship with the child the um the
knowledge about the child the um
the knowledge of the current and
foreseeable needs and then the the
custody and proximity relationship than
you just a quick followup yeah follow so
I'm I guess I'm still stuck on the
suitability question because what I'm
envisioning in my mind is a situation
where the child is removed because of
say I don't know sexual abuse or extreme
violence or you know the murder of
another child in the home at what point
does the division say well this person
is no longer suitable to manage the um
you know
monetary best interests of this child
because they aren't suitable to manage
the other best interest of this child
and so I don't I'm I'm curious about how
we
navigate that and how we um make sure
that the bill does what it's intended to
do which is to make sure that people
aren't becoming you know Indigent
because their kid went to foster care I
I completely understand that so I think
I think if the if the person is not
acting in the best interest of the child
My Hope Is that Social Security would
not sanction them as the person who's
appropriate to be the representative P
but there may be somebody else in their
life maybe a grandmother who is close
like who are they
in my mind the most practical solution
would be if they're not seeking to
reunify with say a sexually abusive
parent because that would be harmful to
the child who are they seeking to
reunify with and is that does that
person already maintain a close
relationship with them have knowledge of
their needs and be able to use these
funds in their best interest now if
nobody is available I think that's when
the department would be step in and and
potentially become the representative p
and that's where other portions of the
bill mandate how they use that money not
to reimburse themselves but to make sure
that the child's needs that aren't being
funded through um you know just as a
matter of course you know do they need
some shampoo do they need you know
something for sports do they need
basketball shoes like what do they need
and then to the extent that their needs
are met to conserve that money up to the
resource limit so that they can have it
and don't leave custody with lint in
their pocket and um
adulthood anyone
else seeing none thank you so much for
your testimony now those of you who have
filled out pink cards know that besides
putting your name you put your address
so now the chair recognizes John
building and chairman uh my apologies
earlier today I at least got it in the
129 uh Pleasant Street and we also have
with us director uh Jeff ler who will be
joining me at the table uh I just wanted
to start off by thanking the sponsor
Prime sponsor for uh HB 1598 represent
Mary Jane walner she actually took the
time and courtesy during the uh time of
the LSR filing period in and prior to
the sign off to really actively Engage
The Department in a conversation around
this bill and I and the work product
that you see before you represents her
Earnest desire to creating really good
policy here in New Hampshire as well as
taking into account from the Department
the mechanics of how we would go about
doing it um I actually even though I am
an active member of the bar my current
role is legislative in nature and I
really do appreciate also uh the
attorney Michelle rangen from the New
Hampshire legal assistance because I
think she provides you with a really
good overview over the mechanics behind
the bill uh so with that said we we do
understand and appreciate the the good
works of what this is trying to
accomplish because currently those
benefits that you have like the SSI the
Social Security uh um for the disabled
uh that uh the New Hampshire legal
assistance was referring to currently
when we receive those funds they are
deposited back into the general funds as
opposed to being put into a trust
account on behalf of that child so when
let's say they do emancipate or age out
there could be some funds out there to
support you know kids in the future and
I think that's at least part of the
goals also so the immediate needs of
dispersement as was described earlier to
you would be one of the goals timing is
everything in life isn't it and uh we
received this past
session 160 plus fiscal note worksheet
requests from the LBA I'm proud to
represent to this committee we have
turned in all but about seven of of them
so far well over 150 the LBA has been
working so hard to catch up with the
fiscal analysis on bills that it is
happening so rapidly that by the time
your bills were printed out they
magically about an hour or two later
actually published if you go online you
can actually see the fiscal analysis of
this legislation uh I did bring copies
of the fiscal analysis that I will leave
after our testimony with you just for
background information uh but we will
need just like the bill that had I had
um had the opportunity to chat with you
folks before the lunch break this is
going to require the collaboration of
work with the division 3 uh as it
relates to funding this is a very
laudable goal that is trying to be
achieved by this bill however it does
come with mechanics that are different
in nature in kind in New Hampshire in
other words we have to be very
thoughtful in how these funds are
administered in other words you have to
treat it very much like you would in a
guardianship action that if you're
trusted with individuals funds you have
to account for those funds you have to
report out and those are the pieces that
the department would be required to
doing as part of their work as well so
when you do see the fiscal note it will
at first reaction you know the the price
sticker shock whether it's a used car
nowadays or I'm sorry pre-owned car or a
new car it is it is a dollar amount that
we do need to reconcile and working if
this bill is to proceed forward to
giving the department the resources of
doing this because in addition to the
accounting there would be a need for not
only with um uh the director's staff
director fers at DCF but also with our
legal folks we've identified that the
attorneys would need to be involved in
terms of helping to maintain these funds
during the course of the time that we'd
be managing those funds um we did work
with a couple of really wonderful
attorneys one was uh attorney Janelle
layan I want to give a call out to
Janelle she's a department attorney who
was the first law clerk in the New
Hampshire Probate Court uh back in the
90s and we have her now and so she
helped with the language of this bill as
well as attorney Lori Young who also has
a background she worked with the Office
of Public guardian and uh she could she
would have loved listening to Michelle's
testimony because it was exactly I think
what Lor's would have been and
recognizing uh the the current state of
things so with that I am not a social
security uh expert in any means but I do
know that those who are experts were the
ones who helped us put together this
bill and I'm confident that the bill is
currently drafted is really good but if
I draw your attention to page two line
25 repon walner was gracious enough to
give us language so that we have in
there the appropriation language $1
although it will get you one hour
parking outside of here unless you have
a legislative parking permit which you
still have to walk a long ways but
you'll get a new parking garage over
here soon um won't get us to where we
need to go so that will be a
conversation that will need to be had
working with division three I see that
we have represent Mooney also in the
audience oh she was here uh and she
serves on division three so that
cross-pollination between your committee
and that committee is very critical for
this to be a successful piece of
legislation so with that I will turn it
over to director fer because he will be
brilliant and much more brief I'm sure
I don't about brilliant but brief thank
you John yeah when uh representative
Warner approached me with this bill I
was very excited about it and we're
certainly in full support of it and um
but it does come with a cost so I mean
that's all I'll say now but this is a
it's a brilliant Bill definitely needed
um we're trying to get all the resources
to strengthen families as we possibly
can and to prepare kids for when they do
uh leave foster care as well so any any
dollar that could go toward
strengthening a family um a resource for
Family Resource for a kid that's been in
in care for many years is what we're all
about and we really want to push that
going
forward any
questions representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I agree
wholeheartedly that um children who
become adults and who are aging out of
this system really need to have more
special attention paid to them because
um they're really at a
disadvantage um and
um two-fold problem I I know that we've
talked about adnauseum is that it's not
only setting them up
personally for failure in a lot of ways
right we're not preparing them for
adulthood but also um we will isn't it
true
that we may need to um pay for services
for those specific
individuals um in all different ways
where um we may not have if they were
able to use these funds um and set
themselves up um on a better
easier healthier path to
adulthood um um yeah I think we need
both I think you know we're working very
hard to provide funding housing for
example um uh tuition uh drivers driving
lessons and licenses etc for kids after
they turn 18 or or move out of our
system and this would be an added um
resource um to help prepare not only the
young person um but whoever they move in
with usually it's
family
um just a short followup um in in the
preparation that you were talking about
um is there any sort of um Financial
finance um piece that might go to that
because you know just as any any young
person um suddenly having a windfall
whether it's $5,000 or $10,000 or
$1,000 uh guidance on how to um you know
what's the smartest way to spend this
money to set yourself up for a better
future um is that something that would
happen or or plan that you would think
would you
would yeah create a program for yeah we
have an adolescent unit um who's run by
Rob rodler who's amazing been with the
DCF for many years and is an expert in
adolesence and helping kids uh graduate
from care into the real world so there's
an array of services that we can offer
we get a lot of federal funding for
example we call it the Hope program um
so uh and part of that there's another
bill that floated earlier for financial
uh literacy um and I think that's
something that we're also very in favor
of as well in trying to to do um opening
bank accounts helping people to plan and
budget their money and things like that
so we do have staff and programs that
help young people especially older aging
out as they say transition young people
um so we have both services and some
resources like Section 8 um and uh um
tuition reimbursements okay thank you
for answering my question anyone
else representative
McMahon thank you Mr
chairman uh if I may to the appropriate
Authority here on this question is um
upon the
establishment that the child is in that
the child is in the care of the
department uh are you custody or
Guardian ship what page what line are
you reading from um this is page 2 19
and 20 thank you yes pardon me Mr
chairman I should have said that all
right and then I I correlate that
statement on page one to line four that
this is for all children in the care of
the department and then line nine saying
that if they're already receiving
benefits uh does this state that um it
happens in both silos in in one case
that the the child is being cared is in
a care U location and that there's a
change that's taking place where they
become a by label a foster
child and then then the state takes
takes over as
in p on page 2 19 and 20 and then it's
child um chairman Pearson in response to
represent McMahon's question when it
refers to all children it's talking
about placement not only with foster
care but there's other types of
placement with children receiving
services that are out of home placement
which you're very familiar with in your
work um so it would be a much larger
universe than the foster children um by
way of some statistics earlier today we
did testify on the financial literacy um
um proving uh legal Authority here in
New Hampshire for children to be able to
cap or in foster care or other
placements to opening bank accounts um
that the stats that were discussed then
were 2,000 children at point in time
back in Spring of
20023 just last year uh we had in
placement with foster care of which uh
16 are older which is what this other
Bill we were on earlier today uh there
are 400 kids that would have been able
to Avail themselves it gives you an idea
of the universe which you'd be dealing
with around foster care but that's not
the entire universe because it would
also include other placements within the
agents through the agency and through
the courts one followup Mr chair
followup thank you uh specific to
the indiv uh the clients if you will
that you're referring to do we um do we
not know
this amount of how many individuals
would need this care uh so that the
amount of funding for the fiscal note
would be appropriate to meet those
needs my understanding is that this
legislation is designed not to leave any
child behind so that the uh agency would
be responsible to reviewing for all
children in its care and placement for
for the benefits under this bill and and
there's a there's a number by by name
with with a number of how many uh
individuals would have this benefit uh
provided and G de facto guaranteed so
that they're not left alone waiting for
an approval yeah and we and certainly
that's information that we provided as
part of our fiscal analysis and whether
or not it's reflected in the fiscal note
worksheet even though I've read the bill
I've just skimmed over our worksheet
because it was just published or I
shouldn't say mine it's the lbas it's
not our fiscal note but our financial
analysis went into that uh clearly if
this bill clears the policy committee
when you've already heard from the
director and myself that we acknowledged
that this is very good works on behalf
of represent wner in her legislation
there is going to be a need for a very
thoughtful discussion in the finance
area because there are fiscal
implications around this bill that do
need to be resolved and discussed for a
an appropriate amount for resources as
well as perhaps um the issue well I I'll
leave it at that it can there's some
complicating matters that just need to
be resolved um financially all right
thank you gentlemen thank you Mr
chairman anyone
else yes representative uh Bickford
thank you Mr chairman thank you
gentlemen um would this not create
inconsistent amounts of money for the
child that ages out to receive when they
age out because of the amount of time
that they're in which means the amount
of money they would have going into the
trust
account so in other words one child
might get a certain amount because they
were in the system for two months
another child would get another amount
because they were in the system for six
months that sound correct yeah it would
be into a yeah it' certainly be on a
visualized basis um around it currently
those children are receiving 0 so I
would imagine any uh I think the goal of
the bill here is to provide those
resources that uh they're entitled to
through the um Social Security
Administration that and also you'll note
that also Veterans Affairs of funding as
well is recognized in this legislation
uh that that would be uh safeguarded for
for those children whether or not for
ongoing expenses during their care or uh
upon their exiting uh care from the
system that was a long window
yes thank you representative Raymond
thank you so do we have any idea of how
many kids would end up roughly obviously
uh how many kids do we anticipate are
going to end up um needing the state to
create these accounts for them versus
how many have a trusted appropriate
adult who would be the one to be the the
rep Peay because I mean I would imagine
that you know some mom or dad would
still be able to be getting that income
but others perhaps aren't going to be
appropriate it would be individualized
yeah um yeah I think the number we have
we're actually I think collecting
$500,000 a year in so Security benefits
that we then use on behalf of the kids
in placement yep so this would change
that which is we agree with um uh but
that gives you an idea of numbers it's
about a half a million a year that uh
going to us now to provide services for
the kids that could be going directly to
the kids and families on individualized
you you saying no hands up uh thank you
and we're looking for your handout which
is the fiscal analysis is
it that is
correct and I'd like the committee to be
thinking are we ready to go forward on
executing this or not so think about it
and think about it as uh the um analysis
around
he take a look at this um because within
about a minute we're going to decide
whether we want to go forward with this
weeks
we were talking at lunch and we were
1425 yeah let's deal with this but thank
142 okay are we ready to take a straw
poll as to whether you think we are
ready to vote on this bill before us
presently or not
down up up up up up up up up down close
enough this this this bill here you me
the one we're just talking about yeah
now
what not yet wait um remember all the
fiscal stuff will be be dealt with in
division
fre uh not that fiscal doesn't matter to
us but we're primarily um policy
and there may not be the money this year
so this may be aspirational for another
uh budget but um so again thumbs up I
saw thumbs this away I see thumbs I
don't see THB we sort of ran out of
thumbs here getting better up or
down um I see enough to proceed to
dealing with this bill right now so
therefore I close the hearing on House
Bill 1598 and I open the exec session on
House Bill 1598 and the chair will
motion uh representative
ball your motion I would make a motion
to OTP OTP moved by ball I would like a
Democrat for a second representative
discussion what's that you may have a
discuss okay thank you Mr
chairman I just feel that this is the
wrong way to go about it this um these
Social Security benefits the children
are for their support it's not for a
savings account to be used at after
their age of majority of which they can
go g get that apartment or they can go
get some drugs but they get whatever
they want it's to help support the child
that's what it's for so to say that we
don't want the state to get paid is is
is wrong uh for the reimbursement
because they need to collect child
support
too and and just think if we hand the
money over to the child when they come
to age majority the neighbor someone
down the Street's gonna say well how
come I don't give money to give to my
children I used all mine up to support
the
children so it it's wrong in that
respect um if we did a stipend for every
child in state after they age out well
that would be
fair but this isn't fair to the
public thank
you representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman
and I actually agree with uh
representative Bickford about the money
being for the support of the child
that's the the purpose of it um but I
can tell you that when I worked for DCF
here in New Hampshire and when I worked
for a child protective in New York I had
families who needed that SSI or SSDI
payment in order to pay their rent and
the most heartbreaking thing is when you
are working with a family who cannot
support the child in their home for a
variety of reasons maybe you know
because of abuse or neglect or some
other struggle and then you're working
with the parent to correct their
parenting challenges but they lose their
home because they've lost the income
that they needed and so now the parent
is doing what they need to do they're
taking the classes they're going to
treatment they're doing their parenting
time with their child but the kid can't
be reunified because they have no place
to live and we can't send kids back to
someone who's homeless and I've I've
seen it more times than I can count on
my fingers and it like it still breaks
my heart and I've been out of the the
field for 10 years now um so for me I'm
going to support it because based on the
questions I was asking earlier um My
Hope cross my fingers is that the bulk
of this money would be staying with the
current rep PE or other appropriate rep
PE that would help these families not
become homeless and given our our
current housing crisis I the idea that
we might be responsible for someone
becoming homeless while they're trying
to correct the parenting mistakes that
led to their child going out of the
house just it breaks my heart so that's
where my support comes from my hope is
that we won't have very many of these
accounts because kids will have an adult
who can take them back any
further discussion representative
Perez thank you Mr chairman for allowing
to speak um I'm Bor in support of this
bill because as someone who volunteered
within the hire Family Services I know
many families struggle and and I think
we're moving in the right direction by
passing this bill so that's why I'm
supporting the Bill thank you thank you
anyone
else saying nothing further when the
clerk is ready the motion is ought to
pass on House Bill 1598 FNA clarifies
DHHS
obligations uh and it was moved by
representative ball and seconded by
representative Perez the clerk may call
the role please
chairman Pearson yes Vice chairman long
yes representative D Simone yes
representative Bickford no
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
sidel yes representative Gman
yes uh representative LC and patrino are
not here representative Perez
yes representative Greg
yes representative Molton is not here
representative Raymond yes and that is
12 Ys and zero Nays I see one nay I'm
sorry I'm sorry 12 to one so the motion
carries 12 to one
um if I were a senior this would be a
senior moment so I guess I'm having a
middle-aged moment uh that can this go
on consent even though it's going to a
second
committee okay thank you
everyone what was the vote 12 to1 12 to1
121 12
to1 I 12 want want a different
vote well bitford voted no so can't be
okay this ends the uh what 12 to1 yeah
like
just this closes the exec session on
1598 and now I open the hearing on House
Bill
1590 uh training regarding child abuse
and neglect for licensed
Physicians advanced practice
nurses and
physician assistance and I'm talking
slow to get the prime sponsor to the
table representative law thank
you thank you Mr chairman uh
representative long representing
Hillsboro District 23
Manchester um Al schille 1590 was
brought forward uh through um currently
there's training regarding uh child
abuse and neglect and uh what we're what
they're noticing is that there aren't a
lot of upper level uh medical providers
that are taking that training for one
obvious reason is time constraint um uh
and being transparent also they're
speaking with a few of the uh proponents
of this uh there they did have some
amendments that they would like to look
at I didn't want to bring those in now
uh so that I could hear all the
testimony and make sure we have
everything covered um I think it's
important to um to have training and
identifying uh abuse and neglect uh
there are some there are some facilities
uh there are some organizations that
mandate it and there then there are
others that don't they just ask people
to take it at their time uh there is an
online uh um there is an online module
that you could follow in order to get
this
training um so I asked that the uh
committee look at this and and and
um help us in being assur
that all pertinent people that see the
children on a regular basis um have this
training in order to identify uh abuse
or
neglect thank
you would you take questions would you
defer to I'll I'll go for it I'll defer
okay Miss Gladstone actually I believe
she has a card there several several
knowledgeable people in this
Advocate who is a social worker and not
a
lawyer good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the child and family law
committee for the record my name is
Cassandra Sanchez I am the child
advocate for the State of New
Hampshire I'm here today in support of
House Bill
1590 and I wanted to share with you an
experience that my office had in
reviewing some cases is involving abuse
and neglect of young babies over this
past year so starting between February
and June 2023 the office of the child
advocate identified nine cases of
non-ambulatory babies that presented to
emergency departments with broken
bones after finding these cases and
working with the medical
community it was determined that two of
these cases the babies had been brought
to their pediatrician prior to arriving
to an emergency department
one of them had been seen by an
emergency room doctor before being seen
by a pediatric specialist in child abuse
and neglect whom all those three the two
pediatricians and the initial Ed doctor
none of them called in abuse and neglect
to DCF for these babies and in each of
these cases the babies had multiple
broken bones not just one many of them
six or more
ribs in the work that we did we worked
very closely with
DCF um who worked very quickly to try to
gather medical records work with the
hospital that did ultimately file and
act protectively and file in court in
some of these cases because of the
initial doctor visit they were not
successful in court and ultimately the
children were returned to the home of
the the parents which it was unclear who
the perpetrator was but it was known in
all of these cases that the two parents
were the primary caregivers of the
children when these injuries
occurred given the large amount of these
that occurred in such a short period of
time the office of child advocate held
what what we call our system review
mappings and so what we do with the
mappings are we um present pre- inters
with folks that have been involved in
some of these cases and then we bring
together Professionals in the field
staff from DCF um these also included
medical professionals and law
enforcement in in the specific mapping
that we did in August
2023 and the hope of this mapping was to
come up with some recommendations to
ensure further protections of these
types of cases in the
future what we learned during the
mapping was that training for medical
professionals was not always mandated
and was a current need that exists there
is also some other legislation that you
will see this session that also stem
from this um there's two Senate bills
Senate Bill 459 that Focus on the
presumption of harm with babies with
broken bones as well as um Senate Bill
472 which talks about the
multi-disciplinary team and looking for
a study committee to ensure that those
teams can communicate and share
documents fluidly to ensure the safety
of children and so those along with this
house bill would help address the issues
on cases like these we know these are
just a handful of the cases that come
across DCF or don't um if medical
profession the initial medical
professionals don't recognize abuse and
neglect and so we are truly hoping that
this training can be mandated so that
all providers who are oftentimes the
first Contact for children who have
serious injuries are trained and are
able to recognize these injuries and
call into the agency so they can act
protectively I am open to any questions
thank you representative Raymond thank
you um thank you for Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question so um
um 100 years ago when I worked for DCF
it was the DCF um workers who were going
out and talking to the doctor's offices
and stuff who does the training
now there is the no andell training um
which is hosted by the um New Hampshire
Alliance I'm sorry I'm going to be
blanking on their acronym right now um
which is available um and is voluntary
training um I do I do know in working
with DCF that they do have staff that
does continue to meet with the medical
community as well um again on a
voluntary basis so a lot of the
hospitals are open to inviting in dcyf
to do those trainings to talk about what
they're seeing in the field um and my
office as well has been called in to
some professional groups to talk about
what we're seeing in the field of abuse
and neglect um but because none of those
are mandated it's who has the time and
the interest to call in those follow up
follow up do you know what other states
are doing are there is there like a a
medical associ a or some you know agency
that would provide these type of
training for you know for example
doctors it's hard for a social worker
with a bachelors or a masters to tell a
doctor what to look for sometimes are
there you know certified groups or
licensed groups that do it well I can
speak from my background I'm working in
Massachusetts and in Massachusetts
doctors are considered mandated
reporters and so they are required to
take the mandated reporter training and
um stay up toate on the mandated
reporter training and so that is
something that was required there that
anybody who is considered a mandated
reporter which would be a professional
level including doctors would take and
then they could Outreach the agency for
additional supports but the at minimum
we getting that training and it was
required thank you
yes representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for speaking um
to this bill I just had I'm sorry I this
really hit me so just give me a second
to remember my
question
um regarding the training um who decides
what's uh AC acceptable training um for
example somebody um might say oh I'm
taking this online training course but
who is actually going to say that's an
acceptable level of information that's
given like who is going to be um in
charge of deciding what's acceptable
training and all also who else is going
to be in charge of keeping the records
of people who
are who are um require mandated required
to to take these trainings that is a
great question I do not have the answer
to that question so I'm going to defer
okay medical professionals of those of
you who have signed up on pink cards the
first one who knows the answer please
say so thank
you representative
panck thank you uh chairman for allowing
me asked my question and thank you for
taking my question um I had a
professional license and we were
required to do ceu
hours uh we'd have to have 12 ceu
hours uh every two
years
uh why we why are you asking to have
years I don't have the specifics as to
why it was requested every two years I
am in support of the request for every
two years because it is important to
stay up to date um information changes
on child abuse and neglect that's
something that my office spends a lot of
time being trained on ourselves to
ensure that we are constantly in the no
and so being updated every two years
would ensure that as research changes as
information changes they would get those
updates as well follow follow up okay
thank you um I see that in the budget
all right um um the first year is going
to cost
$25,000 the second year it
doubles um I don't understand why it
would double in one year um just looking
for the
explanation I would have to defer that
question as well I'm not sure the the
budgeting
amount anyone
else thank you for your testimony thank
paradox no one listen to
you turn on the mic please thank
you my name is gwendaline Gladstone this
is my colleague Dr
oral I'm a retired child abuse
pediatrician we have evaluated thousands
of New Hampshire children with concerns
for abuse and neglect we're here to
describe a pervasive problem in New
Hampshire that endangers children who've
maltreatment thank you Wendy good
afternoon my name is re M oral I'm the
medical director dor of the child
advocacy and protection program at
Dartmouth for The Last 5 Years in my
career and tenure at Dartmouth I have
seen many children who presented to
Medical providers either in Primary Care
setting or emergency rooms with all the
signs and symptoms of child abuse and
neglect but their diagnoses and
recognition of child abuse was sorely
missed as a result result of which they
were injured and harmed and suffered uh
from pain I would like to give you a
couple of examples for instance a
four-month-old
infant uh had had 12 visits to their New
Hampshire primary care provider uh since
one month of age for failure to gain
weight repeated bruising signs of head
and mouth injury and rectal
bleeding at least on four of those
visits there were very concerning
complaints from the parent and findings
that the primary care provider
documented but they still failed uh to
file a report with DCF and simply
accepted the implausible explanations
provided by the
caretakers thus the opportunities to
report to DCF were sorely Miss missed
and eventually the infant at 4 months of
age presented to an emergency room with
malnutrition diarrhea onethird of the
tongue torn from the bottom of the mouth
from the floor of the mouth that
required surgery and a Severe gum
laceration and the infant is now 17
months a of age in fostter care uh
with uh injuries uh to the mouth that
will affect dental health and with all
the pain that they suffered for four
months uh of duration we expect that
there will be long-term mental health
and physical health difficulties for
this
child this is a good example of how the
lack of recognition of obvious signs of
abuse and neglect and failure to engage
DCF result in escalation of injury and
ongoing suffering for the child which
may cause lifelong
difficulties cases like this are
unfortunately very common just as uh the
previous speaker uh relayed this is
because healthc care providers don't
consistently recognize signs of abuse
and neglect or or they inadequately
address concerns for possible
maltreatment with incomplete evaluations
or they don't report suspected abuse and
neglect uh to DCF at all I would like to
share with you another case
example and with both of these cases I
personally was involved I would like to
let you know a 5-month-old infant was
seen at an emergency room in New
Hampshire because of br bruises on their
back the child's caretaker attributed
these to someone else that was present
in the home previously an incomplete
medical evaluation was done by the
emergency room doctor even though at
such young age such unexplained bruising
uh represent Sentinel injuries that
should trigger a DCF evaluation and all
caretakers of the child to be considered
suspect
perpetrators uh this was not done and
the emergency room physician accepted uh
the uh explanations as fact and the
child was returned to their caretaker
only to return to an intensive care unit
with severe abusive head trauma findings
before DC
was able to get into the house at four
years of age now this child is living uh
with severe and permanent developmental
impairment they are bedbound tube fed
blind and dealing with a seizure
disorder this is another good example of
how incomplete work up by a physician
and acceptance of the caretaker's blame
of someone else to account for a very
young infant's injuries may result in
Failure to protect the child this
child's uh previous bruising injuries
would have healed perfectly fine had
this child not been return to the
concerning environment in their uh
household and avoided the devastating
outcome they are now living with these
are only two of many cases I ENC
enountered in New Hampshire some of them
died some of them survived like the
second case with major handicaps and
some of them suffered pain with residual
physical and mental health
problems and all of these outcomes can
be avoided if we are able to train our
medical providers who are the ones to
recognize child abuse and neglect when
these children Pres sent to their
clinics or emergency rooms and that is
why I'm here to ask you to take that
step along with my colleague Wendy
Gladstone uh to help the legislature
pass House Bill 1590 so that our state's
child health care providers complete a
recognized and accredited course every
two years this would mean we put
children's well-being first thank
you any questions questions for the
Grossman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you both for being here to do such
important work um really appreciate this
my question is currently in medical
school right
now is there any training related to
child abuse and neglect and I asked this
question coming from a parent with a
child with autism who who 15 years ago
was misdiagnosed because the training
wasn't quite there yet the way it is now
we also know child abuse and neglect
Education and Training has come a long
way into terms of educating our
community so in medical school is there
any and that may be 20 years behind but
is there any
training there is but it is only a few
hours long only to create an awareness
of oh children are abused even in their
homes but no skill set is provided to
either medical students or residents in
any specialty that they do in Pediatrics
as a result even a specialty uh trained
physician when they start working as a
pediatrician they don't have full
understanding of how to recognize child
abuse anding nect nor do they know
specifically how child protection system
works and what mandatory reporting
really means in New Hampshire but Dr
Gladstone may say
more um yes there already is training it
part of schooling is required by the
Council on medical education it's
required as part of training whether
you're a resident in Pediatrics or
family practice or advanced practice
nurse or PA physician assistant um as Dr
Ral pointed out part of the purpose of
this education is to provide uh medical
caregivers with specific skills how do I
talk to a child who makes a disclosure
during a physical exam how do I talk to
a parent I've been taking care of their
kids for years and suddenly I have to
say I'm concerned someone's mistreating
their child and I'm going to report that
to Child Protection agencies so these
are skill sets that are not typically
taught early on they're not part of the
annual education that hospitals require
their uh employees to take um we also
included in our recommendations that
providers learn the specific laws in New
Hampshire that are important to know
such as we have a religious exemption in
New Hampshire most providers get their
Education and Training in other states
before they come to work here they need
to learn how things go in New
Hampshire I would like to ask uh the
Doctor Who made the assertion that this
is not being done in medical schools how
many medical schools are you
specifically aware of I am parttime CEO
of a medical facility and I have people
uh Physicians and nurse practitioners
who've been trained in various places
and I think you made a broad
generalization
uh correct and uh that knowledge comes
from uh multiple medical schools that I
had uh professional experience in and um
I know what residency programs require
they are so packed with mandatory
training uh sections for residents and
for medical students as well child abuse
and neglect is learned by medical
students and residents only if they
elect to do a child abuse
rotation as they do in my hospital as
they did at other couple of universities
that I worked at uh and I have no reason
to doubt that it is any different in uh
other uh medical students and another
point that I would like to make I don't
know if this question is going to come
up or not but but uh most major
hospitals do have a mandatory training
for uh orientation purposes when any
employee starts to work in that
particular
facility but those trainings are very
limited too simply to remind the
employees that they are mandatory
reporters they need to file a report
with DCF when they recognize child abuse
and neglect and it stops there okay we
are going to need to move on we are
repeating ourselves and we have several
other people I do wish to hear from so
all right representative Raymond thank
you I'm sorry I have the thank you Mr
chairman I have the same question as
before is they are an
accredited um group agency whatever that
does this training so that if we were to
pass this legislation hospitals and
doctor's offices could say okay that's
that's the provider that's where I go so
that I can be in
compliance would you like to Yes um
there is currently a voluntary
accredited program in New Hampshire that
is specifically designed for health care
providers and specifically addresses all
the components we've discussed here it's
three hours
long um and there was a mention of a
proposed amendment to change the
language of this legislation from two to
three hours um the importance is that
whatever training is received is
accredited meaning it's evidence-based
on scientific principles and it's
recognized meaning that it's understood
that the materials covered address these
specific problems that we've identified
which is
recognition evaluation reporting and
understanding the laws in New Hampshire
I may have missed it but what was the
name of this organization who does this
the granite state Children's Alliance
which is the a parent company for the
network of child advocacy centers in New
Hampshire they were unable to come today
but we have a letter from them of suppor
in this Bill thank you and other doctor
I will need you to fill out a pink card
already okay thank you all right
representative
Nelson hello um thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question my
I asked this question before um I'm not
sure if um you um going to be able to
answer this um but who is going to keep
track of all of these medical uh
professionals to make sure they're in
compliance with
this um the bill states that the um any
provider seeing children in New
Hampshire who's a physician advanced
practice nurse or physicians's assistant
um will have this uh training be um
supervised or counted by their employee
we didn't tie it to lure because you can
come to New Hampshire and practice under
for example a nursing license that you
got in another state and so if you
already have that license you don't have
to to get additional lure in New
Hampshire um and that so we thought that
if we tied it to lure we would miss all
those people that's why it's related to
the employer not the Licensing Bureau
followup um I think this is great um and
I'm I'm I don't want you to think that
I'm knocking the bill I'm just a little
bit stuck on and thank you for thank you
for answering that but I'm just still a
little stuck on
how are we going to make who how do we
make um the employers the hospitals the
practices accountable to making sure
their people are complying with this is
there a a reporting system
to somewhere in HHS
or uh it is actually quite easily doable
because uh at least my hospital and I
suspect every Hospital in New Hampshire
has an orientation training program for
every new employee and we also have
learning modules that we have to repeat
every so often every year every two
years Etc so this training can be
integrated into the orientation training
and learning modules at every hospitals
uh in New Hampshire to start with at
least to Train everybody working for a
hospital and then uh we may reassess the
situation that is my Approach and
another question that was asked was
about CME
situation every medical provider in New
Hampshire is mandated to complete 100
credit hours of uh training to obtain uh
CMEs every every two years to renew
their
licenses and this training may be
integrated into that
mandate without our involvement at all
and without adding extra burden on uh
medical providers and as a result people
may not only obtain CMEs to their lure
but also get trained every two years and
be updated with uh renewed information
base doc uh representative Panic thank
you thank you chairman um thank you for
taking my question so you're saying that
every two years the Physicians and
nurses who need to renew their
Professional
Licensing will have this mandated
program and would that be overseen by
Bureau um the Licensing Bureau is not
specifically mentioned in the bill um it
is understood that it would be a
condition for
employment so that when a person joins
for example a hospital staff as Dr oral
has explained part of their orientation
requirement would be to take this
training and that
recertification would be required every
two
years okay I think I'm I'm a little
confused no we have other people coming
to testify I want to give them a chance
let me explain but that training as part
of orientation and employment can be
used toward lure to make uh providers
life
easier all right I'm going to thank
these people for testifying because we
have some other folks who have some very
impressive credentials here as
well and the chair would like to
recognize I saw him uh director fler did
he step
out he's
hiding he's hiding in the
is yeah very briefly uh when Cassandra
Sanchez uh of oier approached me with
this and highlighted this
situation it was appalling it was
amazing and that in this day and age
this thing could happen so just here to
say DCF is in full support of this bill
we'll do everything that we can to help
implement it in our and play our role
and just wanted to go on record saying
that uh um full support and and
cooperative and uh we'll do our part
thank you so much much appreciate that
uh chair recognizes uh Ben Bradley from
the New Hampshire Hospital Association
who is the worthy successor to Paula
menahan who's now on in retirement
sailing the southern
Seas thank you Mr chairman um members of
the committee my name is Ben Bradley I'm
the vice president of state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all 26 of the
state's Community Hospitals as well as
our Specialty Hospital hital um our
providers take their obligation and our
hospitals take their obligation to
report any suspicion of child abuse or
neglect very seriously hospitals require
training in child abuse and neglect for
all their staff upon hire and at least
annually New Hampshire Law requires any
person who any person not just providers
but any
person who suspects that a child under
the age of 18 has been abused or
neglected must report that suspicion
immediately to
DCF we agree that Healthcare Providers
are in a unique position to identify
children who have been abused or
neglected and support the programs that
our members offer to help educate
providers on reporting child abuse and
neglect um we do have a few questions
for the committee's consideration on
this bill and representative Nelson I
appreciate you bringing those forward um
particularly as it relates to the um
line 15 uh of the bill where it states
recognized and accredited training we
just asked the committee to consider
what constitutes this recognized and
accredited training and what Authority
determines the
qualifications of that recognized and
accredited training Additionally the
bill cites on line 13 all entities
licensed Physicians advanced practice
nurses or physician assistant provide
the training uh we just asked the
committee to question whether the this
captures all
providers um that you have
listed um or whether the employee
education mandate only applies to some
providers and not others depending on
their work
Arrangements um again we are very
supportive of ensuring our hospitals and
providers um report on child neglect and
abuse um and thank you for the
opportunity to share our feedback on
this important issue I'd be happy to
take your questions U Mr Bradley going
back to that point on line 13 all
entities employing I'm one of those but
I also know that there Standalone still
in this day Standalone Family Practice
Physicians and increasingly Standalone
nurse practitioners advanced practice
who are their own employer and are you
suggesting that perhaps line 13 may be
addressing those folks that we're not
capturing or we couldn't that's my
question Mr chairman yes thank you good
rosan thank you thank you Mr
um we're ensuring that the hospitals are
reporting but what about the training so
we all want to ensure that reporting is
happening but what we've learned is that
there isn't the proper training
happening to identify
and so what do you what's currently in
practice right now that is providing
training we all know that we're mandated
reporters but currently right now what's
in place well our as I mentioned in our
testimony our hospitals do require
training in in this child abuse and
neglect um upon hire and annually um so
I feel hospitals do cover that training
um somebody and actually in the Preamble
of the um bill it talks about voluntary
uh training that's available publicly
available for providers um but notes
that few participate in it um that may
be because hospitals use their own
mechanisms to provide this training
versus what's the public uh volunteer
training uh let me follow up on that by
asking the question um this training and
this training and there could be
training to be aware that such a thing
as child abuse occurs there could be
more thorough training that shows uh
what to look for um how do you respond
when you see a child continually be
readmitted that could be it's a
9-year-old boy who likes to climb and
fall out of or it could be Abus so to
what degree is the hospital uh training
for new hires and annually how far do
you go my understanding is that training
is very comprehensive
it provides for um not only recognizing
but also how to report um but I'm happy
to get you additional information I
would from our from our members I'd love
you to be able to show us what the
training even if we could have an
outline of the trainer's script or
something that would be wonderful if you
could do that for us uh I'll see what I
can find thank you uh representative um
deimon thank you Mr chairman and thank
question you've said that
hospitals provide the
training my first part of my question
is is
it a a specific accredited training or
is it a training that the
hospitals bring together all by
themselves um I will look into it but my
understanding is that it is um you know
a a
um appropriate and accredited or or um
recognized training for providers
and yep go ahead thank you for that
answer just as a
followup
um I know that in in order for an
employee uh and currently it uh
according to this the training is
voluntary but I know that for an
employee to um maintain employment with
any agency whether it be dealing with
children or not they have
to fulfill a uh sex harassment course I
find
it
shocking that
all entities who employ people who deal
with children under the age of
18 don't have
to be it isn't a demand that they
file uh go through this training do you
feel that the hospitals will uh be more
consistent if this bill were to
pass um I I think from what I understand
from our members and the information
I've gathered they are consistent in
requiring this training for their
members or for their for their employees
as I noted in my testimony upon hire and
annually one final one final thank you
Mr
chairman so they fairly consist is what
you
said I'm I representative my
understanding is these our our members
provide upon hire and
annually training on child abuse and
neglect all I'm asking is if there could
be some consideration for clarity in the
bill
on what constitutes accredited and
recognized for training uh maybe
something worth the committee's
consideration and um how the bill
approaches Who falls under the
requirements as it states all entities
employing so with that you would be in
support of this
bill um I just need Clarity I I need
clar I think we can be we're very
supportive of ensuring that there is
training for these providers on child NE
neglect and
abuse um and I think that some clarity
around these questions would be helpful
for our additional support on this Bill
thank
you I want to pick up on uh what I'm
sensing is one of your points and if if
it isn't I'm going to round it out
anyway um that I have seen
training that was accredited by a
recognized accreditation
Bureau be less than a training program
that was not accredited for any number
of legitimate reasons but it was far
superior so the question of accredited
and you know the the the buzz phrase we
throw around now evidence-based which to
me is shorthand for don't answer
anything else I've played Trump cards
now um I would like to know what your
program is what it consists of I think
it would be uh very helpful for me to
know what our hospitals are doing in
this and if you to provide that I'd
appreciate it understood thank you
Bradley saying nothing thank you so much
and uh welcome to the hot
seat I have a card and I cannot quite
read the writing but it's I do recognize
the ZIP code so with the card writer
from Atkinson New Hampshire please come
up up well this is on another bill I
think uh this is boy I've been doing
that all day but nice to meet you sir
and we'll see you again real soon okay
thank you uh with that I have no more
lost
okay okay the confusion is it's in the
same handwriting and it says Dartmouth
Health children's to both people
and you can write like somebody else can
write or they wrote the card for you
anyway who are tell tell us who you are
you thank you so much for um having to
speak um dear members of the committee
child and family law um my name is Ru
alal and I am a physician Ru alal that's
what you wrote okay wow good thank you I
I will admit that a colleague wrote that
for me as I rush to use the restroom
coming from another uh meeting no excuse
necessary thank you um I just want to
start off by saying I I know this topic
can be triggering and um if you please
just take care of yourself if you need
to step out for a moment or you know
take a break I think that we all do this
especially those of us who work in the
field um and so just as a reminder um
please take care of yourself um so as I
told you my name is Dr Ru Gupta olal I'm
a physician at Dartmouth Health in nsha
um I grew up in New Hampshire I hold a
medical license here and I am board
certified in Family Medicine in addition
to uh providing and delivering Primary
Care I've also worked in the fields of
urgent care as well as substance use
disorder over the last three years I've
been providing specialized Medical Care
in the and evaluations for children when
there is a concern for abuse and neglect
therefore I work very closely with DCF
child advocacy centers law enforcement
um the attorney uh you know the district
attorney and county attorney's offices
and um have been doing testimonies I'm
here to speak in support of House Bill
1590 so I thought I would pivot a little
bit from what I initially prepared to
just um address a couple of U really
wonderful questions that have come out
of the discussion so far um many of
which have been answered but
particularly I know that Mr Bradley
brought up um you know a couple good
points about what you know what is the
accreditation and and you know the
hospitals do provide um something and is
it different from what it is being
spoken of so having been a Dartmouth
employee which is in Dartmouth is as we
know the largest employer in in New
Hampshire but also one of the bigger
Hospital systems and works with um many
of the other Hospital systems and I
closely work with Elliot and Southern
New Hampshire and the other Hospital
Systems as well um so as an employee
every year I do an annual attestation as
well as um an annual training which I
believe is similar to what Mr badley was
speaking of that consists of about six
or seven modules ranging for topics of
cultural
competency um sexual harassment in the
workplace uh interestingly hepatitis A B
and C transmission um Dawning and doing
of gloves and masks and then a couple
other smaller items that usually get one
to two slides one of which would be
child abuse and being a mandatory
reporter as we all know which is also
the case for any adults in New Hampshire
not just um Healthcare Providers and on
that one or two slides um would also
include dcf's phone number and this is
how you know and you should make your
report what is not included in those
couple slides in the training that I've
received annually as a Dartmouth
employee um is what signs to look for
what are inconsistent statements so if a
a parent or a caregiver or a um you know
anyone bringing the child says oh yes
this injury um happened because of you
know the kids were playing with Nerf
guns and d d d d da and a provider might
say well that I guess I maybe that makes
sense and sometimes it really does make
sense and sometimes it does not make
sense so those types of nuances also you
know a a baby who cannot yet walk or
crawl should not have certain types of
injuries a toddler who is unctious and
falling all over will likely have many
bruises on their shins but they should
not have bruises behind their ears they
should not have marks on their neck um
they may have bumps and little golf
balls on their foreheads but there are
other places that would they will
unlikely have those injuries and some of
these things you've heard the word
Sentinel
signs those are the types of things that
can actually be delivered in content
material within a few hours at least in
an abbreviated way that can be very
helpful for um providers of Health Care
to then use as knowledge to then provide
the appropriate care whether or not a
referral to dcyf should be made or is
this something that we're going to say
hey let's you know get an x-ray you know
on our own and and see maybe you know
maybe it was this soccer injury whatnot
um so I go off script a little bit just
to address that because I believe that
and and and to also give you this
background that there is a a three-hour
module that was spoken of there's also a
longer module that um many of uh the cap
providers so cap is child advocacy and
protection program and we're a small
group of nurse practitioners um
Physicians social workers childlife
Specialists nurses and we do the
Specialized Care in New Hampshire for
children when there's concern for abuse
so um several of us providers actually
participate in giving this education
live to Hospital Systems clinics and
whatnot when they voluntarily fault sign
up for it we just see that not a lot of
people are doing are signing up for it
and I think that's why this bill is
really important there are other
accredited courses that exist and
absolutely those two hours um can be
done in many different ways it is true
though that there's this there's this
one course that happens to be here in
New Hampshire that would fit the bill
and give that knowledge um and is
accredited by Dartmouth Health um so to
go back and just share a little bit of I
had planned um where it's relevant you
know we do know that there's about a
quarter of a million children under the
age of 18 in New Hampshire and most of
them do see a a health care provider at
some point whether it's for some sort of
urgent reason or hopefully for well
child checks which doesn't always happen
but most kids are seen we know that most
kids are regularly seen by teachers and
in school systems and so that is another
place that you know identification can
happen however in a healthcare Cent
doctors and skin being literally the
largest organ in the body doctors are
well equipped to make critical decisions
um and with information that's presented
in front of them to say hey yes this
might be a concerning sign or this is
not and so with that education and that
background even as a refresher every
couple years it's sort of ready and at
hand um I am you know I have a two
children with chronic medical health
issues I have aging parents I'm a
patient myself and having been a
physician for 20 years I can confirm
what you already know that we don't have
a lot of or Physicians don't often have
a lot of time to address issues that are
not sort of the presenting factor or the
main um topic of discussion for that
visit so if there is a finding that is
that has nothing to do with why a child
or an adult has come to a visit it it
can be hard um for that person to just
sort of out of the blue pull up unless
they've had sort of recent regular
training on um you know physical exam
findings or in congruent statements with
injuries that's those are the the
opportunities that they have if
something's at the tip of their mind to
be like wait this might be something
concerning and they don't need to make a
diagnosis of child abuse they just need
to refer to DCF who is then able to do a
thorough investigation and bring
resources into the home I mean I think a
lot of some of what the misconceptions
are in in when in my conversations when
I talk to other providers is that many
people forget that DCF in our state has
wonderful resources that when provided
early for families can really make a
huge impact in how that parent guardian
or whoever may take care of that child
and and have the their own abilities to
do that so that's sort of an opportunity
that I think we we sort of forget that
we have um I appreciate your time thank
you very much and I'm open to any
question questions that you may have
thank
you seeing none thank you Doctor seeing
one thank you
representative thank you thank you Mr
chairman um thank you thank you um my
question is rather broad um we um have
um authorized Licensing Board in for
Physicians here in New Hampshire as uh
well as we have a medical society and
I'm just surprised that something like
this needs to come before the legisl as
opposed to being created within the
system itself I mean that's what it's
for that's why we do licensing and so
that they can police themselves in a
sense you know anything about that or
has this come before the board or the
society so I think this is a wonderful
question I think one of the things that
we see in medicine and this is true kind
of back to the medical school question
is that there are so many different
areas and topics and there's very little
sort of real estate and time for all the
different things that could be covered
um there are however a few things that
touch you know no matter what specialty
you're in so the currently out of say
the hund the hundred um hours of
continuing medical education every two
years as a cycle for both physician
assistants and and licensed Physicians
three hours need to be on opioid use
related matters and so that education
those three credits or three hours need
to be spec specific to that otherwi wise
the other 97 hours can be generalized so
as far as I know and I haven't been a
part of so the short answerers I haven't
been a part of those conversations what
else can we make mandatory but what
we're seeing is that there's a lack of
education on child abuse even though it
touches every field so anyone providing
care under to a child under the age 18
whether they're gastron neurologist or
an asthma provider or a general
pediatrician or an ed doc
having that routine training and that
exposure will allow for them to have
that um sort of you know this is
something that none of us want to see
none of us want to find I mean you yeah
my point my point isn't whether we want
this or not right of course we want
consistency my point is why are you
doing this through rules rather than
through your Society or through your um
uh medical profession your Physicians
board as opposed to com to the
legislature and putting in a
statute that's a fair question that I'll
defer to those who have helped write
this bill um so I don't know that I can
answer that directly thank you okay yeah
thank you representative it seems like
we're caught between a rock and a hard
place on the one hand we get yelled at
when we tell the professions how to run
their profession but on the other hand
we've got professionals coming to us
saying tell us what to do yeah so the
question I wonder is to what degree has
all this test testimony been given to
oplc or Board of Medicine or the medical
society saying hey we got a big problem
we need to do this ourselves and why
does it wind up here am I on track with
you there if I may may yeah yeah thank
you I do think though um one thing to
keep in mind where I can't answer that
question directly I do know that several
other states do have similar legislation
in place um where they are um you know
having the mandatory training and at
some point where you know this is the
state that we are all a part of and you
know help to take care of um and live in
there are you know we're seeing a a
system failure of some sort and wherever
and whatever it may be the the answer
that may be right for the medical
societies across the state of the you
know the the nation of the United States
may not still still be adequate enough
for one state or another and in New
Hampshire what we're seeing and and I
don't I I don't want to make assumptions
as to why it's in New Hampshire because
it's definitely there in other states
but other states have also made progress
to put in legislature to support such
mandatory training so I don't think
we're the only state to um be addressing
it in this way um okay we're going to
have to wrap this up thank you so much
for your testimony I appreciate it I am
one ing uh researcher if we could find
out what states have this by law as
opposed to their Boards of medicine or
oplc equivalents have done this so with
one9 and also we would uh representative
deimon would like to know if there is an
accredited course that the American
Medical Association and I would add the
American osteopathic Association has in
place on this subject that should be
pretty quick to to do and thank you so
much for doing this with that I conclude
the hearing on Bill
1590 and I don't think we want to
proceed with this because I've heard
there are some amendments floating
around so we will defer an executive
session is the 30th of the month if at
all possible so thank you so much now
where are we we are oh gosh we're all
the way up to 2
o'clock I open the hearing now on House
Bill
1199 relative to the services of the
office of child advocate for youth
experiencing homelessness and making a
an appropriation there for and the chair
recognizes
representative long the prime sponsor
representative thank you Mr
chairman uh representative long
representing Hillsboro District 23 in
Manchester uh House Bill 1199 uh was
brought to me early in the process um
through my experience in Manchester I
felt um often times
uh including the state we concentrate on
adult
homelessness uh because that's where we
see mostly of um and and youth
homelessness is is not really uh on top
of the page um I could say for my years
of uh being an alderman in
Manchester I've I've heard every year
the number of uh homeless youth in our
high schools uh that number in
Manchester is 6 to 900 and I'm always
I'm always told double that because
you're not getting a lot of them that
are uh that are going to qualif that are
going to tell you um and and uh I I
don't see enough being done for youth uh
I think in an effort to pick that up um
that the state should have uh somebody
who oversees that I like the fact that
it's the uh child advocate uh
independent uh from from the state uh or
independent from uh any other entity um
I like the reports I've gotten from the
child La thus far not always uh
reflecting nice on me but I want to hear
the facts and not you know not what
makes me feel good I want to hear what
the truth is so I I I love the fact that
uh if this committee approves it that it
would be going to the office of child
advocate um and youth homelessness is a
um something that I believe the state is
addressing any questions for the prime
sponsor seeing none chair would like to
[Music]
recognize representative Panic with a
question thank you chairman um thank you
taking my question I'm a little confused
on the cut off age um we're looking at
in other bills uh you're of age of at
age 18 in in special education you're of
age uh at age 22 and in this case you're
of age up until age 25
so we seem to be all over the place with
that I think that we've got a narrow it
down to when are we considered adults at
18 uh we can vote at 18 we can go serve
our country but according to this bill
at age 25 we're still considered a
youth um my also my concern with this
bill is that um that's my only question
at this point in time thank you okay uh
so the way I could respond to that is
different scenario call for different
expectations as far as age goes um you
know I know a 24y old well a youth
experience in
homelessness under 18 uh has a high
likelihood of being homeless has has an
adult if you want to identify an adult
has 18 however somebody who's under
25 um you know we all know that brain
function um so I I think it would be
beneficial to us um to address from my
to address from 25 and under uh and not
go 18 and under um because at 26 and
over uh the states we still going to be
paying our tax dollars to address that
so I think it's easier in addressing it
at a younger age than when they're more
any other questions for the prime
sponsor seeing
none hearing none chair recognizes Holly
Hampshire good after afternoon chairman
Pearson members of the committee I will
try to be brief because I know that you
are running behind um my name is Holly
Stevens and I'm the director of public
policy at Nami New Hampshire which is a
Grassroots nonprofit
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy on behalf
of Nami New Hampshire we are I'm here
today in support of House Bill
1199 lack of access to Safe stable
housing um has a profoundly negative
impact on the mental health of
individuals especially of Youth um as a
result suicide has been found to be the
leading cause of death for youth
experiencing
homelessness um multiple protective and
risk factors have been linked to the
concept of resilience which is
understood to be the capacity of an
individual to cope successfully with
significant changes in their lives
protective factors include social
connectedness relig oity social support
internal locus of control and positive
emotionality the position that is um
would be established if this bill was
enacted um in the office of child
advocate would be one that would look at
all of these resources that are
connected to these protective factors
factors for these uh young uh kiddos um
so if this position was established then
the youth who are experiencing home
homelessness could be connected with
social services that would then um
potentially reduce their risk for
suicide um and this is the reason that
Nami no Hampshire is in support of this
bill we do think that the office of
child advocate is an appropriate place
for this uh position um
because um they oversee existing
programs and that support homeless youth
um
and would be able to look at all of the
uh the gaps um and in the services that
are in existence today and with that I
will end my testimony and take any
have oh can I just mention one one last
thing uh mention one last thing yeah um
I know that the age was just asked about
and um we know that youth ages 10 to 14
suicide is the leading cause of death in
New Hampshire um but uh we know that um
18 to 24 it's the second leading cause
of death and we know that brains um
Contin continue to grow up until the age
of 25 and I suspect that that is one of
the reasons that the uh sponsor chose
that as the cut off
age good thank thank you thank
you and would like to hear from um
advocate
good afternoon once again for the record
Cassandra Sanchez the child advocate for
the State of New Hampshire um I too will
work to keep this brief for you um I
wanted to share as many of you know um
the role of the office of the child
advocate our mandate is to oversee
executive branch agencies that serve our
children and in part in our mandate we
are to assess those Services identify
gaps and seek out um through advocacy
additional legislation that can help
fill those gaps and ensure the needs of
New Hampshire children are met um
currently we are able to do that through
um the children that are involved in our
dcyf system um so we do work and um
oversee the missing children that are
involved with DCF we do follow those
missing children and ensure that they
are recovered ensure that um the agency
is looking out for signs of trafficking
and other um high-risk behaviors in
these children when they are missing and
so we do have an aspect of this role um
when talking about children who are
missing or are homeless already but
again it is very specific to those
involved with our DCF system we know
that we have many more children in the
state of New Hampshire than those
involved in our system that are facing
homelessness or have gone missing at
some point in their in their youth um
childhood so given that um the expansion
and the added position in our office
would allow us to further look at the
homeless issue across the state we do
have a Statewide lens in all that we do
and so we are able to compare what areas
of the state have services that are
working well and then look at how could
we then expand those services to other
areas of the state um another critical
aspect of our office that allows for the
great work that we do is our
confidentiality we have the ability for
those um who are either experiencing
homelessness or missing they can
Outreach our office all communication
with our office is confidential as well
as those providing services to these
communities a big piece of this and the
importance of the confidentiality is
that that allows for folks to share
honest and transparent information with
our office they're truly especially
those that are providing the services
are able to share with us truthfully the
gaps that they see that they're facing
or that their agency um the barriers
that they have to truly providing the
service that they want to provide in the
community and this allows for us to get
a a a different grasp on the issue than
many of the other entities that are the
ones that are directly providing the
services or um have some some stake in
the game um Beyond just providing a
service and ensuring that those needs
community um and then also we do have
access through our U memberships on
multiple professional organizations to
um many others agencies like ours across
the country and we tap into those
professional organizations to look at
advancements or what other states are
doing um on these particular types of
issues to see what we could bring into
New Hampshire that is Affordable and we
know is already effective
elsewhere at this time I'm open to any
questions I'm seeing none thank you so
much thank
you chair recognizes Aaron George Kelly
from
Waypoint good afternoon chairman Pearson
Vice chairman long and esteemed
children-in-law committee members thank
you for taking the time to hear from me
today my name is Aaron George Kelly and
I'm the director of homeless Youth and
Young Adult Services for Waypoint I've
come to speak in support of House Bill
1199 as you know House Bill 1199
establishes a position within the office
of child advocate to identify and
oversee programs and services for youth
and young adults experiencing
homelessness in addition the office will
be required to consult with young people
who have experienced homelessness to
identify needs and accompanying
resources to increase prevention and
coordinate
Services Waypoint began providing
services to Youth and Young adults in
New Hampshire experiencing homelessness
or housing instability who were
disconnected from their families and in
1974 until
2021 Waypoint was the only organization
in our state providing these services
for Youth and Young adults it is with
these 50 years of experience that we
come before you today to respectfully
ask that you pass this bill over the
past three years New Hampshire has begun
to take action to understand the issue
of Youth and Young Adult homelessness in
our State through this work we have
gained some knowledge of the number and
needs of Youth and Young adults
experiencing
homelessness we better understand the
true scope of the issue and some of the
causes we also know that a number of
young people aging out of child welfare
and Juvenile Justice whether from foster
care or institutional placement will
experience homelessness in their young
adulthood and that a number of youth
living in poverty will continue to be
unstably housed throughout their early
adulthood there has also been some work
done in New Hampshire to determine what
a system of services to to prevent and
end Youth and Young Adult homelessness
would look like and small pockets of
that system have begun to emerge but
even with this work we have not done
nearly enough the number of Youth and
Young adults experienced ing
homelessness in New Hampshire continues
to grow Waypoint operates the only low
barrier emergency shelter for young
adults in our state we opened in October
of
2023 and we have 14
beds every night since we have opened we
turn away an average of 28 young people
looking for a safe place to sleep those
young people resort to sleeping outside
or in their
vehicles in addition Waypoint currently
has 77 youth on our priority list
waiting for a bed in our Transitional
Living Program and during this last
weekend storm our dropin Center in
Manchester saw 30 young people in just
one
day providing housing and services as
soon as possible to these vulnerable
young people is one of the strongest
prevention measures to end chronic
homelessness and to ensure we have
healthy successful adults you've asked
for three minutes you're going way past
it and you're reading and we can read
too so wrap it up please
okay this opportunity with the child
with the office of the child advocate
would provide the 30,000 foot view that
New Hampshire needs to make sure that we
are examining the strengths and gaps of
existing systems identify and bringing
together relevant stakeholders and
departments in ways that truly create
impact and change and positively impact
these vulnerable
individuals this opportunity will also
allow the office to explore funding
entering into the state for this purpose
and advocate for further funding for
services across the Spectrum including
community- Based Services and supports
for the Department of Health and Human
Services over the past 50 years
waypoint's homeless Youth and young
adult programs have grown from two
people with a backpack to program
serving 55 communities in New Hampshire
with 75 staff but we cannot do this work
alone the issue requires our state to
take a closer look and a greater level
of responsibility and House Bill 1199
does just that and voting yes you are
allowing some of New Hampshire's most
vulnerable Youth and Young adults to
have have a voice thank you for your
time and attention to this important
matter and I'm happy to take any
questions anybody with a question to
make her happy boy I wish I had one love
to make you
happy no great testimony great testimony
we'll read the
written as well thank you chair
recognizes Ariel Hayes from the New
Hampshire youth success
project
and if you have
it hello thank you very much for having
me today good afternoon chairman Pearson
and members of the family law committee
I'm here in support of HB 1199 as well I
am the current director of
sustainability with the you success
project and I served as the Director of
our org for the last two years I have
lived experience with homelessness as a
22-year-old and I was a case manager at
Waypoint with their runaway and homeless
youth program for two years as well um
the New Hampshire youth success project
is a board of young people who have
experienced unaccompanied homelessness
in New Hampshire while under the age of
25 and when I say unaccom that means we
were without a parent or Guardian while
we were experiencing homelessness um and
the youed to success project Works to
make sure that Youth and Young adults
have a voice and a say in these issues
that impact us most directly and we
believe that we both have a right to
have that say and that our systems are
better and stronger when we are involved
in decisionmaking that impacts us um we
work closely with the Manchester and
balance of state continuums of care
which work on ending homelessness across
the state and have been involved in
creating the coordinated Community plans
to end youth homelessness in New
Hampshire um and we were also very
involved in the youth count survey
creation um you are receiving info
sheets right now with some of the main
findings from that and it was also cited
in the bill itself and while this survey
was delivered to 18 to 24 year olds we
asked the
1,476 respondents that we got responses
from in October 2022 to reflect back on
when they first experienced homelessness
and that median age was 16 so we have a
lot of young people who are experiencing
unaccompanied homelessness without a
parent or Guardian before they turn 18
and often times they are not being
connected to Services until they turn 18
there's a lot of reasons why that might
be but fear and lack of knowledge about
what they're experiencing as
homelessness is likely a big part of
this um a little bit about Youth and
Young adult homelessness we often
describe it as invisible because young
people again don't always know that what
they're experiencing is homelessness and
we're really good at flying under the
radar we know how to shower and fit in
with our peers and really fly under the
radar if we're living in a car or
staying with friends um which can make
it really hard to see the effects of
Youth homelessness until it often
evolves into adult homelessness or
chronic homelessness is and this bill is
really an opportunity to interrupt that
early by providing with young people
with supports um young people are also
an especially vulnerable population of
folks experiencing homelessness because
we don't necessarily have the survival
skills to keep ourselves safe um we
um we have a lck a lack of knowledge
about the systems or are just scared of
involvement especially for young people
under 18 and this can make us especially
vulnerable to things like
trafficking um it's also really hard to
regain stability because we don't have
rental history we often have poor or bad
credit um and it can make it really
challenging for us to compete in a
rental market okay you're way over your
three minutes requested so I'm going to
ask give you a half a minute to
summarize okay perfect um lastly this is
an opportunity to prevent adult
homelessness this is a critical age
where we can turn things around and the
you success project is excited to
partner with the office of the child
advocate we feel like this is a good
place for this position to um live you
have 11 more seconds I think that's all
I have you're really kind are there any
questions yes representative Greg y
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here and taking the question and
also for sharing your story so you did
say that you were home correct M that's
only half my question um what made the
difference for you I was homeless for a
brief period of time and what really
made the difference for me was that my
family's in Arizona and I had financial
support which a lot of young people
don't I was able to get help getting a
security deposit on an apartment and
helping me get a car when I didn't have
access to them if those two things have
fell through I wouldn't have been able
to keep my job and my homelessness would
have lasted much longer but unlike many
who have a genuine but theoretical
compassion for the problem you've lived
it correct yes yeah anyone
else thank you so much thank you and the
hi
good afternoon thank you chairman and
members of the committee for hearing my
testimony today um my name is Emma
savini I'm the children's Behavioral
Health policy coordinator at new Futures
new Futures is a nonprofit nonpartisan
organization that Advocates educates and
collaborates for the health and wellness
of all Granite Staters um today we are
here in strong support of House Bill
1199 um for many of the reasons in fact
all of the reasons you've already heard
um I would just like to highlight uh the
component that addresses youth mental
health um when children experience
homelessness or youth experience
homelessness this is considered an ace
or an adverse childhood experience um
adverse childhood experiences are
traumatic events in childhood that can
have really long and dangerous
consequences long into adulthood um
these can include mental illness chronic
health problems um substance use among
other really serious
consequences um experience ing
homelessness in youth is a risk factor
to contribute that contributes to having
higher Ace scores so when somebody
experiences more than four aces in their
life they're much more likely to have
those severe consequences I just
described um s uh concerningly youth
experiencing homelessness um are more
likely to have caregivers who are
incarcerated have caregivers who are
experiencing mental health issues or are
experiencing substance use disorder all
three of those are Aces
um in addition when children are living
in poverty including experiencing
homelessness those um risk factors are
compounded and so they are more likely
than their peers who have um Financial
Security to have Aces long term even
with parents who are you know similarly
experiencing mental health issues or
substance use disorder or are
incarcerated um the good news though is
that there are protective factors to
that can reduce one's risk for those
severe consequences down the line one of
the most impactful ones is connecting uh
youth with safe and sustainable housing
um so House Bill 1199 is a great first
step in creating uh a system where our
children can access safe and sustainable
housing um through navigating systems um
that they may be involved in um we also
really appreciate that this position
would be situated with the office of the
child advocate um I think it's important
that the the position is able to nimbly
navigate um both the criminal justice
system the Health and Human Services
System the education system um
homelessness touches so many aspects of
life and I think this the office of
child advocate is really well positioned
to be able to access all of those and
the other systems that a child may be
experiencing as a result of their
homelessness um so all of that is to say
that new Futures would strongly urge the
committee to vote a to pass and I'm
happy to take any
questions any any questions good to have
you back thank you thank you and with
that I close House Bill 1199 there being
no more pink cards and I would like to
do the uh
straw the straw pole of thumb to see do
we want to move on this or do we want to
hold it for two or three more weeks uh
thumb up thumb down there's a thumb two
three four many thumbs we are thumb
full thank you for
that I love you I love your I love your
laugh representative all right so then
we uh now go into an executive session
for House Bill
1199 uh relative to Services of the
office of the child advocate for youth
experiencing homelessness and making an
appropriation therefore and who would
like to move the
bill representative long would like to
OTP long can I have a republican for a
second I saw representative Nelson's
hand flying up thank you Mr chair you're
welcome uh so there's the motion before
us OTP move by representative long in
seconded by representative Nelson when
you are ready the clerk may call Ro
isn't she doing a wonderful job you know
clerks chairman Pearson
yes Vice chairman long yes
representative deimon yes representative
Bickford yes representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
panic
yes representative sidel yes
representative grman yes
yes representative LC and representative
Patrina are not here representative
Perez is not here representative Greg
yes representative Molton is not here
representative Raymond yes that would be
12 y z
nay and it's got a financial note so it
has to go on the regular calendar and
with that uh we close the he the exec
session on House Bill 1199 FNA isn't it
fun to go to the hearing and discover
how it all turned out in the same day
huh yeah yeah all right let's
see we are oh now moving up getting
there uh and whoever um gave the motion
made the motion gets
the right you take the blur and that's
true on the previous one too yep you got
that good everybody's got the job doing
well all right I open the uh hearing on
House Bill 1282 FN relative to duration
of child
support
and the person who is doing such a
tremendous job as the clerk is slowly
making her way to the witness
table because she is the presenter and
um the chair now recognizes our very own
representative
all thank you
your bill thank you chairman
Pearson um this is a second go around we
already um this is in a really bad
spot we already um put this bill forward
last year um unfortunately it did not
make it pass the Senate because of A
Minor error and that was in one word
actually it's two words I use the word
benefit as opposed to the word child
support on line seven if you recall the
reason this came before before us was
because there was
um some misunder understandings of when
uh child support ended it said that when
the child completes High School
or reaches the age of 18 whichever is
later but in the scenario where a child
turns 18 say in January but then drops
out of school in April there is no end
date because they've never graduated so
that is what was brought to us by our
constituents and so we um as a group
came together we amended it so that we
followed the Social Security wording as
to when Social Security ended for um
when children receive
services and as I said because we took
it right from Social Security we used I
when we did this we used the words
benefits and the Senate wants us to use
the word child support on line seven I
did change in this presentation where we
said last year on line 13 we would said
we would go through age 22 to follow the
um special education law I changed that
wording because I sit on another
Committee of um for children gosh it's
been a long day and I'm totally brain
dead um you you are among friends sorry
um it was
the
represented the child on children
um yeah Child Care sorry the special
committee on Child Care thank you very
much yes and a representative I think it
was representative MC Beth came up with
this wording um she was concerned about
putting a specific age of 21 because
perhaps in the future that age would
change and so rather than putting the
specific word we would just link it to
um that RSA so that if that changed this
would automatically change as well
should it say at some point go to age 23
so that is the only um difference really
are those two words child support and
then changing how we determine um when
it ends if a child in in special
education
a those were the only two things I
recall last year that this passed
unanimously and I'm hoping that we can
move it forward quickly uh once again
this year since we were all in agreement
last year thank you any questions for
representative
ball well it was good last year and it's
good this year too thank you so thank
you so much well
um we're going to go into a 4minute
maximum here and if your speech is
longer than that you get four minutes so
you may want to cut out some things that
are not helpful if you have a very long
speech the chair recognizes Mr Robert
tangu to come on up and you ask for
three minutes and I'm giving you four
okay thank you um so uh I'll actually do
less than that and hope that you'll grab
me some cander in
uh
1595 uh so so I I am in support of this
bill uh it just clarifies the language
uh I feel like the language in the
original bill is or law is uh
restrictive saying that it ends when
they turn 18 and it this way gives it uh
more more more room um uh to do so and
uh it doesn't really seem like it will
have much of effect but it it will it
just it
just child support in my opinion um is
something that's kind of used as a tool
and it's uh brings a lot of funding to
the state and that's good uh for
taxpayers but the the money that comes
to the state from title for uh D is
coming from federal tax funds so it's
still taxpayers and uh I think that
child support causes contention whereas
each individual parent should be able to
choose how they spend their their money
on their uh children and family and uh
with that I I'll end it my coms thank
you so much wow you got two minutes and
12 seconds in the time bank for another
day chair recognizes Susan bristen from
dhh
sbcss three minutes to provide
information for us thank you we are
getting
punchy thank you Mr
chairman
um as a representative of DHHS bcss uh
the only two things I would like to
point out about this bill is that it um
calls to go into effect in 60 days and
as child support we would have to do
some there will be some training there
will be
some um you know computer type stuff I'm
just the lawyer of computer stuff I'm
like I don't know you know but
uh and I'm assuming the court will also
have things that they'll need to do
because suddenly it'll be it'll be
different so I think 60 days seems like
a short amount of time especially since
we're coming up on what they call
graduation
season where the issues of 1819 who's in
high school become a thing to that point
wouldn't it be uh appropriate to say it
is not 60 days from now but 60 days from
passage and if the house passes it and
the Senate passes it send the Spy over
to the governor's office and ask him if
he's going to sign it and if the word is
yes you can start the training and and
tell him to go slow with the pen and I
mean there's ways to do
this I have no official position on that
I'm not asking you for an official
position I would also point out that
there's no there is not an appropriation
for the changes made in this yeah well
other than that well I want to give you
as much time well this is there an FN to
it I don't have the FN but then again I
printed these bills out quite early
maybe there is one there is there is one
wow I all that paper I used and I never
got the fiscal notes so let me go
through this and that means it's going
to have to go over to the you know
who's uh division three of finance and
uh we're all going to become good
friends with representative Edwards
107,000 okay next
year so yeah there's a fiscal
note anyone with a
question seeing none thank you so
much and
uh way we go one more and now the
representative the gentleman from
03811 come on up
and yeah um is it Jay or Jim Jay sorry
Marshall marel I got almost all of
it and if you push the button that turns
your mic on okay thank you my name is j
marel I'm a practicing attorney and uh
with a high concentration in family wi
could you move the microphone now turned
on closer thank you okay is that better
much better oh okay thank you than you
uh my name is j marel I'm a practicing
attorney with family legal we're out of
conquered New Hampshire uh with about 25
experience 25 years experience
practicing in high concentration in
family law uh read the bill familiar
with child support guidelines generally
supportive only a couple of questions
that the committee might want to think
about um one is uh was the legislative
intent to include homeschooled children
in this as well as well and the reason I
ask is because um the languages is still
a full-time student at a secondary or
Elementary School at the age of
18 um if you my I respectfully point out
that there might be a question of law as
to whether this applies to children who
were homeschooled because they're not
really enrolled in school uh what
they're usually doing is they are part
of a if they're homeschooled they're
usually a part of a department of V tion
approved homeschooling plan uh so you
may just respectfully pointing out I
hope it passes but I would not want to
see any ambiguities in it and create
additional legal problems so I'm just
thinking you might want to have language
in there that is enrolled as a full-time
student um at a secondary or elementary
school or in uh New Hampshire Department
of Education approved homeschooling
program which would provide the same
congruent
protections um the those would be the
only only things the only thing I would
think of would be whether or not you
intend to apply this
prospectively uh or
retroactively uh So to avoid problems
with modifications I don't think there
would be a flood of it because by the
time if this comes comes to pass there
may be a small Gap you may see you may
see additional filings so you may want
to think about that and debate it
amongst yourselves otherwise I can see
the need for brevity and I'm done if
anybody has any question questions be
them seeing none but thank you for that
um they're trying to make me a lawyer
you know they're buying me law books and
putting me on legal committees and so on
and I just love the legal ability to
look at something and see we liberal
arts people will just say wow that's so
cool you know and a lawyer mind will
look at potential problems in its
specific so thank thank you so much for
bringing these pleas thank you for the
opportunity to address you I appreciate
it I have no more cards so this
concludes the hearing on 1282 FN and I'm
going to ask what do you think do you
think we want to uh ask a couple of our
members to come up with and I heard oo
and AZ from
this I'm looking at you but I mean from
you you can be part of that if you were
quiet okay that's fine
and you are um the prime sponsor if we
all think this well even if we don't
think it's a good idea you have the
right to get an amendment you may want
to talk to O and
ah and
quiet and see what they think and bring
it back and on uh you know if you bring
it back in a week or two we can do it in
a week or two it's not it's just let me
know no so uh we can uh notice it okay
one yeah go ahead so that that amendment
is just to the
uh
uh just to the effective date
representative Paul no there's two
things homeschools oh and home schools
okay is that what you want to work on
both of those things
The Homeschool one's easier to
understand the prospective retrospective
we may want to ask Council to elaborate
yes please yes chairman would you
elaborate please if you're calling me
back I am okay uh the prospective versus
retrospective um The Homeschool thing
thank you we're going to work on that
but the the second one we may need a
little unpacking of that oh okay okay so
in other words generally speaking unless
something is Curative okay it it applies
prospectively rather than than
retroactively so for example uh and you
usually see that in in in in the terms
of uh statutes which have to be amended
because of their constitutional
deformities and so for example sometimes
they apply things retroactively so it
might be worthwhile to State whether
this whether this statute itself
constitutes a basis for a modification
or not of a uh of present child support
of present child support
orders uh because I can see somebody
seeing this passing and somebody saying
well you know either uh he's 18 he's
going to be 19 it's going to be this or
that or you're going to apply it and you
know you can say well shall not
constitute a basis for a modification
and applies uh to new orders only words
to that
effect that it
pleasure I'm sorry yeah go ahead
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman I'm sorry I was just that then
leads me to the question uh if we if we
were to have an amendment that said that
this C you know shall not apply to
modifications does that mean that anyone
who has a current child support order
wouldn't be able to then go back to
court once it was enacted I'm sorry
could you please repeat that so
if if we were to say that it doesn't
apply to
modifications does that mean that anyone
who currently has a child support order
would not be able to go back to court
and have that modified no what it would
mean it would be basically in other
words if you're going to say in other
words you really don't want to turn this
I don't think it will happen but you
don't really want to turn it into what
amounts to I'll call
Floodgate you just don't want a flood of
people coming to court and saying I want
to change and and because we have
probably 60 or 70% of the people who go
to court are are self represented and
they may not have the same knowledge
okay they'll look at a statute and go oh
that applies whatever and you just don't
want to flood courts with uh
modifications that really aren't timely
uh most of the judges are overworked as
it is
right so in other words you know in and
of itself shall not be a basis for a
modification it should apply to new
orders okay if somebody is going to come
forward and you know they're in a
position where they either have to renew
an order for a very short period of time
that's possible you know I Can See For
example where somebody might say
um oh
they're in high school but uh they're
not going to graduate for a while or
something like that and I need to extend
the order that's certainly one thing
uh the other thing that I and I hope
I've answered that question just to
carry it one step further I have had
cases where and where this statute does
well to to cure the whole where I've had
19yearold high school seniors okay so
that order still applies because they
hadn't graduated high school so they
were so on that basis the last
occurrence of now you have 20 year olds
and 21 year olds believe it or not in
high school and the a child support
order in
effect so this is what that cures and I
think it's probably a good idea to do it
that way also Maine has something
similar to it uh where child support
will end at 19 the idea being you you've
had enough time to to finish school here
and that's really kind of
it thank
you representative thank attorney marel
could you return to the bench oh sure
okay don't leave yes oh okay uh just uh
two questions for your guidance sir um
if you're and this this one of a
speculation uh address if an individual
is uh already graduated like up to 25
years old right would there be a
retroactive Bill to be paid um only in
terms of existing orders so for example
it doesn't create a new obligation but
uh if for example somebody's 25 25 would
be kind of long out there
but if there was an unpaid child support
obligation it's still unpaid uh
basically if you look at a uniform
support order as they are now you'll see
that each order for payment actually
becomes an independent judgment as it's
due so you don't have to keep going back
to court all the time and then just for
point a CL followup thank Mr chairman uh
attorney Marcel uh that individual never
graduated well if he's that's the
problem with the current statute I think
that's what this is is meant to fix okay
so uh and that's the whole in the law
that this fixes this says that uh child
support will absolutely terminate by the
age of 19 years and two months no matter
what unless the parties agree to
lengthen it which they are free to do
okay and then one last one Mr chairman
um attorney Marcel you referred to one
other uh statement I was trying to check
my note real quick sure to be added uh
somewhere in somewhere in here and I
just if you would just restate that as
as to where would that narrative change
okay be placed and like the wording like
in what line would that where would that
go okay well I'm presuming you are
talking about
um let me get it out here okay so we're
talking about the approved um about the
approved
schooling uh if you're talking about
that I would say that um if you look at
line okay starting from the Roman
numeral
4 okay 1 2 3 4 and then where where it
starts on the left RSA 461b and then you
have the Bold or reaches the age of 18
years old unless the child is still a
full-time student at a secondary or
Elementary School at the age of 18
parenthetically I'm not sure where
Elementary School would be in there but
assuming it apply somehow and it might
uh or and then what I would write is um
enrolled in an approve in a new in a let
me just give you some
languag An
approved
uh a homeschooling program approved by
the New Hampshire Department of
Education and that would be my
Amendment but that that incl okay we got
I got that um would the charter schools
come
under if it's approved by the New
Hampshire Department of Education if
they're approved if they're approved but
would that Comm under uh when I say
command it's it's there's different
designations now okay on location so so
there wouldn't be in terms you know
Elementary you know High uh secondary
right but charter schools are Standalone
okay uh and want to see what your
guidance would be in that regard okay if
if a charter school is basically I'm
going to give you a diplomatic answer
here if a charter school is approved by
the Department of Education and its
curriculum is uh congruent with uh a
high school education program then it'll
probably be deemed a high school
education program uh high school
education see what I'm trying to head
off is this on appeal the New Hampshire
Supreme Court as most appellant courts
will hold okay is that the the new they
will will not add language to
legislation the legislature didn't see
fit to include okay and they always say
and it's could it's all the Appellate
decisions I've read and the appeals I've
participated in it's all pretty much the
same uh if this legislature didn't see
fit to put the include the language in
the statute we're not going to infer
it's there okay and they are the final
AR Arbiter of what legislative intent
was so that's the reason why I'm
thinking you want to get it in there so
child did I help did I did I answer your
question no thank you sir okay I think
we're good on that and thank you
councelor okay thank you very much
appreciate that with that I open the
hearing on House Bill
1595 adjustment of Child Support based
on parenting time medical support child
care expenses and we uh called to the
front the bills Prime sponsor who is
actually I called him to the front I
meant to call him to the witness table
bill
good afternoon my uh name is David
Bickford I'm here to introduce uh HB
1595 which is a about
guideline um uh and putting in parenting
time adjustments I'm not going to speak
to the technical parts of the bill I
will tell you that this is where
everything pretty much came from from
the New
Hampshire review of the child uh child
support guidelines which cost
$16,000 to get that review and the
reason the federal government has us do
the reviews because they want to know
how much uh deviation there is and if
there's much deviation we're supposed to
make uh uh changes in the child support
guidelines so uh
I worked on this with uh some other
people uh represent a majori is here uh
and uh he and I have become good friends
over this if you recall the first time
we met was right
uh and uh so I guess without further Ado
I will go back to my place and we'll
hear what uh the others have to say that
all right uh it a question from
representative d
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um what year was that
report this is uh the this is the uh
December
2022 report it's the latest report out I
have have I have all the reports
actually they happen every four years
and follow yeah followup and what years
does that include information
from well predominantly the last four
years but
over the spectrum of time but it's about
it takes a snapshot of what's going on
here in New Hampshire and they do go
back in time
here um and I can't remember just how
far um but they they make a number of
recommendations in here and one of their
major recommendations is to have a
parenting time adjustment so is it fair
to say that from 2018 forward oh they've
been saying that since I think 2004 in
that report every four years this report
comes out the last one
cost I think 50,000 something like that
thank
you
welcome would you be prepared to give us
the gist of the bill in about two
minutes or would you like to defer to
representative
me uh why don't we don't do
that
yeah in the sake of moving on the
technical stuff will come from a fellow
name of George uh Peace Corp and he help
devel okay I'm going to ask you to do
two things please number one is on the
way to taking your seat fill out a pink
card it's a good idea you have to do
that and then secondly pass me the pink
card and uh since uh there is only one
person on the pink card with the name of
George Pisco I'm going to call on him to
come down
cor peace core as in what the Kennedy's
got going right the peace peace SC like
the American peace SC that's what I
meant yes really fine fine polish name
yeah okay one second here uh yeah goad
representative bigford he's filling out
a pink C I know I or someone I'm trying
to take the notes and I got sidetracked
and someone please tell me what the name
of the report was the actual
you thank you for coming uh Mr pcore
would you please uh explain to us why
this bill should pass okay thank you uh
for the invitation uh Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
George pcore I'm here on behalf of the
National Parents organization New
Hamshire chapter and as representative
Bickford also uh to state it it's a
bipartisan effort together with
individual parents to uh for this bill
uh the bill has four components and if I
may I'll just talk to it rather than
reading the written testimony the first
two items are direct
recommendations of the last quadral
review the last two are uh supporting
recommendations to implement the two so
number one parenting time adjustment New
Hampshire is one of only nine states
that does not have a formulaic approach
to Parenting Time
calculation in addition New Hampshire
has a deviation rate of
40% probably the highest among all
states more than half of that is due to
issues with parenting time so there is a
challenge for us to have a
consistent method of calculating
parenting time uh that saves un legal
resources we are
proposing what's known as and it's a
mouthful 1.5 multiplier model cross
this mouthful is used by 22 other states
this is not rocket
science 18 of which use the 1.5
multiplier variant the 05 refers to the
assumption that fixed costs account of
cost
the the model has been
recommended by all parties that were
surveyed the last report parents lawyers
judges I think it was a second choice
approach by
bcss we have added two minor refinements
to the model to eliminate two known
shortcomings of this approach namely the
need for a threshold and Cliff effect
now Cliff effect and child support
guidelines is a large change in the
child support or order for small
parenting time uh
shift we've done
simulations and compared it to the
what's known as the best of class or
best of breed models and this approach
Compares very favorably we have provided
a graph in the written testimony which I
believe is uh
distributed the second approach or
second item is the consistent treatment
of medical support and child care costs
once again this comes right out of the
recommendation of the report which says
move these items from income deductions
to add-on child costs to be consistent
not only with income shares methodology
but also to reduce the disproportionate
burden on the
obligor the next item is the first of
the consequential changes to support the
first two and that is to
include obligor parenting uh sorry child
expenditures as part of the ability to
pay calculation so this is a technical
point right
now the difference between adjusted
gross income and self-support Reserve is
compared is used to determine whether
the original order should
apply but the obligor also has to meet
the obligation of direct expenditures
that's why it's
included the last point is the amendment
of the income shares methodology from
what I call a partial to a full income
shares
methodology uh I think representative
Bickford referred to a 2004 report I
think this was the HB 310 commission if
my mind uh serves me
correctly which identified that the
original intent to implement an income
shares methodology was done incorrectly
for whatever reasons so we are proposing
that this be
corrected so that all child costs are
calculated on a prated
manner based on the relative income of
both parents this is what the income
shares methodology is supposed to be
it's known as the proportional
contributions
principle uh the this is also consistent
in my recent readings of the Supreme
Court literature with the Anderson
decision which affirmed that New
Hampshire uses the income shares
methodology
prated for total child costs on relative
incomes so those are the four items uh
thank you for the opportunity to
overview them uh these are all technical
in nature uh and I'll be pleased to
questions
I give the committee a minute or two to
look through that report and see if they
have
any Mr chair May yes representative
Bickford um thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my my question you
started to say something about other
states and what other states have done
and I thought you said something about
Oregon and
California uh use this um you introduced
the bill you cannot ask
other you wrote us and told us what to
do yeah you either you either speak from
that table or you speak from that table
all right I spoke to you about that but
okay you don't recall I guess not now
wait a minute though is it are you would
you say that you really didn't do
anything except Hi here's the bill you
didn't argue for it over there right
then I'm going to Turn You Loose oh go
ahead sorry exception to the rule thank
you you're chairman I am that's why I
get the
money well anyway could you give us how
this fits in with the rest of the nation
or world you know what's going on what's
happening out there yeah uh well again
uh 42 states have parenting time
adjustment models half of them use the
multiplier model methodology that we are
proposing here with a
refinement uh three of them use what's
known as a sliding scale method this is
like varying percentage of Step
depending on the income it's the crudest
method uh but it has the advantage of
Simplicity uh States like Oregon Oregon
have developed a complicated
mathematical model which if you graph it
looks like an scurve and economists say
that's the way it should look
ideally uh in our simulations we
actually approach that very closely even
though the income shares model that's
been recommended sorry the multiplier
model that's been recommended in Prior
reports and the most recent reports is
what's known as a peace wise linear in
other words it's not exactly a curve but
it approximates a curve and I apologize
for the techie Babble but we are talking
about a technical issue here California
also is known as having a best of breed
model and in our hand out uh our written
testimony we have done a simulation and
they look very close so you're in good
company best to breed
good any other
Nelson representative
Raymond sorry I I reached my hand way
out hoping you'll notice it not thinking
it would be mistaken for a
representative dset so thank you Mr
chairman
so I know it's very late for math um but
my question is about how passing this
bill will impact um our families who
already have child support orders and
parenting time orders um so we recently
the house passed and who knows what the
Senate will do with it a an
approximately equal parenting time Bill
and then now we have this bill and I'm
wondering how um this will impact our
hundreds and thousands of families that
are having current support orders will
all of those people have to troop back
to court and do the form over again do
there does there have to be um like an
instigating event you know what I mean
in order to redo it will we I understand
the question completely if I may
interrupt understand it completely and
I'm internally chuckling because in our
working group meetings this is exactly
the issue that we discussed it's a very
important issue
uh section six of applicability in the
bill answers that that essentially it
would only apply to new bills or for
existing bills when they come up for
regular review which is three
years and
uh it says the ACT shall not constitute
a substantial change in circumstances
for purposes of the section in other
words people can argue well this is a
new bill and uh therefore I want another
crack at it the answer is no wait your
turn okay thank you I'm sorry I was
looking for Roman numeral six and I did
not find it thank you oh sorry as you
said it's it's late the day and we're
talking math so whether it's uh binary
or digital or Roman numeral anybody else
anybody else anybody else thank you so
much for your testimony and thank you Mr
chair members of the committee chair
recognizes representative Jim ma Italian
names isn't that right right what
representative ative D Simone is not
here but you are
so thank you Mr chairman it's a it's a
tough act to follow my pan over there
but uh that's a p that's a Pon ski there
you Pon ski there you go that's right
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee um for the record my name is
representative Jim majori representing
the great town of
Northampton um I come I come to this
bill in this information uh without
having any personal experience with
divorce separation or child care support
uh when I first learned about it it was
when I was first campaigning six years
ago so I started doing my
research uh started looking into what
has happened where have we been where
have we gone oh my goodness if you do
that research you'll go back to 1989 and
you will see at least representative
Bickford's name on
98% of those bills and I think maybe
even more than than that this is a this
is a subject that I appreciate this body
both bodies have spent an enormous
amount of time researching and in the
time that I have uh reviewed some of the
studies from 2 excuse me from
1995 2003 especially this one uh 2005 uh
especially this one from
2022 what I have noticed and what I want
to stress is that these bodies hours and
the one across the wall can I say that
do I say that here or can I say only
with a sneer only with a sneer the
Senate oo okay we have always relied on
the most valuable upto-date information
that we have we have always relied on
the technical expertise of the experts
who have testified and submitted that
information to us before we make those
decisions on how we are going to mend
our statutes and I feel and I have come
to learn from representative Bickford Mr
peace core and others on the working
group that we have been part of for the
better part of a year that this
represents the latest information that
we have to make the best choices for the
children and the families in our state
is it perfect clearly looking back again
as far as I could go on our website to
1989 there will always be an opportunity
to find something that is better but I I
beg of us that we do not discard what I
consider to be the best option right now
for what will we will never find which
will be the perfect I have come to say
that HB 1595 represents the best of the
information we have and I urge the
committee to pass this bill so that we
can send it to the Senate and and and
urge for their support also thank you Mr
chair and I'm happy to take any
non-technical questions or I will defer
numbers thank you thank you chair
gley good afternoon and uh thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
bear with me this is my first uh public
testimony so have some nerves so bear
with me um I have a written written
statement in favor of uh house build
1595 um so I'm just going to read
it and uh welcome to questions at the
end uh so I'm I'm here because I support
this bill uh because the New Hampshire
existing child support system is broken
and is a significant root cause of high
legal cost to nontraditional families in
our state uh families that have been
impacted by a divorce or just
non-traditional
families uh this bill will establish an
improved framework that will more
effectively and fairly ensure that both
parents are able to financially support
their children it will ensure that both
parents have stake in the financial
well-being of their non-traditional
family unit resulting in a net benefit
to New Hampshire children Children and
Families um I have personally navigated
the uh New Hampshire child support
system since uh 2016 2017 is when I
first was
uh uh separated uh and I've spent
thousands of dollars on legal fees uh
which I would have uh much rather gone
to my children's College savings
accounts um I've got two children uh 12
and 10 um earlier in
2023 uh most recently the cour issued an
order that resulted in me paying uh my
co-parent a full uniform support order
uh meaning I pay the same percentage as
a parent that has basically no custody
no physical custody of their children um
I however I have phys physical custody
of my children uh 50% of their time I've
had that since day one uh of being
separated um I coach their sports teams
I furnish a bedroom for each of them I
buy them clothes I drive them places I
feed them take them on vacations uh
purchase toiletries medicine gifts gifts
for their friends gifts for their
teachers um I also pay um 75% of their
outof pocket Health Care um I save for
their college so on top of those
day-to-day fixed and variable costs um I
pay 20,000 over $20,000 a year in child
support to my co-parent um after taxes
and and payroll reductions I take home
less than $65,000 per year which the
$20,000 is pulled from um that means
there's nearly four months of the year
that I work before I start earning money
for my household um I've never missed a
child support payment I've never been
late to make a payment um I would never
you know allow my children to live in
poverty as long as I can help it um I'd
be happy for my kids to live with me
100% of the time um my co-parent not to
get into a lot of detail about this but
they have a a bachelor's degree from the
same University as I do they graduated
in the same year as I did in fact we
worked for the same company um the
company that I still work for uh before
they decided to stop working and change
their career path uh my co-parent has
had the same opportunities as me and the
same degree of Education in much broader
local Family Support Network but due to
the to to career choices uh they learn
less income than I do um So within the
framework of our existing system they
have limited incentive to earn more
income due to the money they receive
from me after taxes so this Dynamic puts
an unfair burden on uh the higher income
parent in co-parenting families like
mine who ultimately support two homes in
some cases uh despite having pretty even
capabilities Mr gley you asked for two
to three minutes what am I at you are on
a roll um so and and it's all good stuff
I just about done I got one paragraph
I apologize for that I go ahead so I I
just wrap by saying the existing system
in New Hampshire that families are
dealing with uh to anyone who
understands Equity fairness the system
is obviously not working it's flawed I
hear from many friends who dealt with
this and people are talking about it uh
so I think New Hampshire owes it to
Children of divorced parents to to fix
the system so thank you thank you and if
you don't mind if you could submit your
testimony to the clerk because we file
these things I meant to print out enough
copies I just didn't have time so I can
happy to email the copy if you wish but
if your hard copy could go to the clerk
all printed out she can put it in the
folder and and believe me uh I'm told
that down the road sometimes judges when
they're trying to decide something want
to know what the legislature was talking
about and it's not just us it's you
folks and these documents sometimes come
into play great so good thank you thank
you chair recognizes um also from
Atkinson and also named Jay marel thank
you Mr shair Esquire yes thank you sir
um I've looked at this bill this isn't
the first time I've seen it and um in
its in different forms and just by way
of background I've been involved in
legislation uh one way or another since
about
2015 uh involved in drafting and
reviewing
legislation uh one of the challenges
here is the inherent and let me just be
I'll be brief uh New Hampshire if you
look at RSA
A14 has never linked CH uh the
percentage of time that a parent spends
with a child to the to a child support
order it never has um the parenting
rights and responsibilities act has been
around since about 2005 in various
considerations basically the support if
you look at section one is that after a
filing uh Court shall make such further
decree in relation to the support and
education of children as shall be most
conducive to their benefit in order a
reasonable provision for their support
but what you do is you now create a
tension between the amount of parenting
time and what's most beneficial for
their support and one of the other
problems that I've said and by the way
in doing this I've re I've reviewed
child support uh guidelines across the
United States I would also recommend for
reading is child support application and
guidelines by Laura Morgan it's
published by Walters Clues I have a copy
of the second edition which is the
latest it's about this thick and it is
she's one of the leading Authorities on
child support and how it's implemented
across the United States um to address a
couple of things first of all we do have
a lot of deviations and which means from
the guidelines and one of the problems
that I've seen is is that there's almost
nothing that really works for everybody
100% of the time so I would agree with
the proponents of that legislation the
problem is is that child support
necessarily becomes so individuated to
to develop these supports and I realized
what Washington DC did years ago in the
early 80s to try to bring in guidelines
and the precise problem is with a lot of
the changes such as joint parenting and
so on and so forth it just creates
problems and the best way to solve them
is to really create individuated
Solutions what the good part about what
this bill does is is that it tries to
dis it tries to undo one of the problems
with the Sila case I don't know if
you're familiar with it okay that was
the one that um the Sila case was the
one that created I'm not going to say
created problems because the New
Hampshire Supreme Court simply dealt
with the legislation that it had and
said this is what it means so what it's
done here which is positive which is if
tries to eliminate the impact uh the
unfair impact of a full guidelines order
on people who have joined custody so
what this tries to do is say okay if we
take a certain percentage and we go like
this and we use parenting time we'll be
able to come up with a fairer order I
get that but the problem but what you're
doing is you're creating an inherent
tension here between the first part of
uh 468 461 A14 and this remember this
461a is the parenting rights and resp
responsibility act that's the overall
architecture for parenting rights and
how we raise children remember that the
child support guidelines are merely the
mechanism by which child support is
calculated so what we're doing is do we
want the na so the parents are supposed
to drive the car they're not supposed to
have the car drive no matter what
everybody says about Elon Musk they're
not supposed to have the car driving
itself it's not there yet um what I
respectfully recommend is this can be
improved I think I think it needs to be
made a little less complicated I think
it needs a little more study I can also
agree that the uh child support
guidelines are widely perceived as
unfair uh to a lot of people and one of
the reasons why is because they have no
upper limit in the state of New
Hampshire other states they do uh but
that's kind of where it is I'll be happy
to entertain any questions if anybody
has
them
um representative bigford thank you uh
Mr chairman yes sir thank you um the
upper limit is not an issue with this
bill is it this well it still is in
other words you don't have an upper
limit here okay what you do is you have
a mechanism for calculating the
guidelines but uh you don't have I'm
going make sure I'm getting heard okay
but you don't have an upper limit in the
bill so for example if you have somebody
making six or seven or eight or 900 or a
thousand 100 or uh 3/4 of a million
dollars a year uh you know you get the
guideline and that's your number
uh there you know there should be an
upper limit to it there is currently in
the child support statute uh they try to
avoid unnecessary confiscatory and un
unreasonably low orders right okay but
there is no upper limit to it right okay
we I'm sorry go ahead we we tried to
follow the recommendations here and I
don't recall that being one of the
recommendations yeah and I'm I'm
familiar with the reports that UNH did
if those are the same reports yeah four
years before right okay I'm familiar
with those and I've read them and I I've
read them when they first came out
so Dr Smith yeah I think so and they
have some good points in it and the
things need to be changed but I think it
needs a little more study uh I've been
dealing with these things for quite a
while and um nothing will satisfy
everybody uh one of the things that we
had that were works well most of the
time which is called the child support
offset which deals with shared
residential responsibility which was
working well for years and what you did
which doesn't include this and it works
well most of the time which is where you
take parent A's income parent B's income
take the difference and then if you have
shared residential or approximately
equal residential responsibility parent
A's income parent calculate the
guidelines as if parent a pays parent B
calculate the guid line says if parent a
pays par parent B pays parent a then
figure out what the difference is and
the and the difference goes to the lower
earning parent okay that's one thing
that works most of the time and usually
with some adjustments you can get
equality uh where the CH where the where
the child which is one of the goals is
to make sure that the child has an
approximately equal standard of living
in both households which is what the
point of the guidelines are okay and
that's what the point of the um that's
what the point of the statute was so I'm
not trying to be convoluted it's a
compli it's a complicated problem I only
have a few minutes I get it I'm only
thinking that you may want to study it a
little bit more and you may want to make
some fine tunings to make sure that it
can work thank you so much for your
testimony appreciate it uh for the
committee remember um we do not have the
option of retaining the bill to work on
it over the summer all we have is the
ability to say this bill has Merit for
future legislation or this bill does not
so since this is an early bill this has
to be out the door by Thursday February
15th which means for us it's Tuesday
February 13th so uh I will listen we we
will take testimony happily take
testimony from the two remaining people
who signed up but uh I'm not going to
suggest that we um execute today I am
going to suggest that if uh you wish to
work further with the prime sponsor and
the other sponsors feel free to do it if
you want to do it very informally you
may do that as you wish if you wish to
gather some people together that becomes
a work group and it has to be noticed in
the calendar uh it has to be gotten to
me to get into the calendar to have a
room set aside for that you may do that
if you wish but uh those are the
parameters of what we have with this but
under the last day this will ever be
looked at by US unless you want to do
interm study is February 13th
representative Bickford uh thank you Mr
chairman um we have another similar Bill
coming up at the same time next week
right and it would be best if we didn't
send two bills with the same thing right
forward so I am certainly open to trying
to marry them together into one bill
doesn't matter to me who the sponsor is
as long as it moves
forward Okay let's listen to the next
one next week and see what we want to do
after that and along the way to that we
have two more people because there are
some good things in it I think that we
could use yeah I mean chair recognizes
Mr Robert
tangue who asked for three minutes and
I'm going to give you five minutes and
sir that means I got to find my
watch okay you remember you
side when you when you turn these in you
should have the bill number on it so it
doesn't get lost in the it'll be okay
it'll be
okay
yeah
well he's getting ready to do that so it
doesn't count against his time I think
the clerk might like to have somebody
help her with this pile of stuff here so
we can make packets for the
representatives who weren't here patrino
and LC um if somebody would be willing
to do it it'll probably take you about
10 minutes sprawl it all out also I want
to uh uh make sure that I get a blur but
committee report on 1588 from
representative
whom on me my
desk oh it needs to come to me for
approval first okay and also eventually
representative ball in 1598 so if we can
find
that I'm asking for her
blurb on 1588 it has to go to me first
for approval I'm just
okay I know we're remembering the ways
to do it that's
okay okay are you ready I am rock and
roll okay um so what I just passed
around was this uh document right here
here's a picture of me from my LinkedIn
profile um with a note and uh it's
basically just to show the contention um
that comes into play with family court
matters and a lot of it's over money and
financial resources and basically child
support is a big candy bucket that gets
awarded to one party and it's typically
the party that
um has the
kids and when
that's assumed to be uh typically a
mother um that is part of what goes
into
basically
um causing families to break up breaking
up a family is a big deal it's it's such
a big deal that it's it's been shown in
um the child's uh the uh title 4D grant
money uh and it's taken very lightly now
clip if you what I'm
sorry
I just didn't know providing a photo or
anything like that would be helpful you
guys just have your process do you have
one or I do okay well what I'll do is
I'll just leave it leave it as is and
let them know that you do have a photo
if necessary um and are you available on
this number the 8058 number absolutely
yep okay this is the domestic violence
Coalition can reach out to you if they
think that that's necessary to get it
from you so
much
M we suspend for a minute point of order
uh Mr chairman I don't feel like this
has anything to do with the
bill we need to speak directly to the
bill not to the global issue uh of child
support this is based on adjusting the
support
guidelines so so what happened you can
hit your mic back on again please thank
you I apologize um so what happens so
that's on October 31st first what
happens is when someone decides to end a
relationship it's always one person one
person decides to end a relationship and
break up a family and they do that
assuming that they will get the
kids and get the child support money and
um if you listen to that audio that
audio before the point of order was um
it was describing that the domestic
violence Coalition had a picture and
they actually sent a picture to the what
you're looking at is a picture of me
with some criminal defamation and a
letter uh for me to describe that how I
got that at the governor's office all
those videos are on there so I do
support this bill um as as giving a
reason uh to
guide as amount the amount of time that
you have with someone instead of just
uh
having a
financial
incentive uh to not work as you heard
previous gentleman stated he he works
full-time he makes he makes money and
then the partner will choose not to work
so their income goes down they get money
and that should be adjusted by the
actual costs of time and and money
raring uh this bill doesn't solve
everything um but elves a lot and so and
I'd also like to speak um a little bit
more about as I brought up in a previous
bill um 1955 the uniform support act
came out we codified it in laws RSA
546 um I do recommend that we do put
that if you guys are going to talk about
this more put that on the financial
guidelines worksheet RSA 546 A5 when
determining the amount due for child
support the court shall consider all
relevant factors including standard of
living and the situation of the parties
relative wealth and income of the
parties the ability of the obligor to
earn the ability of the oblig to earn
and the need of the O oblig the age of
the party is responsibility of the
obligor for the support of others if
they have other children we've made
these laws if you read the laws they go
back in time they make sense lots of
people had to work on them vote on them
and discuss them before they came out
all the way back back to the Inception
of RSA 461 parental rights and
responsibilities uh there's a lot of
contention when you hear lawyers speak
and testify they make a lot of money the
more contention the more money they make
and they use that and you can see it in
my case specific I can show all those
details and I've brought them all to the
people's attention yeah got one minute
and 20 seconds to go sounds good so it
it's important RSA 546 1945 uh 56 sorry
55 uniform support act there are special
circumstances where they can deviate
from that however they're hidden and
they should be put on the form with the
child guidelines worksheet also uh RSA
C which is currently in law requires
that the person seeking child support
shall file a child guidelines worksheet
they did not do that in my case yet the
judge ordered child support to generate
a rear ages and um you know the point is
is
judges lie in New Hampshire lawyers lie
in New Hampshire and nobody does
anything about it and if we are able to
pass a bill which I do support this bill
uh to remove the candy bowl from uh the
person who is ending a relationship and
breaking up a family I think that is a
good thing thank you so much on time
under budget and with a smile thank you
last card questions oh yeah well I'm
sorry there questions I know you guys
are tired and and I would be too I was
afraid it was going to be all about
numbers and columns and things but that
was the last okay
anybody nope thank you so much thank you
okay and the last card I almost said Guy
Lombardo it is the end of the day Greg
Lombardo any relation
no that's all right well Emma savini is
not related to Chloe either I just lied
about
it so hello my name is Greg Lombardo I'm
in favor of this house bill um 1595 I
have a similar scenario to the guy send
him up to my left I forget his name
unfortunately but um again I'm a
divorced father with two little kids
ages four and six I've had 50/50 equal
shared parenting since the beginning of
my divorce parenting plan established
with the 223 equal shared parenting
however I'm forced to pay full guideline
child support I have the exact same
burden of child rearing as the mother
does she supplies nothing for the
children when they were with me 50% of
the time all while she has 100% of the
child rearing funds meant for both of us
have we need some sort of syst system
that provides and allows both parents to
have equal or approximate equal
parenting time to have proportional
income to do so having the lower earning
parent end up with 100% of the funds for
child rearing does not make sense with
the kids um when the kids are provided
for and taken care of equally or
approximately equal by both parents
that's it all good thank you so much any
questions
anybody representative long has a
question thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you Mr Lombardo uh could you could
you give me a brief look at what your
5050 parenting time is is is it
overnight 5050 is it actual time it's
actual time 5050 um so it's called what
I people call it is a 223 so it rotates
every other week so basically every two
days we swap and we have every other
weekend we swap so I have them the exact
same time that the mother does okay and
uh follow up if I make yes the higher
earner is I'm the higher earner you're
you sing none thank you so much for your
story and sorry here after
Sundown uh with this uh don't leave
anybody we've got um a few things if
that's testimony that can go to uh
certainly one copy for the clerk and um
this ends the um hearing on House Bill
1595 don't go any where anybody please
we have a couple of things that we need
to do very briefly uh representative
Mary Jane walner remember back one
o'clock um was uh had some papers she
wanted to share with us she made limited
copies there is a stack of three from
her here and if you're interested in
those papers she referenced you can come
by and pick up what you want
Representatives while supplies last I do
I did promise that we would look to see
whether we want to exact this bill or
not do we want to do that or do we want
to ponder it and have some amendments
down we're not ready I wasn't either but
I wanted to give you the chance now I
was also told um that over for the lunch
hour people said that they might want to
look at representative Bernard's Bill
House Bill
1425 about suspension of driver's
licenses and I didn't give us a chance
to decide whether we want to move to
execu or not if we don't do it today it
has to be noticed in the calendar in the
future I can't just roll it over so do
we want to go forward with executing
representative Bernardi's Bill about
prohibiting suspension of driver's
licenses in child support enforcement
matters or not thumbs thumbs I think
we've lost too many people unfortunately
uh we haven't lost if everybody wants to
we're still good but I just want to say
I don't think we're ready either but I
did want to give you that chance as
promised and the only other thing is I
need a report from representative ball
and you can get it to me whenever you
have a chance to and thank you so much
for your your ran work today uh with
that uh this
um committee meeting is adjourned thank
you
all